THOUGHT TODAY WE'RE GOING TO BE
FOCUSING ON THE ISSUE OF
ENSURING A SAFE AND RELIABLE
GRID -- WE
CERTAINLY ARE A PLEASED TO HAVE
WITH US A TWO OF OUR MEMBERS WHO
WERE NOT ABLE TO ATTEND THE
FIRST HEARING --
SENATOR HANNAH BETH JACKSON
WELCOME.
AND WE ALSO LIKE TO WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SCOTT.
THIS MAYES FOR YOUR ATTENDANCE
TODAY WE KNOW THE DURING THE END
OF SUMMER WAS A LITTLE DIFFICULT
TO GET EVERYONE TOGETHER BUT WE
APPRECIATE YOU ALL BEING HERE
TODAY --
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN --
WITH -- THE
FOCUS OF THIS.
PRESENTATION OF BEING ON THE
ENSURING SAFETY AND RELIABILITY.
AND THE OUR PURPOSE HERE TODAY
IS TO TAKE A DEEPER LOOK.
AT THE WORK OF THE CPU SEE AN
ELECTRIC UTILITIES TO MITIGATE
FIRES AS A RESULT.
OF UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE.
I'M CONFIDENT THE VALUES
INCIPIO'S CPUC CAN FILE REVIEW.
AND APPROVE MITIGATION PLANS
WHAT I REALLY WANT TO HEAR ABOUT
TODAY'S THE WORK THAT WE CAN
EXPECT TO SEE ON THE GROUND.
AND WHEN WE CAN EXPECT TO SEE IT
DONE.
ADDITIONALLY.
WHAT DOES ON THE GROUND?
OVERSIGHT LOOK LIKE.
WHO IS DOUBLE AND TRIPLE
CHECKING THE WORK?
AND PARTICULARLY FOR VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT.
WE WILL ALSO HEAR FROM THE P. O.
USE TODAY.
THESE UTILITIES VARY IN SIZE
FROM SERVING LESS THAN A
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS. TO
DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND PWER IN
LOS ANGELES WHICH SERVES FOUR
MILLION.
ALTHOUGH THE PO USE EVER
RESPONSIBILITY A STATE LAW TO
DEVELOP FIRE MITIGATION PLANS
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE DEPTH
AND BREADTH OF THOSE PLANS.
I'M ALSO CONCERNED THE DUE TO
THE SIZE OF SOME OF THE PIER USE
THOSE UTILITIES WILL NOT BE IN A
POSITION TO PROVIDE THE LEVEL OF
SAFETY MEASURES.
THAT WE WILL REQUIRE OF THAT I
USE.
HOW WE ADDRESS THOSE GAPS?
I'D LIKE TO TURN TO A SENATOR
DODD.
UP FOR HIS OPENING COMMENTS AND
THEN WE WILL CONVENE OUR FIRST
PANEL -- AND
THAT WILL A TAKE PLACE AFTER HIS
COMMENTS.
I THINK YOU SOME A MEMBER --
TODAY'S HEARING TOPICS
CONCERNING ISSUE THAT I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON ALL YOUR LONG.
I BELIEVE ENSURING A SAFE AND
RELIABLE ELECTRIC GRID.
IS PRIORITY NUMBER ONE FOR
REDUCING UTILITY CAUSE FIRES.
ENSURING A SAFER GREAT IS ALSO
IMPORTANT STEP TO RESTORE
CONFIDENCE IN OUR INVESTOR AND
PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITIES.
THE GOVERNOR AND I HAVE PLACE TO
IDEAS ON THE TABLE FORGETTING TO
A SAFER.
ELECTRICAL GRID.
THERE MAY BE OTHER APPROACHES
TODAY'S HEARING WILL EXAMINE
THESE DIFFERENT APPROACHES.
THERE ARE ADVANTAGES IMPACTS ON
SAFETY RATES EFFICIENCY AND MORE
AND LOOK TO HEAR IT LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING.
A MORE IN EACH OF THESE ITEMS
[inaudible]
PRETTY SENATOR.
ARE WE WILL CALL FORWARD OUR
FIRST PANEL WHICH IS GOING TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF THE
MECHANICS OUTCOMES AND GAPS IN
WELL FIRE MITIGATION PLANS.
OF THAT WILL BE LED BY MICHAEL
PICKER PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
AND ELIZA VEDA.
MALASHENKO DIRECTOR SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
WE WELCOME BOTH OF YOU
[inaudible]
AGAIN [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THINK YOU A I'M MICHAEL PICKER
AND SOMEONE TO TALK REAL QUICKLY
ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IN
TURN HANDED OFF TO THE SEVERITY
WHO SKETCH OUT THE SCOPE OF WHAT
IT IS THAT WE DO SOME OF THE
LIMITATIONS.
AND THEN ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
SO PALM.
I THINK THAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT
WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S PUT FOR YOU
CAME OUT THE DAY BEFORE OUR LAST
HEARING SO IT WAS REALLY IN A
POSITION TO ADDRESS IT SOMEONE
TO TAKE A COUPLE SECOND JUST
KINDA RUN THROUGH.
OWN HOME.
WHAT HE CALLS?
FOR SO IN TERMS A WILDFIRE
PREVENTION TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL --
BUILD SIGNS OF WILDFIRE PLANTS
THAT ARE IN EXISTING LAW PUBLIC
UTILITIES CODE EIGHTY THREE
EIGHTY SIX ADOPTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWO THOUSAND S..
SIXTEEN AT THE RIVER AT THE
LEADER UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
SENATOR HILL [inaudible]
IT.
WHAT THIS?
PROPOSAL DOES IS IT TELLS US
THAT WE MUST ADOPT THOSE PLANS.
RATHER THEN REVEALING COMMENT
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
ADOPTION IS NECESSARY IF WE
WANNA TAKE OUR ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS --
HE ADOPTING IT MAKES IT
ENFORCEABLE BORDER RATHER THAN
JUST DIRECTION TO THE UTILITIES
--
REPORT THEIR PLANTS MAKES THE
PLANS ANNUAL.
THAT SETS UP GIVEN THE PACE
THERE WERE MOVING OUT HE
INDEPENDENT EVALUATOR SO THAT
WILL ACTUALLY TAKE SOME OF IT
OUT OF OUR NORMAL.
PUBLICLY EDUCATED PROCESS AND
PUT IT TO STAFF LEVELS STAFF
WILL THEN MAYBE PRINT TAKE THE
RESULTS OF THE REPLANT AFTER
IT'S BEEN EVALUATED TURN IT OVER
TO THE COMMISSION FOR ADOPTION.
WE CURRENTLY DO ENFORCEMENT FOR
NON COMPLIANCE BUT THIS SAID SO
MANDATORY ELEMENTS THAT ARE NOT
CURRENTLY ALONG INCLUDING --
PROTOCOLS FOR HIS DISABLING ONLY
CLOSERS DE ENERGY AS A NATION
THE NEW VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
REQUIREMENTS THAT WE ADOPTED
EARLIER.
THAT WHILE LAST SPRING.
HIGH INPUT INSPECTION IF
STRUCTURE AND THEN VERY
IMPORTANTLY IS THIS THE
PROTOCOLS FOR CONSUMER
PROTECTION IN RETURNING SERVICE.
AND WE'VE GOTTEN MUCH TOUGHER IN
A MORE DESCRIPTIVE ON THAT WILL
ACTUALLY DE CONSIDERING THAT FOR
FINAL ADOPTION HAD THIRD OR
THURSDAY MEETING.
HITTING CREWS WHO INCREASES OUR
ENFORCEMENT CAPACITY SO THIS IS
ALWAYS A TOPIC OF CONVERSATION
HOW MUCH --
ENFORCEMENT FINES AND PENALTIES
ACTUALLY GET THE KIND OF
BEHAVIOR CHANGES THAT YOU WANT
OUT OF PARTY'S --
BUT WE KNOW FROM OUR
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TODAY HAVE FOUND OUR
OUR CURRENT CAP A FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER VIOLATION PER DAY.
TO BE ABSOLUTELY INSUFFICIENT
FOR THE PIPELINE AND HAZARDOUS
SAFETY MATERIALS ADMINISTRATION
OF THE FEDERAL RAILWAY
ADMINISTRATION SO I THINK THIS
IS OUR RECOGNITION AND ARE IN
THE GOVERNOR'S EFFORT TO TRY TO
ACTUALLY GET US INTO MORE HONG
LINE WITH WHAT THE FEDS REQUIRE.
IN TERMS TO RATE PAYER
PROTECTION WILDFIRE POTENTIAL
COSTS ARE REVIEWED FOR
REASONABLE LISTEN THE RATE CASE.
AND THERE'S NO BLANKET AUTHORITY
OFFER OF WELFARE EXPENSE
EXPENDITURES IT REQUIRES
EVOLUTION OF THE SAFETY CULTURE
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT CAME OUT
OF OUR EXAMINATION OF GAS AND
ELECTRIC AFTER THE THE SAMPER
NOTE.
EXPLOSIONS THERE'S NO TOP THE
BOTTOM CULTURE AROUND SAFETY.
WITHIN THAT ORGANIZATION.
TOM WE SAW LOTS OF HIGHLIGHTS OF
REAL STRENGTH AROUND SAFETY
WITHIN P. GINNY BUT IT WAS A
UNIVERSAL THROUGHOUT THE
ORGANIZATION THAT CULTURE WASN'T
THERE THE YOU NEED TO SEE WHERE
EVERYBODY IN THE ORGANIZATION.
RESPONSE ON A DAILY BASIS TO
EVERY DECISION THAT THEY MAKE
WITH SOME CONSIDERATION OF THAT.
AND IT ALSO INCLUDES SOME SOME
OF THE REFORMS FOR THE LEGAL
FRAMEWORK FOR FOR WHILE FAR
LIABILITY.
YOU CAN SEE CONTINUES TO ENSURE
THAT OF THOSE WHO ACT
NEGLIGENTLY OR HELD LIABLE.
IT'S MODELED AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT SIDE
JURISPRUDENCE FOR FLOOD CONTROL
DISTRICT'S IT ALLOWS THE COURT
TO WEIGH THE REASONABLENESS OF
AN INVESTOR OWNED UTILITIES
DECISIONS.
AND SO MY OBSERVATION IS THAT IS
PRETTY MUCH WHAT I SAID EARLIER
THIS YEAR AND SYNONYMOUS THAT --
HERE DIFFERENT LAWYERS GIVING
DIFFERENT OPINIONS ON HOW HOW
MUCH WE CAN ACTUALLY DO IN TERMS
OF GIVING DIRECTION TO THE
COURTS UNDER THE INVERSE
CONDEMNATION PROVISIONS OF THE
SAY CONSTITUTION.
BUT MANY ATTORNEYS NOW TELL
IMMEDIATELY EAST AND HAVE HAVE
ADVICE THE THROUGH
CONSTITUTIONAL FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO ACT AND IF
THERE'S GOING TO BE CHALLENGES
SOME OF THE UP TO A COURT TO
DECIDE -- SO
THOSE ARE THE KEY FEATURES OF
THE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS
GOING TO TAKE SECOND TO KIND OF
RUN THROUGH THAT.
AS IT TURNED IT OVER TO LISA
CENTER TO QUICKLY TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT OUR POLICY FRAMEWORK
--
FOR HIGH UTILITY WILDFIRE
PREVENTION.
AND THEN WE CAN GET INTO YOUR
VERY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK OF AND HERE
TODAY AGAIN.
POEM.
I THINK YOU SHOULD HAVE THE
PRESENTATION.
IN FRONT OF YOU --
THAT OUTLINES THE POLICY
FRAMEWORK [inaudible]
NO.
OKAY OUT WELL I AM GOING TO GO
THROUGH WITH MAKE SURE THAT YOU
HAVE ACCESS TO IT OF LEADER NO.
BUT THE EL THEN THE FUNDAMENTAL
--
SO ASPECT OF IT IS YOU NEED
THREE L. COMPONENTS FOR A WILD
FIRE VOWED TO TAKE PLACE.
WELL YOU NEED FUEL --
YOU NEED IGNITION AND THE L.
SOURCE [inaudible]
AND WHETHER.
AND SO AS WE THINK ABOUT THE THE
FROM POLICIES THAT WE COULD PUT
IN PLACE IN DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS
WHETHER IT'S GOVERNMENT THE
UTILITIES OR ANY OTHER AND CITY.
AND THINK IT'S HOPEFUL TO GO. TO
REMEMBER THOSE THOSE THREE
ASPECTS THAT BOTH DISCREET BUT
THEY ALSO IN IRAQ WITH ONE
ANOTHER HOME IN THEM.
IN ORDER.
TO ON ONE HAND EL CREATE THE
CONDITIONS FOR WILD FIRES BUT ON
THE OTHER HAND AS WELL.
ON THE MITIGATION SIDE WE NEED
ALL OF THOSE THREE COMPONENTS TO
BE --
WORKING TOGETHER FOR US TO
EFFECTIVELY MANAGE THOSE
THREATS.
NELSON THE FUEL MANAGEMENT SIDE
IN THE UTILITY CON SEX WITH
PRIMARILY TALKING ABOUT
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT.
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
GETTING FIDGET SEASTRAND ROUNDS.
BUT WHAT CLIENTS --
BUT THAT WOULD MANAGING THE MUD
SITUATED THEY DON'T POSE A
THREAT SO REDUCING THE FUEL
AROUND THE ELECTRIC O.
FACILITIES ON THE IGNITION
CONTROL THAT'S THE AREA WHERE
WE'RE FOCUSING.
ON EN EL THE INFRASTRUCTURE
ITSELF IS THE CAUSE OF THE
IGNITION.
SO SPARKS RELATED TO ELECTRIC
INFRASTRUCTURE ALICE THAT THIS
IS THE DOMAIN OF REALLY ASSET
MANAGEMENT OF UTILITIES HARD YOU
MANAGE LINES EL IN SUCH A WAY
THAT YOU ARE IDENTIFYING FOLDS
IN THE U. MINIMIZING THEIR
FAILURE.
CALM AND EVEN JUST UP OPERATING
THE EQUIPMENT IN SUCH A WAY THAT
--
DOZENS THOUGH BECAUSE IN THE
MEASURE MOST SIGNIFICANTLY
REDUCES THE CHANCES OF THAT
HAPPENING.
AND THEN THE WEATHER
PREPAREDNESS SIDE THIS IS WERE
WE TALKING ABOUT SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS WELL WITH THIS THE
STRANDS O. UNDERSTANDING HOW THE
CLIMATE IS BEHAVING AND GETTING
BETTER AND BETTER AT RESPONDING
TO THOSE CONDITIONS ON THE
GROUND.
SO AT THE AT THE VERY HIGH LEVEL
THAT'S THE IDEA BEHIND OF THE
FRAMEWORK IS THIS THREE
CATEGORIES AND LOOKING AT EACH
OF THEM INDIVIDUALLY AND THEN
UNDERSTANDING THE INTERPLAY
BETWEEN THE TOWN THOSE THREE
AREAS.
WELL.
THROUGH THE THERE ARE A FEW
EXAMPLES ALL TPC OF RECENT
POLICY ACTIONS INEACH ONE OF
THOSE DOMAINS --
THE UCBCP YOU SEE HAS BEEN
LOOKING UP WHILE FIRE SAFETY FOR
A LONG TIME AND SLOW LONG
HISTORY OF DECISIONS THAT --
HOST BE IN OVERTIME
STRENGTHENING OF THE REGULATIONS
IN CALIFORNIA THE BIGGEST
CHANGE.
YOU KNOW WAS ADOPTED BY LAST
YEAR WELL IT WAS A SET OF
REGULATIONS THAT MATCH THE WILD
FIRE --
HAZARD PLANS AND ALL THAT WERE
--
ALSO ADOPTED BY THE COMMISSION
BUT THE VIN SEVERAL OTHER
DECISIONS IN THE FROM
PROCEEDINGS AND STAFF ACTIONS AS
WELL SOME EXAMPLES IN FUEL
MANAGEMENT SO THIS IS WHERE THE
DECISION ADOPTED MORE STRINGENT
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
REQUIREMENTS.
REQUIREMENTS INCREASING OUR
CLEARANCE LEVELS FOR EXAMPLE
ROUND DISTRIBUTION LINES O. AND
VARYING THE REQUIREMENTS
DEPENDING ON THE O. WILD FIRE
HAZARD IN THE AREA [inaudible]
WELL.
IF THE EXAMPLES IN THE UTILITY
CONTROL SIDE OWE THE STRICTER
MAINTENANCE REQUIREMENTS
PATROLLING IN HI FI THREADS
OWNS.
รณ INCREASE THOUGH A CLEARANCES
BETWEEN WIRES THAT HELPS
MITIGATE WILD THE WIRE FEELY AB
ALSO JUST PARKS THAT CAN BE
CAUSED BY A OH WIRES FLYING INTO
EACH OTHER IN HIGH WIND
CONDITIONS.
CALM AND PUTTING REQUIREMENTS
AND PLEASE FOR INSPECTION OF
OVERHEAD COMMUNICATION
FACILITIES THAT WAS NOT IN
PLACE.
BEFORE BUT IT AND THE TOTAL
COMMUNICATION FACILITIES
THEMSELVES HAVE TRADITIONALLY
BEEN SEEN AS SOMETHING THAT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY CAUSE A
WILDFIRE THREAT BY IT BECAUSE
THEY ARE COOL A KEY TO THE
USUALLY WITH ELECTRIC CLIENTS.
IT'S ACTUALLY JUST AS IMPORTANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS AT
THE TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES
ARE MAINTAINING THEIR
TELECOMMUNICATION FACILITIES IN
THE SAFE MATTER NOT OVERLOADING
THE POLLS NOT APPROACHING THEM
IT'S ALREADY SPACE --
NOT CREATING CONDITIONS WHERE IT
FEELING OF LEE COOK
TELECOMMUNICATION LINE CAN THEN
BECAUSE OF FEELING OF ELECTRIC
LINE SO THAT'S WHY IT'S IT'S
IMPORTANT THOUGH.
IT WAS AN IMPORTANT PART FOR THE
PROCESS OF IMPROVING OUR
REGULATIONS AND THEN ON THE
WEATHER O. ON SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS SIDE.
BUT WE HOPE THE WILDFIRE MOPS --
AND THE G. EMERGENCY SOME POLICY
THAT -- ALL
HOPES AT ALL THE PROCESS THROUGH
WHICH UTILITIES CAN BETTER
RESPOND TO CONDITIONS IN REAL
TIME --
DE ENERGIZING LINES IS THE
LAST SO.
MEASURE OF LAST RESORT AT ALL
WHEN THAT'S ABSOLUTELY NECESSARY
HEALTH FOR SAFETY.
WELL I'M SO THAT THE JUST SOME
EXAMPLES.
WE KNOW PROVIDED A LIST OF OWE.
THE DECISIONS IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS THOUGH TO THE TWENTY
DECISIONS AND THEY GET VERY
TECHNICAL SOMEONE GOING TO GO
THROUGH ALL OF THE ALL BUT THOSE
ARE EXAMPLES OF ACTIONS THAT THE
COMMISSION IS STICKING EACH ONE
OF THOSE AREAS TO DATE
[inaudible]
HOME.
SO NOW I'M GONNA TURN TALKING
ABOUT MORE OF THE PRIORITY FOR
FUTURE ACTIONS AND WHERE WE ARE
AND WHAT'S SO OUR ASSESSMENT OF
WHAT THE UTILITIES ARE CALM
CONCERNS OF PREVENTION MEASURES
IN EACH ONE OF THOSE CATEGORIES.
WELL LISTEN THE FUEL MANAGEMENT
OF THE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT O.
TRADITIONALLY THIS IS BE IN A
THAT LARGELY MANUAL PROCESS THE
WAY IT'S WORKS OF THE UTILITIES
AND THIS IS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AND GLOBALLY IT'S AND THIS ISN'T
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC.
WELL PROCESS O. UTILITIES DIVIDE
THEIR TERRITORY IN TWO SECTIONS
OF THE HALL OF OF SCHEDULES AT
WHICH SHOW EVERY ONE OF THOSE
AREAS NEEDS TO BE INSPECTED THEY
HIRE A CONTRACTOR. TO GIVE THEM
THE MAP IN THE SCHEDULE AND SAY
YOU HAVE TO INSPECT THIS AREA ON
THE SCHEDULE AND THEN.
CALM.
AYE AND IDENTIFY ANY VEGETATION
THAT NEEDS TO BE MANAGED AND
THEN THERE'S THE SECOND SORT OF
LAYER OF WORK THAT SEEKS POLICE
AND BASED ON THAT INITIAL
INSPECTION A SECOND.
THE ROOFS SORT OF WORK IS DONE
WHERE WELL.
CREWS GO OUT AND ACTUALLY CUT
THE VEGETATION AND MAINTAIN THAT
SO IT'S A VERY --
AND LIEBERMAN SENSE OF PROCESS
--
ALONE IS INVOLVES A LOT OF ALL
BUT JUDGMENT BUT INDIVIDUAL BY
FOREST THERE ISN'T BY ARE BRUCE
WHO PERFORM THAT INITIAL
INSPECTION.
AL I HAVEN'T TRIED THIS OUT IN
PRACTICE BOY I THINK THAT IF YOU
WOULD SEND SEND THE FROM OUR
PERSONAL FORESTERS IN THE SAME
ROUTE THE RULES COME BACK WITH
VARYING RESULTS BECAUSE THAT'S
JUST HOW HUMANS WORK.
RATE WHEN YOU'RE EITHER YOU
VISUALLY PICKING OUT THINGS LIKE
CRACKS IN THAT FREEZING YOU
USING YOUR JUDGMENT AND YOUR
EXPERTISE.
SO.
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT A
HOME.
AND THEN THE SECONDARY PART OF
FORM THE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES THERE REALLY JUST
THERE TO FLIP FOLLOWING YOU KNOW
THE GUIDELINES OF HOW TO SAFELY
OF THE KATA REMOVER TREE.
ALSO THE REALLY OWE MORE OF JUST
EXPERTS ON HOW TO TRIM THE TREE
IN AND NOT NOT REALLY THEREFORE
IN ANY ADDITIONAL ASSESSMENT
PURPOSES.
AND ELM THIS THE THIS IS EXPENSE
OF WITH SPENDS AM.
A THING CLOSE TO PROBABLY HALF A
BILLION OF DOLLARS GO ALL OPRAH
RATIONS A MAINTENANCE ACROSS ALL
OF THE UTILITIES IN CALIFORNIA
ON VEGETATION MANAGEMENT OF
MAINTENANCE OF RIGHT OF WAYS OF
PEOPLE WALKING AROUND.
CALM DOING THIS THESE
ASSESSMENTS AND THEN TRIMMING --
THE TREES.
CALM AND THEY GET THEM FROM
UTILITY POINT OF VIEW THEIR
PRIMARY FOCUS IS ON COMPLIANCE
SO WHAT THEY'RE REALLY LOOKING.
FOR CALM IN THIS IS MEAN MAKING
SURE THAT WHATEVER IS NOT
REQUIRED CLEARANCE IS MAINTAINED
AND THEN TRIMMING BACK THE
VEGETATION THAT'S LIKELY TO GROW
AND SO THAT CLEARANCE SPACE.
WOULD THEN THE NEXT CYCLE RATES
OF THEIR TRIMMING IT FURTHER
THAN WHAT THE REQUIRED
CLEARANCES IN ANTICIPATION THAT
THE NEXT TIME WE COME AROUND
I'LL BE HERE LATER AND THEY NEED
THAT BALL.
FOR A CALM AND THEN THE RULES OF
PICKING UP YOU KNOW OBVIOUS
HAZARDS SUCH AS OF THAT TREE
WELL THE PROBLEM WITH ALL OF
THIS IS THAT IN THE CLIMATE
SITUATION THAT WE'RE FACING
RIGHT NOW.
WHERE WE FREQUENTLY SEEING EL
VERY HIGH WINDS --
YOU HAVING HEALTHY TREES FAIL
CALM AND AND BRANCHES AND THEY
FLY FROM OUTSIDE OF THE
CLEARANCE SPACE.
CALM AND SO.
THAT AND THAT'S JUST ONE OF THE
THE FOR ONE OF THE THE MENTAL
CHALLENGES WITH THIS PARADIGM
THAT IF YOU ONLY FOCUSING ON
MAINTENANCE OR ALL OF YOUR
CLEARANCES ABOVE YOUR RIGHT OF
WAY WHICH YOU ABSOLUTELY SHOULD
BILL.
IT'S THOUGH BY NO MEANS AT ALL
BE SURE PROOF WAY TO CALM
SUFFICIENTLY MITIGATES THE O.
THE VEGETATION O. THE FUEL LOW
RISK THAT WE'RE FACING.
SO THERE ARE SOLUTIONS OUT THERE
CALM NOT ANYTHING THAT'S BEEN
IMPLEMENTED WIDELY BLADES WELL
THIS IS THE PERFECT OPPORTUNITY
FOR A BIG THE THE MACHINE
LEARNING ALL SOLUTION AND THE SO
SOMETHING THAT TECHNOLOGY CAN
HOPE WITH.
A WHOLE NEW FLYING.
DRONES OR OF THE DOING OF THE
AERIAL PATROLS AND COLLECTING A
LOT OF VISUAL DETAILS FOR LIGHT
OR ANOTHER SERVING OF SOMETHING
THATS DONE THE TRANSMISSION
HOME ON THE ANNUAL BASIS.
BUT THOSE --
VERY VERY DIFFERENT QUANTITIES
SO UTILITIES HAVEN'T BEEN DOING
THAT SO MUCH DISTRIBUTION SIDE.
AT ALL BECAUSE OF THE COSTS AND
AND SOME OF THE REASONS BUT
EXPANDING THAT DATA COLLECTION
AND THEN THAT CHALLENGE WITHOUT
RIGHT NOW IS JUST PROCESSING THE
WITH THE VOLUME OF DATA FAST
ENOUGH.
THOUGH TO MAKE IT USEFUL EL BUT
AGAIN THOSE AT A THING THIS
TECHNOLOGY IS ABOVE ALL OF THEM
THERE'S A LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES
AT LOOKING AT ADVANCED
TECHNOLOGIES IN BOTH EMERGING.
COMBINING SATELLITE DATA --
THEM WITH --
WHO'S SERVING RESULTS AT HOME
AND OTHER WAYS AND USING HOME
ADVANCED COMPUTING TO DO MUCH
MORE GO HOME.
ADVANCED THOUGH RISK MANAGEMENT
THAT YOU WERE ABLE TO DO WITH
HUMANS CALM AND THAT'S JUST A
QUESTION OF NUMBERS AND VOLUMES
THE HEADS WE CAN PROCESS A LOT
MORE IT WOULD BE TO WITH
MACHINES.
SO THEN ONCE YOU HAVE THAT RISK
ASSESSMENT YOU COULD START.
TO TAKING PEOPLE OUT THERE DOING
SECONDARY VERIFICATIONS THAT IS
WHERE THE INDUSTRY IS MOVING TO
WORDS.
IT IS NOT ANYTHING THAT'S BEEN
DEPLOYED GLOBALLY THE ONLY OTHER
PLACE THAT'S BEEN SORT OF ON THE
EDGES A IN AUSTRALIA.
CALM.
BUT I THINK DESERT KIND OF THE
AREAS TO BE LOOKING AND SO AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE NEXT
FRONTIER OF HOW DO WE MANAGE
THIS PROBLEM RATHER THAN JUST
FOCUSING ON MAKING THESE
CLEARANCES WELL WHITER --
IT IS THEN I WILL GO THROUGH AS
MUCH DIESEL IN SOME OF THE OTHER
ONES A A THINK YOU THERE'S BEEN
A FAIR AMOUNT OF DISCUSSION ON
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS.
AND WHETHER PREPAREDNESS AND
UNDERSTANDING L. WHETHER IT THE
MORE GRANULAR LEVEL AND SOME
SUCCESSES THOUGH.
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT FROM --
SEEM TO YOU.
WITH THE PLAYING WHAT THE
STATIONS AND MOST CRITICALLY
COLLECTING GRANULAR WIND
INFORMATION CALL BECAUSE THAT
BOTH GIVES YOU ON THE GROUND
THOUGH.
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS OF WHAT'S
GOING ON IN PROXIMITY TO THE
ELECTRIC CLIENTS BUT IT ALSO
ALLOWS YOU TO DO MUCH BETTER
MODELING AND UNDERSTANDING RISKS
AND UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT ACTUAL
WHAT THE CONDITIONS WERE
HOPPING.
AND GET MORE GRANULAR BUT THAT'S
HOMES DOES A LOT OF
OPPORTUNITIES IN THIS AREA AND
THEN ON THE IGNITION CONTROL.
THOUGH.
THERE ARE ADVANCED TECHNOLOGIES
THE UTILITIES HAVE BEEN
DEPLOYING WACO รณ FULL SUN
SAYING BEING ABLE TO PINPOINT
SINCE.
THAT DISCONNECT LINES WHEN
THERE'S SO FOLDS WHICH COULD
INDICATE VEGETATION CONTACTS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT.
SO ONE OF THE NEXUS IS OVER THE
NEXT ALSO IN THESE THREE AREAS
IS -- USE OF
ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY IN GOING
BEYOND SOME OF THOSE MORE MANUAL
WAYS OVER A DONE A FINE RISKS
AND DOING VISUAL HUMAN
INSPECTIONS AND THINKING OF HOW
WE CAN ACTUALLY DO THIS MORE AT
SCALE AND FASTER.
USING DIFFERENT TYPES OF DATA
STREAMS AND ADVANCE THE
ANALYSIS.
AND THAT TIES TO THE QUESTION
ALL OF OH DOUBLE CHECKING AND
HELPING BOOTS ON THE GROUND AND
WHOSE VALIDATING THE THIS AND
THE INSPECTIONS OF THE UTILITIES
A PERFORMING.
CALM YEAH LIKE UTILITIES SO.
HOW FLOW VETO WHO OVER THIRTY
THOUSAND EMPLOYEES IN THE IN
CALIFORNIA ALL TOGETHER I MEAN
IF WE'RE GOING TO DUPLICATE THE
WORKING NAY GAINES CREATES SOME
WAS SIZE WORKFORCE JUST UNITS
JUST NUMBER IS RIGHT?
AND JUST PUTTING PEOPLE OUT
THERE TO DOUBLE CHECK PEOPLE
ISN'T PROBABLY THE MOST
EFFICIENT WAY ESPECIALLY FOR THE
STATE'S WHERE IT SUCCESS.
JUST TIME TO GET BUDGETS THROUGH
AND HIRE PEOPLE AND TRAIN THEM
AND MANAGE THEM.
HOME SO WE SHOULD COULD
OPPONENTS OF IT THEM BOOTS ON
THE GROUND WHAT WE'VE ALREADY
DOUBLED รณ MORE THAN DOUBLED
OUR ELECTRIC SAFETY PROGRAM AND
ABOUT THE LAST TO JUST TWO
YEARS.
HOME WHILE WE'VE HIRING IN
DOUBLING THAT SEEKS TIME WE FROM
MANAGEMENT EXPERTS STAFF TO HIRE
THOSE PEOPLE AND TRAIN THEM SO
THERE'S A COST TO THAT AS WELL.
SO WE CAN NEEDS TO BE MINDFUL AS
WE DOING THESE THINGS ALSO BUT
THERE ARE OPPORTUNITIES IN
TECHNOLOGY NOT ONLY FOR THAT
INITIAL ASSESSMENTS BUT ALSO IN
HOW WE OUGHT IT.
BECAUSE YOU DON'T NEED AS MANY
PEOPLE TO DOUBLE CHECK THE
RESULTS OVER YOU YOU KNOW OWN
FLAVOR VIDEO CAMERA.
HOME OR A LIDAR HOME IN OF THE
DEED A I WAS JUST I ASK IS THAT
THE P. YOU SEE DOUBLING UP OR IS
THAT --
THAT'S THE P. YOU SEE YES OF THE
STAFF IN MY SECTION HAS MORE
THAN DOUBLED IN THE ELECTRIC.
POLICIES TO BRANCH BACK WELL SIX
YEARS AGO THOSE ONLY ONE GROUP
IS ABOUT THIRTY PEOPLE THAT
OVERSAW ALL OF ELECTRIC ALL
TELECOMMUNICATIONS AND GAS.
SAFETY THIRTY PEOPLE IN THE
ENTIRE STATE SO THAT'S WHERE WE
WERE -- HOME.
ABOUT SEVEN YEARS AGO SO WE HAVE
NOW MORE THAN THREE PEOPLE OF
JUST DEDICATED TO THE GAS SAFETY
PROGRAM AND MORE THAN THIRTY
PEOPLE IN THE ELECTRIC AND THAT
THIRTY HOUSE DOUBLED FROM ABOUT
A DOZEN AND THAT WE HAD JUST TWO
YEARS AGO.
SO WE'VE BEEN GROWING QUITE A
LOS CALM IN IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS AND CONTINUE TO EVALUATE
OUR STAFFING.
AT HOME.
BUT THOSE ARE THE KIND OF THOSE
SORT OF MATHEMATICIAN NUMBERS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
ALL STILL BE HAPPY TALK MORE
ABOUT THIS IN IN QUESTIONS AND
ANSWERS BUT I JUST WANTED TO PUT
A PIN THAN THOSE THAT THE YOU
KNOW AND WE SHOULD.
I THINK NOT ONLY BE LOOKING AT
AT PEOPLE AND STAFFING AND HOW
MANY AUDITS WITH DOING THAT
HUMANS AND HAULING YOU LINES
WERE PATROLLING PHYSICALLY.
BUT ALSO THINKING HOW CAN WE DO
SOME OF THAT DOUBLE CHECKING AT
ALL WITH ADVANCED TECHNOLOGIES
AND USE MACHINES IN THE BOUNCE
LEARNING AND SCHOOLS THAT AND
NOW ALL BECOMING AVAILABLE. TO
US THAT WEREN'T EVEN THE COUPLE
OF YEARS AGO THIS WAS PROBABLY
NOT TECHNICALLY FEASIBLE BUT
WHEN NOW NOT COSTS WERE WE CAN
ACTUALLY THINK.
DO THIS AT THAT SCALE AND NOT
JUST THEN AND PILOTS
[inaudible]
CALM.
THEN ELMO LAST THE SO THE LAST
SLADE AND SO IT SORT OF SHIFTING
GEARS A LITTLE BIT WHO CALLED
THE THE REGULATORY FRAMEWORKS
THE KNOTS AND BOLTS OF HOW.
THESE HIGH LEVEL IDEAS SORT OF
MANIFEST THEMSELVES IN THE
REGULATORY SPACE BECAUSE WE USE
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT LANGUAGE AND
WE HAVE THE FRIEND.
OF HISTORIC PROCESS SEES THROUGH
WHICH WE CAN ACTUALLY MOVE THE
BALL FORWARD HELM.
ON THESE ITEMS AND SO THE
ROUGHLY SPEAKING SRI DIFFER
IT'LL FLOAT WERE EXTREMES I
WOULD SAY A THREE DIFFERENT
PROPHECIES AROUND THOUGH SO ONE
OF THEM IS THE WILDFIRE
PREVENTION ON PLANNING.
ALMOST OF THIS IS THE DOMAIN
WHERE UTILITIES AT ALL.
SO THE VOCAL PLANS OF HOW THE
GOING TO MITIGATE O. WILDFIRE
RISKS IN THIS PACIFIC
TERRITORIES THAT FILE THEM WITH
THE COMMISSION OF CURRENTLY
TAKES PLACE AS PART OF THEIR
GENERAL ORDER ONE SIXTY SIX
REQUIREMENTS IT'S BEEN GOING ON
FOR AWHILE.
THOUGH.
THERE IS SOME NEW PLAN
REQUIREMENTS BUT THAT THE
FRAMEWORK IS MORAL US THE SAME.
CALM THE PURPOSE OF THESE PLANS
ISRAELI INFORMING I DON'T MEAN
YOU STAKEHOLDERS AS TO WHAT THE
UTILITIES ARE DOING AND
COLLECTING FEEDBACK A STING
IMPROVEMENTS IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO
HAVE A PLAN.
WELL YOU KNOW WHEN YOU GO TO ANY
SUITABLE FOR OF THE INDO PROOF
WOULD.
ORGANIZATION THAT NEEDS TO HELP
EMERGENCY RESPONSE YOU YOU
ALWAYS WANT TO HAVE AN EMERGENCY
RESPONSE PLAN A RISK OF
MITIGATION PLAN TO THIS GOOD
THINGS TO HALT IT GETS PEOPLE
THINKING ABOUT THESE ISSUES ARE
UP IN THE VAN SUBMIT GIVES A
GOOD FRAMEWORK FOR
COLLABORATION.
AND IT'S COOL AGAIN FOR A FOOD
FOR EVERYONE TO WILL SIMPLY GOOD
FAITH ASSESS ALL PERFORMANCE
AFTER THE FACT RATES SO THE WAY
THAT YOU NEED WHETHER IT'S FIRE
OR ANY OTHER KIND OF SO THE
SITUATION WHAT YOU WANNA DO IS
HAVE A PLAN.
AND THEN YOU YOU HOW THE VANCE
AND THEN YOU GO AND YOU COMPARE
HOW YOU PERFORMED AGAINST THE
PLAN YOU DO LESSONS LEARNED THAN
THE NEW REVISED THE PLANNING YOU
CONTINUOUSLY IMPROVE SO PLAN
SERVE THAT IMPORTANT PORT
PURPOSE.
THE RISK ASSESSMENT AND RATE
MAKING AT ALL IS THE AREA OF
WHERE WE FUNDS UTILITIES WELL
BEFORE I GO.
AGAIN.
FIRE A FEW YEARS AGO FOR LET'S
SAY FIVE YEARS AGO AND ALL THE
COMMISSION HOW THE AT ALL VERY
DISTINCT JUST THREE MAKING
FUNCTIONS SO THE OTHER
UTILITIES.
ON THE CYCLE COME UP WHEN THEY
ASK FOR A FOR MONEY THROUGH
GENERAL REEKIE SUPPLICATIONS AND
THEN ABOUT THE FROM PARTIES
ARGUE YOU KNOW WHAT THAT IT'S
TOO MUCH NOT ABOUT.
COMMISSION CONSIDERS THAT THE
VOTES ABOUT AND IT WAS ALWAYS
DONE FROM VERY RATES POINTS OF
VIEW ON THE COSTS THAN THE MAIN
PARTIES IN THERE WOULD RATE
PAYER IN PHOENIX.
WELL THE COMMISSION RECOGNIZED
THE GALLUP POLL THAT THAT WAS IN
THE BIG ENOUGH A CONSIDERATION
OF SAFETY THROUGH THE PROCESS.
AND WENT THROUGH A VERY LENGTHY
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO DESIGN A
BETTER WAY TO DO RATE CASES IN
THE WAS A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS CONSIDERED AT THAT TIME.
IN THE METHODOLOGY THAT ABOUT
THE CAN RATE PAYER INTERVENE
ISN'T SAFETY ADVOCATES IN MANY
DIFFERENT GROUP CAME UP WITH WAS
THE SORT OF THREE STEP PROCESS
WHERE FOR THE FIRST PART IT IS
THE SOMETHING CALLED US MY
PROCESS WHICH IS BASICALLY
METHODOLOGY FOR RISK ASSESSMENT.
AND IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S A DATA
DRIVEN SO THAT IS THE VERY
DETAILED WAY THAT UTILITIES GO
IN THE SENSE THEIR OPERATIONAL
RISKS.
AND AGAIN HIS MODELS WERE
EVALUATED HOW HE EATS ALL THESE
CATEGORIES THIS RISK QUANTIFY
THOSE RISKS AND HOW THE BILL
THESE MODELS.
SO THE COMMISSION WENT THROUGH A
PROCESS OF APPROVING THOSE
MODELS WHICH IS HOW YOU DO RISK
ASSESSMENTS IN GENERAL AT
UTILITY AND THERE'S AN ONGOING
WAY TO KEEP MAKING IMPROVEMENTS
TO IT.
THE SECOND STOP IS RAMP WHICH IS
A UTILITY SPECIFIC FILING WHERE
UTILITY.
BEFORE FILING THE REEKIE SAYS
RIGHT NOW THIS IS OUR ASSESSMENT
OF OUR SPECIFIC RISKS IN THIS IS
HOW WE RANK THEM WILL UTILITIES
THROUGH BELIEVE A SINGLE ROUND
THREAT RANK BELOW WILDFIRES IS
NUMBER ONE SEEK TO RISK AND THEN
IT GOES DOWN FROM THERE.
CALM AND THEN THE INCOMES OF THE
GENERAL SO THATTHERE'S A
PROCESS TO CONSIDER THAT IN FOR
COMMISSION TO VOTE ON WHETHER
THAT'S APPROPRIATE AND THEN THE
RE KEANE'S COMES.
WHERE THE REQUEST FOR MONEY?
MATCHES SORT OF THE RISK
CATEGORIES IN THE COMMISSION
CONSIDERS WHAT ABOUT SUFFICIENT
ENDS AND THEN ONCE THAT GETS
ADOPTED IN THE BACK AND THERE'S
REPORTING AND AUDITING TO MAKE
SURE THAT UTILITIES ARE SPENDING
MONEY WHERE.
THE SAID WEEKEND SUSPENDED ON
SAFETY IN THE TH BE DEVIATE FROM
THEIR REQUEST THEN THEY HAVE TO
EXPLAIN WHY.
SO THAT'S THE NEW MODEL THAT THE
COMMISSION'S ADOPTED AROUND RISK
ASSESSMENT RATE MAKING.
AND THEN THE LAST SECTION OF THE
COMPLIANCE AND ENFORCEMENT WHICH
IS DRIVEN BY COMMISSIONS GENERAL
ORDERS --
GENERAL WOULD IN NINETY FIVE
THAT YOU HEAR I HAD --
ELECTRIC UNTIL COMMUNICATION
FACILITIES.
OWE THEM.
THAT'S THE FRAMEWORK THAT WE USE
A STYLE FOR AUDITS AND INCIDENT
INVESTIGATIONS.
CALM THAT'S A STRICT CODE THAT
SAYS THIS IS HOW YOUR CAN USE
NEED TO CONSTRUCT AND MAINTAIN
YOUR SYSTEM THAT'S WHERE THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
REQUIREMENT LIVES.
AND TELL THEM IN ON THE BACK END
OF DIED BECAUSE THERE ISN'T
FORCE MONTH ACTIONS THAT THAT
STAFF AND COMMISSION CAN SEEK IN
THE RANGE FOR ALL.
ALL IN ALL INCOME FOR MONTHS AND
WORKING WITH THE UTILITY TO ALL
CORRECTIVE ITS HOLES THROUGH
PROGRESSIVE LEVELS OF
ENFORCEMENT THAT CAN INCLUDE
CITATION THAT'S A STAFF LOW
FINANCIAL PENALTY.
ALL THE WAY THROUGH AND THE PORT
INSTITUTING IN THE INVESTIGATION
WHICH ARE LARGE ADJUDICATORY
PROCEEDINGS.
SO THESE OF THE PAIN OF BEING
CALM SEPARATES THOUGH EFFORTS UP
TO THE STATES.
AND ONE OF THE SO THINGS THAT I
IN THE CURRENT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IS DOING IS CLOSING THE
GAPS BETWEEN NAM.
CALM SAID THE WAY THAT THIS THIS
IS OF ALL OF THE WHERE THINKING
IN THE SEPARATE STREAMS MORAL AS
WE'VE HAD JUNE YOU KNOW
IMPROVEMENTS OF OUR GENERAL
QUARTERS AND OUR COMPLIANCE.
EFFORTS WE'VE HAD IMPROVEMENTS
AND AND CONSIDERING SAFETY RISKS
WITHIN THE RATE MAKING AND THEN
WE'VE HAD THE WILDFIRE
PREVENTION PLANNING WITH THE
WORD THE WASN'T A LOT OF WORK
DONE TOOL --
TO INTEGRATE THOSE THREE EFFORTS
SIPPING THE CURRENT PROPOSAL IS
AT ALL.
DOING TWO THINGS IT IS SO.
IT'S GOOD IT'S BUILDING UPON
WHAT THE WORKERS OR YOU CAN DIE
BECAUSE THIS TOOK A LONG TIME TO
DEVELOP AND NOT ALL OF FRUITS OF
BOTH HOW COME TO BEAR YET.
CALM BECAUSE IT JUST TAKES TIME
FOR FOR THINGS TO GO THROUGH THE
REGULATORY SYSTEM IN THAT
SECTION HE IMPACT ON THE GROUND
AND SITTING YOUR CYCLE IT'S JUST
HOW IT WORKS IN ISRAELI LARGE
INDUSTRIES.
SO WE'RE JUST ABOUT POINT WHERE
WE SHOULD BE STARTING TO SEE A
LOT OF BENEFITS FROM US SO
CHANGING SO SOMETHING COMPLETELY
NEW WOULD JUST SET US BACK.
SO THE CURRENT PROPOSAL BUILDS
UPON THIS FRAMEWORK BUT IT ALSO
CLOSES THE GAPS BETWEEN THEM BY
FOR EXAMPLE HOME CREATING SOME
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LINKING
WILDFIRE PREVENTION PLANNING
WITH THE RISK ASSESSMENT AND
RATE MAKING [inaudible]
ELMER.
AND THAT I THINK WOULD BE
BENEFICIAL.
I KNOW IT TOOK UP QUITE A BIT OF
TIME DOES SO WITH THAT I WILL A
TURNIP OF AND THANK YOU OF
ALTERED TO TO MEMBERS AND SEE IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS BASED ON
THE PRESENTATION.
UNDER JACK'S.
THANK YOU --
SO I WASN'T A AT THE EARLIER
MEETING BECAUSE I HAD LONG
STANDING PLANTS TO TAKER.
AN EXPEDITION TYPE BOTH THROUGH
THE FJORDS AND THE GLACIERS IN
ALASKA.
AND IN THAT PREPARATION I WAS
TOLD NO ALASKA'S A RAIN FOREST
IN IT'S GOING TO BE IN THE
FORTIES AND FIFTIES.
AND SO I A MAKE SURE YOU BRING
MUD BOOTS SOMETHING I NEVER
OWNED AND BE PREPARED FOR LOTS
OF RAIN IN FORTY DEGREE WEATHER.
ENTIRE EIGHT DAYS TO THEIR IT
WAS SUNNY AND SEVENTY FIVE
DEGREES.
NOW THE JOKE WAS I BROUGHT MY
SANTA BARBARA WHETHER WITH US.
BUT FOR THE PEOPLE IN ALASKA
THEY HAD NEVER SEEN THIS BEFORE.
AND SO THE FACT OF MY MENTIONING
THIS IS THAT ALL THROUGHOUT
PROBABLY THE WORLD WE ARE SEEING
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES IN OUR
CLIMATE.
AND IN DOING SO PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT A NEW NORMAL --
BUT OTHERS TALK ABOUT THE FACT
THERE IS NO NORMAL.
THAT THERE IS TRUST UNCERTAINTY.
AND I THINK --
THAT YOU IT AS WE AS I LISTEN TO
YOUR DISCUSSION TODAY
[inaudible]
I AM.
DEEPLY CONCERNED --
ABOUT THE FACT THAT --
WE DON'T SEEM TO HAVE ANY KIND
OF COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING WHAT
IS PROBABLY ONE OF OUR PRIMARY
RESPONSIBILITIES IN THIS STATE
AS GOVERNMENT WHICH IS TO
PROTECT THE SAFETY.
AND SECURITY OF OUR PEOPLE.
AND AS WE ARE HERE RIGHT NOW
FIRES ARE YET AGAIN BURNING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AND TO IT'S ONLY SEVEN MONTHS
SINCE THE WILDFIRE THE
DEVASTATED MY COMMUNITY WHICH
BECAME.
THE LARGEST WILDFIRE IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY IT IS NOW
BEEN SUPERSEDED JUST SEVEN
MONTHS LATER.
BY THE MENDOCINO FIRES.
AND SO -- I
WOULD APPRECIATE IF YOU COULD
EXPLAIN TO ME WHAT YOU BELIEVE
TO BE THE P. UC'S ROLE.
IN ESTABLISHING A AND WHEN IT
COMES TO A ADDRESSING THIS WHOLE
ISSUE OF OF THE POTENTIAL FOR
WILDFIRES IN THE REALITIES
CREATED BY.
OUR UTILITY COMPANIES AND EITHER
THE MISMANAGEMENT THE NEGLIGENCE
OR WHATEVER IT IS THAT WHEN
THESE POLLS FALL --
OR CREATE SPARKS TO CREATE THESE
FIRES THAT BURNED DOWN --
THAT THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE'S HOMES
TAKE LIVES DESTROYED BUSINESSES
DESTROYER CON TO ME WHAT DO YOU
SEE AS THE P. UC'S ROLE.
IN DEVELOPING THE SAFETY PLANS
AND HOW WHAT WOULD YOU SAY AT
THIS POINT TIME YOU ARE --
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESSING WHAT HAS
BECOME.
THE NEW NORMAL OR THE UNCERTAIN
NORMAL WHERE WE ARE SEEING THESE
MASSIVE FIRES.
OVER THE LAST FIVE AND TEN
YEARS.
SO THANK YOU FOR A MINUTE JUST
KEY OFFER WHAT YOU SAID AND THAT
QUESTION IS UNCERTAINTY.
AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THAT IS CLEARLY UNCERTAIN AS WE
STARTED THIS YEAR ALL OF FOCUS
WAS ON UTILITY INDUCED FIRES AND
ONLY ONE IN TEN FIRE COME FROM
UTILITIES.
AS A MATTER OF FACT IS A FIRE
THAT SU PROSTITUTE MISFIRE
ACTUALLY WAS CAUSED BY A
MOTORCYCLE.
XIKAR FIRE WAS CAUSED BY A
PASSING CAR WITH A DEFECT.
YEAH SO I HATE IT I JUST WANT TO
BE CLEAR.
I DON'T THINK THAT ANYTHING THAT
WE CAN DO AROUND THE ELECTRIC
UTILITIES OR ANY OF THE COULD
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE COVER
CAN ADDRESS ALL OF THE
CHALLENGES.
THAT IS SO OUR TASK IS TO REALLY
FOCUS UNTIL UNTIL YOU TELL US
THE YOU WANT US TO BECOME THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAR OF FORCE FIRE
ATTENTION.
WE WE WILL FOCUS ON THE THE THE
THE MANY MANY DIFFERENT --
TYPES OF INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR OVERSEEING.
SO PART OF IT HAS BEEN.
REBUILD THE STRENGTH OF A SAFETY
FUNCTION AT THE P. YOU SAY.
AS ALWAYS A BETTER SAID WE WERE
FAIRLY WEAK WHEN I GOT THERE --
PEOPLE DIDN'T TALK TO ME ABOUT
SAFETY I THINK WE'VE COME A LONG
WAY BUT WE HAVE A LOT FURTHER
TRY JUSTICE AGO. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU DO YOU ACTUALLY
FOCUSED ON IS HOW DO YOU MAKE
SURE THE YOU'RE STAYING WITH UP
WITHOUT CHANGES.
NOW AS A REGULATORY AGENCY ARE
ALWAYS GOING TO BE BEHIND THE
BALL.
POSSESS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY
WE MOVED TO THIS RISK ASSESSMENT
MANAGEMENT PHASE IN THE RATE
MAKE.
IT MOVES INTO NOT JUST A
REGULATORY BUT A RISK ASSESSMENT
TOOL SO THAT WE DON'T GET
SHARPER CUT SHORT OF HAVING TO
DO THREE YEARS OF LITIGATED
DISCUSSION OVER A RULE.
THAT ACTUALLY SPECIFIES ACTIONS
THAT THEN CHANGES NEW
TECHNOLOGIES COME INTO THE
MARKETPLACE OR CONDITIONS CHANGE
IT'S DESIGNED TO ACTUALLY GET AN
ASSESSMENT OF WHAT ARE THE RISKS
THAT ARE OUT THERE.
AND WHAT YOU SPEND YOUR MONEY ON
TO ACTUALLY BRING THEM DOWN.
SO THAT I THINK IS A VERY
IMPORTANT STEP IT DOESN'T.
I SHOULD THE CEILING.
IT ACTUALLY SAYS THE FLOOR WILL
CONSTANTLY RISE.
SO THIS IS FAIRLY NEW WINNERS
WERE IN THE END OF OUR FIRST
CYCLE STARTING OUR SECOND CYCLE
OF THESE PLANTS WERE LEARNING.
WE'RE SEEING THINGS AND I WILL
POINT OUT THAT EVERYBODY IS A
WIN IN START TO DO THAT RATHER
THAN COMPLYING WITH A HARD AND
FAST RULES.
LET'S GO OUT AND TAKE A LOOK AT
THE WORLD AND SEE WHAT WE THINK
THE NEXT CHALLENGES ARE GOING TO
BE.
AND STARTED ADDRESS THOSE RISKS.
THAT'S WHEN WE STARTED TO SEE
WILD FIRES COME UP IN ALL OF THE
ELECTRIC UTILITIES PLANTS SO I
THINK THAT WE WE WILL GET
BETTER.
THAT'S OUR CHALLENGE WE HAVE TO
CONSTANTLY GET BETTER ANTICIPATE
NEW THINGS.
HOWEVER WE SPENT FOUR YEARS
WORKING WITH THE SCIENTISTS SIC
CAL FIRE AND THE FIRE ENGINEERS
TO MAP THE FUEL SOURCES HERE IN
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND TO LOOK AT WHERE THE
ELECTRIC UTILITIES ARE AND WE
SAW THE AMOUNT OF OF AREAS WERE
MAPPED INTO THOSE HIGH FIRE
HAZARD AREAS RISE FROM AROUND
17% ALMOST 40% OF THE STATE'S
LAND MASS.
SOME OF THAT COMES FROM
ADVANCING DROUGHT.
SOME OF THAT COMES FROM YEARS OF
OF OF OF FORCED IN WILDLAND FIRE
MEYER COMMIT MANAGEMENT SOME OF
THAT COMES FROM THE PACE AT
WHICH PEOPLE ARE.
BUILDING NEW DEVELOPMENTS IN
THOSE HIGH FIRE HAZARD ZONES SO
WE WILL ALWAYS.
P. TYING TO KEEP PEACE WITH THE
WAY IN WHICH THE STATE CHANGES
SO IT GOES BACK TO THAT LEVEL OF
UNCERTAINTY THAT YOU ADDRESS.
WILL GET BETTER.
BUT WHAT ALWAYS ALWAYS BE SEEING
NEW THINGS COMING AT US SOME OF
WHICH ARE VERY HARD TO
ANTICIPATE NOBODY EXPECTED
[inaudible]
EVER.
SEE THE KINDS OF INTENSE.
WINS AND LOW HUMIDITY LOW SOIL
MOISTURE HOT TEMPERATURES.
THAT WE COULD RESULT IN INTENSE
FIRES WITH A HUNDRED AND FORTY
FIVE MILE WINDS THAT.
IS ABSOLUTELY UNPRECEDENTED SO
WOULD YOU SAY THAT SAFETY IS NOW
THE NUMBER ONE PRIORITY AT THE
P. UC.
I DON'T THINK THAT I CAN LEGALLY
SAY THAT WE HAVE ANY NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY YOU'VE TASKS WITH MANY
THINGS BUT IT'S SOMETHING THAT
I'VE SPENT A LOT OF TIME ON AND
I KNOW THAT OTHER PEOPLE SPEND A
LOT OF TIME ON IT I THINK THAT
WE ARE ACTUALLY APPROACHING.
THE LEVEL OF COMPETENCE THAT
WASN'T THERE WHEN I STARTED HAVE
YOU WORKED WITH GROUPS LIKE
HELLFIRE IN THE MARSHALL OF THE
FIRE MARSHAL'S OFFICE WHICH A
ARE TASKED WITH THIS VERY --
SPECIFIC NEW KNOWLEDGE AND AND
EXPERTISE SO FOR EXAMPLE WEEK
COMPLETED A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH CAL FIRE TO
ACTUALLY SHARE INFORMATION OVER
THE COURSE OF FOUR YEARS WE
WORKED WITH WORKING GROUPS WHO
WERE CONVENE BY CAL FIRES FIRE
SCIENTISTS WE DON'T HAVE.
PEOPLE WHO UNDERSTAND FIRE
BEHAVIOR AND FUEL.
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE DO IN IT'S
IT'S UNLIKELY THERE WOULD BE A
GOOD USE OF OF THE STATE'S AND
RATE PAYERS DOLLARS FOR US TO
REPLICATE THE SKILL SETS.
SO WE'VE BEEN FORMING
PARTNERSHIPS WITH OTHER STATE
AGENCIES.
BECAUSE WE ALL OF A SUDDEN
BECAME AWARE.
THAT WE DON'T DO WELLS.
BUT THERE ARE WELLS THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN GAS STORAGE
FACILITIES WHERE WE HAVE
AUTHORITY PASSED DOWN TO US FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR
PIPELINE MANAGEMENT WE FORMED A
RELATIONSHIP IN MEMORIALIZED IT
WITH A MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING WITH CAL FIRE.
SO I KNOW THIS IS A WAY THAT WE
TRIED TO DO THAT SO I GUESS TO
CUT THROUGH THIS WOULDN'T IT
MAKE SENSE.
IF THE EXPERTISE ON HOW TO DEAL
WITH THESE FIRES HOW TO PREVENT
THEM HOW TO WORK WITH THE
DIFFERENT UTILITIES AND REQUIRE
THAT THEY DEVELOP BEST
MANAGEMENT PRACTICES ON HOW THE
HOW THEY DRESS THE VEGETATION
ISSUES -- WE
KNOW THAT --
ASEAN CREATED AT THEIR OWN
DIRECTION THESE WHETHER CENTERS
WHICH ADDRESS PART OF THAT
TRIUMVIRATE YOU INDICATED OF
WEATHER.
AND INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE THIRD
ONE WAS SO --
WILL YOU TELL ME THAT THAT THERE
WERE THE THREE THINGS THAT YOU
TALK ABOUT IS BEING.
THE FUEL THANK YOU THAT THEY
HAVE DONE THAT --
OR A BECAUSE YOU KEEP SAYING
YOU'RE ALWAYS GOING TO BE BEHIND
BUT THAT'S NOT IT THAT'S NOT
GOING TO STALK THESE FIRES
BECAUSE THAT'S THE BEST WAY TO
REDUCE LIABILITY.
IS TO MAKE SURE WE DON'T HAVE
THE SARS WITHSO IT WOULD USE
AND DO WOULD YOU AGREE THAT
OPERATING OFF FROM THE
INFORMATION AND EXPERTISE OF
OTHERS.
WOULD GIVE YOU THE ABILITY TO
BETTER IDENTIFY WHETHER OR NOT
THESE UTILITIES OR MAYBE DIRECT
THAT THESE UTILITIES APPLY THESE
BEST PRACTICES IN A PROACTIVE
WAY SO THAT WE DON'T KEEP SEEING
SO MANY FIRES HAY GROUP YOU A
100%.
I'VE BEEN FOLLOWING THE THE
PROGRESS OF THE THE WIND --
MODELING HANDS ANEMOMETER SINCE
INDIA GO SINCE BEFORE I CAME TO
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
THEY ACTUALLY CAME TO US AND
SAID WE WANT TO TRY THIS WILL
YOU ALLOW US TO RECOVER THE COST
OF ACTUALLY DEPLOYING THESE NEW
EXPERIMENTAL.
MODELS THAT WE WANT TO DEPLOY.
BOTH DIGITIZING THE LANDSCAPE
DOING THE NGUYEN MODELING
STARTING TO BUILD THE ALGORITHMS
FOR RESPONDING. TO YOU LET US DO
THAT AND WE HAVE ACTUALLY
WATCHED AND LEARNED.
IT THE ARROW IS HE DIDN'T LET
YOU DIDN'T YOU DIDN'T ALLOW THEM
TO DO THAT.
IS PART OF THE RATE YES WE DID
YOU DID OKAY GET WELL HOW MUCH
COURAGE IN THAT FROM SOME OF THE
OTHER UTILITIES THAT ARE US AL
[inaudible]
JUST STARTED THAT PROCESS OF
REQUIRING THEM TO ACTUALLY LEARN
FROM THAT BUT I WILL TELL YOU.
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO WATCH
INTO WORM WITH THOSE FOLKS ARE
DOING WHO ARE TRYING TO LEARN
NEW BEST PRACTICES BECAUSE AT
THE TIME NOBODY KNEW WHAT WOULD
COME OUT OF IT.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING YOU CAN GO TO
FRIDAY SPENT BY OFF THE SHELF.
AND IT TOOK THEM A LONG TIME TO
REALLY PERFECT AND I WILL TELL
YOU THAT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON WILL SPEND A LONG TIME
ACTUALLY GOING THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF TRYING TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW WOOD DIFFERS IN THE
LANDSCAPE TO TAKE COVER SAN
DIEGO HAS A RING OF AMOUNTS
BEHIND THE CITY?
S. E. HAS THE COASTAL RANGE THAT
TO HATCH A PIECE IN THE SIERRAS
ALL THE WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO
HAVE DIFFERENCES IN TERMS OF HOW
THE WIND PATTERNS BEHAVE.
IN IN TERMS OF FUELS SO I'M I'M
TELLING YOU THAT WE WILL BE COME
A LEARNING ORGANIZATION.
BUT SOMETIMES YOU HAVE TO TRY
THINGS BEFORE YOU KNOW THAT THEY
WORK.
BY BUT WE DO KNOW THERE WHAT SD
GENIE HAS DONE HAS APPEARS TO BE
WORKING IN A CERTAINLY
ESTABLISHED A LEVEL OF BEST
PRACTICE I'M WONDERING.
I'M TRYING TO LOOK TO SEE AGAIN
THE QUESTION IS PREVENTION THIS
JULIE SAVATE UPON.
ISRAEL PENSION WEAKENED ACTION
TO REQUIRE THOSE OTHER UTILITIES
TO DO IT PREVENTION AND SAFETY
THAT I THINK IS WHAT SHOULD BE
THE FOCUS OF OUR DISCUSSIONS
HERE PREVENTION AND SAFETY.
I WANT TO KNOW WHO IS GOING TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN WHO'S GOING TO
WIN FOR STATE HOW WE GOING TO BE
SURE THAT THE UTILITIES.
ARE THAT WE HAVE ESTABLISH SAYS
AND HOW WE CAN ASSURE THAT THEIR
MEETING THOSE BEST PRACTICES IS
THAT YOUR CHOPPER SHOULD BE
SOMEBODY ELSE'S JOB.
I HAD TO IT'S A QUESTION.
SO.
I HAVE ALWAYS BELIEVED THAT NO
ONE AGENCY IS GONNA SOLVE THESE
PROBLEMS ALONE.
AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE WORKED
HARD TO WORK WITHIN THEIR
REGIONS.
IT'S A USEFUL QUESTION TO TO
EXAMINE SHOULD THE STATE HAVE
THE KIND OF OVER ARCHING SAFETY
AGENCY WHAT WOULD IT DO HOW WILL
IT TAKE CARE --
ADVANTAGE TO THE EXPERTISE
PACIFIC DIVISIONS WITH SPECIFIC
OF PURPOSE I MEAN.
I THINK THAT THAT'S A USEFUL
DISCUSSION.
ALL I KNOW IS THAT FOR THE
UTILITIES WE ARE GETTING BETTER
STRONGER AND WILL CONTINUE TO
GET.
HOME MORE EFFECTIVE IN TERMS OF
ACTUALLY DEALING WITH THESE
ISSUES.
SO WE'VE TALKED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE PROGRESS WE'VE MADE.
IF YOU DON'T FEEL THAT IT'S
ENOUGH OR IF YOU FEEL THAT THERE
SHOULD BE A DIFFERENT MODEL.
AGAIN I DEFERRED THE CENTER FOR
I COULD IF YOU HAVE A CLOSING
THOUGHT ON THAT ON I WANT TO
TURN TO CENTER HUESO AND THEN
SUMA MEMORYYES.
THEY HAD A CERTAINLY I I HAVE
MANY QUESTIONS PERHAPS I CAN ASK
HIM AT SOME OTHER POINT I DID
WANNA JUST THAT THE POINT TO
THIS IS THAT.
YOU HAVE LIMITED OF RESOURCES
YOUR JOB HAS PRIMARILY BEEN TO
DETERMINE APPROPRIATE RATES --
AYE I THINK AT THIS POINT N
TIME SOMEHOW OR OTHER IN GRANTED
UTILITIES ARE NOT NECESSARILY
RESPONSIBLE FOR EVERY FIRE BUT
TO THE EXTENT THAT THEY DO HAVE.
A THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
RESPONSIBLE I SUSPECT THE THOMAS
FIRE WILL SEE THAT THERE HAS
BEEN SOME UTILITY ALTHOUGH WE
DON'T KNOW YET WHAT IT IS BUT
THERE'S A LIKELIHOOD OF GOOD
LIKELIHOOD PERHAPS --
SOMEBODY HAS GOT TO TAKE OF THIS
SITUATION AND SOMEBODY'SGOT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE UTILITY
COMPANIES.
THE ANNA ADOPT BEST PRACTICES
AND ARE HELD FEET TO THE FIRE --
WHEN IT COMES TO MAKING SURE
THAT THEY IMPLEMENT THESE BEST
PRACTICES BECAUSE?
WHAT HAPPENS IS A COME RUNNING
TO THE P. YOU SEE IN ASKING FOR
ACCOMMODATIONS O THAT THEY CAN
INCREASE RATES BECAUSE THEY'VE
HAD THESE INCIDENTS?
AND YET IT'S SORT OF LIKE WHEN
YOU HAVE A THE THE FELLOW WHO
KILLS HIS A PARENTS COMING TO
COURT AND BEGGING FOR MERCY AT
THAT BEFORE THE JUDGE BECAUSE
HE'S AN ORPHAN.
I MEAN IT'S IT'S A IT'S A
SIMILAR SITUATION IT SEEMS TO ME
WHEN WE HAVE UTILITY COMPANIES.
THAT EITHER AREN'T BEING
REQUIRED --
TO MAINTAIN BEST PRACTICES DON'T
CONSIDER THEM THAT IMPORTANT
MAKE BUSINESS DECISIONS THAT ARE
CONTRARY TO BEST PRACTICES AND
SO MARK MY QUESTION IS HOWDO WE
FIX THAT PROBLEM AND A LOOK
FORWARD.
TO FURTHER DISCUSSIONS ON THAT.
THANK YOU PEN PART OF THIS
PROCESS WILL ALLOW US TO PUT
ADDITIONAL SPOTLIGHT ON SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU'VE
RAISED.
SENATE HUESO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND JUST FOLLOWING UP
ON YOUR COMMENTS I MEAN THAT --
DOT THAT PARTY THAT'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS ACTION IS
GOING TO BE US LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR.
AND I THINK WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES WITHOUT CREATING A NEW
AGENCY AND A NEW NEW DIRECTIVE I
DON'T THINK THAT'S NECESSARY I
MEAN WE HAVE THE WE HAVE THE PVC
WE HAVE CAL FIRE.
WE HAVE --
DID TO DEPARTMENT FORESTRY.
WE HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES OUT
THERE TO AT LEAST BEGIN --
A COMPREHENSIVE EFFORT LIKE --
PRESIDENT PICKER SAID IT'S CAN
REQUIRE EVERYBODY.
DOING A LITTLE BIT OF THEIR PART
AND JUST JUST TO I HAVE A
QUESTION THAT I'M A FULL PLATE
BUT IN SAN DIEGO IT JUST WASN'T
THE P. YOU SEE AND IT JUST
WASN'T S. TEACH YOU NEED.
I WAS ON THE COUNCIL BACK THEN
AND WE WORKED ON A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE BREAST MANAGEMENT.
POLICY WITH THE CITY.
REQUIRE TO CLEAR --
FUEL AROUND THEIR PROPERTIES AND
THAT'S A VERY REASONABLE THING
TO ASK OF PEOPLE. TO TAKE
PROACTIVE MEASURES TO REDUCE THE
RISK IN AROUND THE PROPERTY.
THAT'S SOMETHING I THINK THAT
NEEDS TO BE.
I MEAN TODAY WE'RE DISCUSSING
THE MEAT AND POTATOES.
I THOUGHT TODAY'S A COMMITTEE
HEARING IS REALLY THE MEAT AND
POTATOES SUPPORT THIS WHOLE.
DEBATE ON AN AND EVERYTHING I
THINK THE HE THAT THE PRINCIPLE
POLICY THAT WE SHOULD.
PRESENT TO THE LEGISLATURE FOR
APPROVAL AND THE GOVERNOR
BOTTOMLEY FOR SIGNATURE.
IT'S GOING TO COME FROM THIS
COMMITTEE AND IT'S GOING TO
INVOLVE --
HAVING THE PC DURING THE WORK
THAT THEY'RE CONTINUING TO DO
WHAT THE WHAT THE PROVIDERS.
THAT AT THAT LEVEL.
BUT ALSO HAVING.
THE COUNTY WORK CHU CHU AND THE
AND THE CITY'S WORK [inaudible]
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS A
LOCAL PROGRAM THAT ON THAT'LL.
HOLD PROPERTY OWNERS ACCOUNTABLE
FOR CLEARING.
THAT STUFF THAT'S ON THEIR
PROPERTY IN HOLDING THE
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE FOR CLEAN
THAT THAT'S IN OUR PROP.
AND I WAS GONNA ASK YOU KNOW I
I'M.
I I LOVE THE TO WIRE.
THE THE UTILITY UNDERGROUND YOU
PROGRAM THAT'S A VERY EXPENSIVE
PROGRAM BUT IT'S MAINLY.
AYE A PROGRAM THAT ADDRESSES A
STATICS REMOVING POWER LINES
FROM
OF THE THE THE VIEW BUT IT'S
VERY EXPENSIVE PROGRAM I'M VERY
CONCERNED.
THAT ANYTHING THAT WE DO HERE'S
GONNA HAVE --
AT AN IMPACT OF INCREASING RATES
--
CAN WE CAN WE PRIORITIZE IS IT
TOO LATE TO SAY I I WANT TO
FOCUS ON SAFETY AND ANYTHING
THAT REPAIRS ARE PAIN INTO --
WAY TO REDIRECT AND I DON'T
MEAN.
USE UNDERGROUND FUNDS SOME
SAYING ELIMINATE THAT PROGRAM.
BECAUSE IT CREATES A SAVINGS AND
THAT SAVINGS --
WE CAN SUBSTITUTE TO CREATE A
SAFETY PROGRAM STATEWIDE.
THAT IN SOME INSTANCES WHAT WILL
RESULT IN AND MAKING INVESTMENTS
SUBTLE STRAIGHTEN THE GREATEST
AT SOMETHING.
THAT WE CAN WORK ON HOW
COMPREHENSIVE IS THE UNDERGONE A
PER ONLY SPECIFIC AREAS OR IS
THAT STATE WIDER.
SO.
THEY'RE UNDER BRANDING PROGRAM
IS REALLY SORT OF A CREDIT TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT THEY
MATCH AND IT REALLY WAS BUILT
AROUND AN AESTHETIC CALL.
IT WAS STILL A STATUTE ACTUALLY
TIME --
DETERMINES THAT THIS IS
NECESSARY FOR PURPOSES OF
BEAUTIFICATION IS STARTED OUT AS
HIGHWAY BEAUTIFICATION PROGRAM.
SO THE UTILITIES ISSUE CREDITS
TO THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BASED
ON THEIR POPULATION.
AND THOSE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WILL
ACCUMULATE THE CREDITS AND IN A
MATCH IT WITH THEIR OWN DOLLARS
IN WHEN THEY'RE READY TO
UNDERGROUND CERTAIN PART OF THE
STATE SO HERE IN SACRAMENTO FOR
EXAMPLE --
THE CITY WORKED WITH A MUNICIPAL
UTILITY TO UNDERGROUND MOST OF
THE DOWNTOWN THAT'S WHY YOU
DON'T SEE A LOT OF POOL SOME
WIRES AROUND STATE CAPITOL --
THERE SEVERAL BLOCKS AWAY --
IT IT IS NOT A TRULY DESIGNED TO
SAFETY PROGRAM.
BUT ALSO SAY THAT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT IS EXPENSIVE SO WE THE
COSTS RANGE --
FOR UPWARDS OF TEN MILLION
DOLLARS DOWN PER MILE FOR UNDER
GROUNDING VERSUS. TEN THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR TOLL
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SERVE FOLKS
NEEDS.
SO TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND MILES OF
OF WIRES TO ONE POINT FOR FOR ME
SHOULD BE FOR ME AND POLLS.
THAT'S A FAIRLY EXPENSIVE
PROPOSITION TO SWITCH OVER ALL
OF ONCE SO PEOPLE SHOULD BE VERY
JUDICIOUS ABOUT WHERE WE DO THAT
WHERE THERE'S ACTUALLY A
SIGNIFICANT FIRE RISK.
AND WHERE THIS IS THE BEST
TECHNIQUE SO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON HAS COME FORWARD WITH
METAL POLES.
STRONGER AND FIRE RESISTANT FOR
SOME AREAS AND SO THAT'S SAID A
TECHNIQUE THAT THEY'RE USING IT
SOME OF THEIR THEIR MORE
MOUNTAINOUS AREAS --
IT'S HARD TO UNDO PROGRAM AND AS
THAT BE SOMETHING THAT WE CAN
ADD.
YOU COULD DO THAT TO THE TABLE I
MEAN HAD PUT THAT ON THE TABLE
MAKE THAT AS PART OF SOMETHING
WE SHOULD CONSIDER.
IF WE'RE GONNA TAKE SOME COST
SAVING MEASURES THAT COULD BE IN
A COST SAVING MEASURE THAT CAN
ALLOW US [inaudible]
CHIU.
SUBSTITUTE A DIFFERENT FUND
RAISING MEASURE THAT WILL HELP
US ADDRESS.
BOB BRUSH MANAGEMENT.
HELP THE COMPANY'S ADDRESS PRESS
MANAGEMENT HELP [inaudible]
HELP --
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE SOME
KIND GRANT PROGRAM IF WE'RE
GONNA COME IN IS THE LEGISLATURE
TELL THE COUNTIES WE WANT YOU --
TO COME UP WITH A PLAN ON HOW
YOU CAN REMOVE THIS BRUSH WE'RE
GONNA GO TO CAL FIRE SAY WE NEED
YOU.
TO IDENTIFY.
WHAT DID THAT THE FUEL AREAS ARE
AND AND WE WANNA WORK
EXPEDITIOUSLY TO REDUCE THAT
FUEL WHAT'S GOING TO BE THE
FUNDING SOURCE FOR TO DO THAT?
DOES THAT MEAN WE'RE GOING TO
ADD ANOTHER COSTS TO RATEPAYERS
AND I'M NOT.
I'M NINETY PREACHER PARTICULARLY
IN FAVOR OF THAT.
UNLESS WE CAN FIND A WAY.
TO INJECT SOME SAVINGS INTO THE
PROGRAM.
AMP AND IT WILL TRULY BEGIN TO
PRIORITIZE.
SO SENATOR FEW THAT YOU THINK
THAT'S VIABLE WE COULD MAKE IT
WORK OKAY [inaudible]
AND AN I GENERALLY I THINK THE
POLICY SHOULD.
THAT WE COME UP WITH SHOULD
INCLUDE THE COUNTIES TO CITIES.
SHOULD INCLUDE CAL FIRE SHOULD
INCLUDE INCLUDE THE FORESTRY
DEPARTMENT IF WE'RE GOING TO
BEAT.
DEVELOP I MEAN EVEN EVEN THE
LUMBER INDUSTRY.
IF IF WORK CUTTEN DOWN --
WOULD THAT'S USABLE.
WHY NOT?
WHY NOT PROVIDE THAT TO THE
MILLS SAYS A SOURCE OF?
BUT WHERE WHERE WE CAN --
ENOUGH SEND THE STUFF.
OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
BIOMASS.
BUT THEY'RE JUST NOT ENOUGH
BIOMASS PLANTS. TO TO CONSUME
ALL OF THIS MATERIAL AND NOT ALL
OF IT NEEDS TO BE BURNED OR
PROCESSED WE COULDN'T.
FIND DIFFERENT WAYS. TO MOLD
SHARED OR TURNED INTO LUMBER OR
TURN IT INTO --
BIOMASS FUEL [inaudible]
BUT SOMETHING'S GOT TO BE DONE
THAT ON A VERY.
COMPLETE AND COMPREHENSIVE
SCALE.
UNPRECEDENTED I WOULD SAY.
AND THAT'S GOING TO REQUIRE US
--
TO TO WE LOOK AT OUR PRIORITIES
AND SAY WHAT'S MORE IMPORTANT AT
THIS POINT.
GIVEN THAT WE'RE LOSING OUR
STATE'S PRIMARY LUNG.
AND I MEAN.
THE PRESIDENT SAID CUT DOWN THE
FOREST CONSISTS ARE SO FEW.
I DON'T THINK HE MEANT THAT
[inaudible]
BUT BUT IT SCARES ME.
IT SCARES ME THAT PEOPLE BEGIN
THAT THINK THAT IT'S A VIABLE
PLAN IT SHOULD BE COMPLETELY.
OFF THE TABLE IT'S IT'S VERY
SCARY TO PONDER THAT WE'RE GONNA
CUT OUR FORCE DOWN --
CUT OFF OUR NOSE TO SPITE OUR
FACE IN YOU KNOW DESPITE HER
FACE I DON'T KNOW IT'S IT YOU NO
ANYWAY.
I WANTED TO ADD THOSE BECAUSE I
THINK.
IF WE'RE GOING TO COME UP WITH A
POLICY IT'S GONNA IT'S IT'S
GONNA HAVE TO BE A LITTLE
AGGRESSIVE.
IT'S IT'S GONNA REQUIRE
MULTIPLE.
PARTNERS THE UTILITIES.
BUT THE COMMUNITIES THAT.
THE I USE.
THE COUNTIES TO CITIES CAL FIRE
AT THE STATE.
ANYWAY THANK YOU MISTER
[inaudible]
SUMMARY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
RESIDENT PICKER THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY.
AND THANK YOU FOR AGREEING TO
MEET WITH MANY OF US ON A
PERSONAL BASIS TO HELP US BETTER
UNDERSTAND.
WHAT IT WOULD OUR TASK IS HERE?
WITHOUT A DOUBT TIME IS OF THE
ESSENCE.
WE DON'T HAVE UNLIMITED TIME TO
COME UP WITH A PLAN WITH A
PROPOSAL WITH THE AMENDMENTS.
TO S. B. NINE OH ONE WE HAVE THE
FINITE TIME.
AND LOTS OF WHAT WE HEAR IS
IMPORTANT.
THE OTTOM LINE IS WE HAVE TO
COME UP WITH A PLAN.
WHAT -- ROAD
AT THE LAST HEARING --
MISTER DALI MISTER WOOD TALKED
ABOUT THE VICTIMS THAT HOUSE TO
BE OUR NUMBER ONE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY IS TO MAKE OUR VICTIMS
HOLD.
THE ALREADY SUFFERED AND WE
CANNOT BE PLAYING AROUND WITH
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO WITH WHAT
THE RULES WERE ALREADY.
WE HAVE TO MAKE ARE VICTIMS HOLE
NUMBER.
ONE WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WAYS
TO PREVENT THESE WILD OF THESE
FIRES.
FROM STARTING IN THAT WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO MAKE SURE
THEY DON'T GROW IF THEY DO
START.
BUT SAFETY WE TALKED ABOUT
SAFETY IT'S EXTREMELY EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT.
AND THEN WE'LL FIGURE OUT THE
COST.
I DON'T THINK THAT --
AND I'M NOT SAYING THAT YOU ARE
HERE BUT A LOT OF THAT THAT THAT
THAT THE DISCUSSION HAS BEEN
AROUND THE COST. TO TO TO TO THE
UTILITIES.
THAT CANNOT BE OUR FIRST
DISCUSSION.
ARE THOSE THE SENATOR ISA GOOD
SENATOR HILL IS INDICATED WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT WHAT WE'RE GOING
TO DO TO STOP THESE FROM
HAPPENING AGAIN.
AND PICKED UP THE LAST HEARING
IN THEM DEED NOW HERE FOR THE
SECOND HEARING.
IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE PLAN IS
GOING TO BE IF WE ALREADY KNOW
THAT I IT THEM SAN DIEGO.
PUT THE PLAN TOGETHER THEY
TESTIFIED IT WAS A ONE BILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT.
DIDN'T HAPPEN OVERNIGHT.
AND YOU'RE RIGHT NOTHING IS
GOING TO HAPPEN OVERNIGHT BUT IT
WAS A TEN YEAR.
PERIOD.
SO THEY THOUGHT ABOUT THIS TEN
YEARS AGO AND BEEN WORKING ON IT
INVESTING.
YOU AUTHORIZE THEM TO TO TO
CHARGE THE RATE PAYERS TO SO
THAT THEY CAN PUT THIS PLAN
TOGETHER.
WHY AREN'T THE OTHER UTILITIES
LOOKING AT THIS?
WIRED THINK FIGURING OUT HOW
THEY INVEST THEIR MONEY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEIR RATE PAYERS.
ARE SAFE.
THAT IS OF GREAT GREAT CONCERN
TO ME.
I THINK THAT THAT DOES IT IS IT
WHEN I LOOK AT THE PLAN
[inaudible]
THAT -- BUT
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT HERE THE
VERY FIRST ONE ON WILDFIRE
PREVENTION PLANNING.
TIS UTILITY SUBMIT FIRE
PREVENTION PLANS.
IS ARE GOING TO BE A BASE BEFORE
THEY SUBMIT THEIR PLAN.
BECAUSE I CAN IMAGINE THAT YOU
THROUGH THE WORD WERE NOT SAYING
I'M NOT SAYING THIS IN A CYNICAL
WAY JUST TRYING TO BE A REALIST.
IF I'M GOING TO POLICE MYSELF
I'M NOT GOING TO PUT THE
STANDARD THE VERY HIGHEST GOING
TO SAY I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU THE
LEAST AMOUNT.
THEN YOU TELL ME WHAT MORE I
NEED TO DO BUT IS THERE GOING TO
BE A BASE WHEN WE ASK UTILITIES
PUT TOGETHER YOUR FIRE
PREVENTION PLAN.
ARE THEY GOING TO BE GIVEN A
BASS AND TOLD THIS IS FOR YOU
BEGAN AND TELL US EXACTLY HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO DO IT OR WERE
GOING TO SAY.
PUT TOGETHER A PLAN.
WHAT WHAT DO YOU ENVISION?
THEY OWN THE WE KNOW HOW TO BE
LOOKING AT THE PLANS AND ARE
ALSO WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
CAL FIRE TO PUT MORE SPECIFIC.
OH OH IT THE TO IDENTIFY AREAS
WHERE WE WOULD LIKE WELL FOR
THE%
PLANS TO BECOME MORE AGGRESSIVE.
IN THE UTILITY PLANS ARE VERY
DETAILED TO EACH ONE OF THE ALL.
HOUSE WILDFIRE PREVENTION PLANS
AND HAS BEEN INVESTING IN
WILDFIRE PREVENTION I KNOW WE
HEAR A LOT ABOUT --
IS D. GENIES SOLUTION AND THEY
DO HAVE SOME OF THE MOST
ADVANCED OF PLAYER CAPABILITIES
IN ONE VERY SPECIFIC AREA AROUND
OH WEATHER PREDICTION.
ALMOST BLADES THE ARE NOT THE
ONLY ONES WHO HAVE THAT
CAPABILITY IT BOTH OF THE CSE E.
AND P. JEANNIE --
IN INVESTING WHETHER ANALYTICS
AS WELL THEY JUST DON'T HAVE THE
EXTENSIVE --
NETWORK OF WEATHER STATIONS
LIKE.
WELL BUT I KNOW THERE ARE ALSO
OTHER.
AREAS THAT UTILITIES FOCUS ON
FOR EXAMPLE THAT THE VEGETATION
AND THE CHALLENGES THAT P.
JEANNIE FACES A VERY VERY
DIFFERENT AND FROM CHALLENGES
INSANE GAO.
SO HOME REPLICATING THE EXACT
THIS IT SEEMED YOU GO SOLUTION
ALL OVER THE STATE DOESN'T
NECESSARILY THE ANSWER AND
THAT'S THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
WE WORK ON IN MY GROUP.
IS REALLY ON THE STANDING THE
SPECIFICS OF DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS
OF WHAT THE UTILITIES ARE DOING
AND BRINGING THEM TOGETHER AND
HELPING THEM THESE CONVERSATIONS
TO SAY QUE.
LIKE LET'S DISCUSS WHAT BE WHAT
THINGS YOU GOOD THAT HERE WHY IT
WOULD IT WOULDN'T WORK IN P.
GENIUS OR IS SEIZE TERRITORY
CALLED YOU TWEAK IT TO MAKE IT
WORK.
HOME SO THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
ABOUT THE GOES ALL I ASK YOU
FIRST I WANT YOU TO UNDERSTAND I
WOULD NEVER.
IMPLY THAT WHATEVER WORKS IN SAN
DIEGO IS GOING TO WORK IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
I'M NOT AN EXPERT BUT I WOULD
EXPECT THAT IF DAD IS MY
BUSINESS.
I WILL BECOME THE EXPERT AND I
WILL SEE WHAT WORKS IN SAN DIEGO
AND IF IT HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL
WHY AM I GOING TO REINVENT THE
WHEEL WHEN SOMEBODY'S ALREADY
GONE THROUGH THE PROCESS.
FIGURED OUT WHAT WORKS THE CAME
OUT THAT'S LIKE A WORK IN THIS
AREA SO WHERE DO WE TWEAK IT.
IT SOUNDS WONDERFUL WHO'S DOING
IT IRWIN IS A BEING OF THE THAT
THE GUTS OF THE FIRE SAFETY
PLANS WITH THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT STANDARD THAT WE
ADOPTED.
WE HAVE OTHER PIECES THAT WE WE
CONSTANTLY MONITOR --
IN TERMS OF ADVANCING --
CHANGES IN TECHNOLOGY AND THE
SAFETY IN OUR GENERAL ORDER
NINETY FIVE RELATING TO OVERHEAD
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR POLLS.
WE HAVE A VARIETY OF OTHER
THINGS THE QUESTION IS HOW DO
YOU BRING IT TOGETHER IN A WAY.
THAT ACTUALLY CONTINUES TO
ADVANCE YEAR TO YEAR HOW DO WE
ACTUALLY COM SET THAT FRAMEWORK
WHO ARE THE RULES BUT SEE IT
COME TOGETHER IN A WAY THAT WE
ALL KNOW ROYCE HALL WORKING
TOGETHER TO PREVENT FIRES.
THE GENERAL ORDER NINETY FIVE
FOR OVERHEAD SO AS A LOT OF
IMPORTANCE OUT OF FIRE HAZARD
AREAS.
SO IT'S A QUESTION HOW DO HOW DO
WE REALLY USE THAT ADAPT THAT IN
HIGH FIRE HAZARD AREA SOON AND
ENDEAVOR BEEN AREAS WE USE THAT
PROTECT PEOPLE WHO ARE DOING
THINGS LIKE TREE MANAGEMENT FOR
ELECTROCUTION.
WE DO THAT TO PREVENT THE LINE
DROPS IT THEY CAN SOMETIMES IT
ACT LIKE TO KEEP PROPERTY
OWNERS.
SO THERE THE I'M JUST SAYING
THAT THAT THE GOAL HERE IS TO
LOOK AT THE AREAS WHERE ALL
THESE THINGS COME TOGETHER
AROUND FIRE HAZARDS.
IAN WHERE ELSE CAN WE BEGIN TO
LEARN AS WE START TO SEE HOW IT
WORKS TOGETHER.
AND THAT THAT'S A GOOD TO BE THE
CORE OF THE FIRST ROUNDS OF THE
THE SAFETY MANAGEMENT PLANS.
FURTHERMORE AS WE BRING
EVALUATORS AND AND THEY START TO
REPLICATE THE UNDERSTANDING OF
THE UTILITIES IS THEY BRING
THINGS FORWARD.
WILL CONTINUE TO ADVANCE THE
LEVELS I'M I'M NOT A BIG FAN OF
SAYING THIS IS THE WAY TO DO IT.
MIKE BY I THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO CONSTANTLY LEARN
AND TO ADVANCE SO THAT A RULE
DOESN'T BECOME A CEILING IT'S
THE FLOOR.
WE WILL START.
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT THAT IT'S NOT GOING
TO BE PERFECT BUT WE WILL GET
BETTER?
AND IF MY LAST QUESTION
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT GOES BACK
--
TO CENTER WHICH WAS TALKING
ABOUT IS THE UNDERGROUND --
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I RECOGNIZE HOME HOW EXPENSIVE
IT IS.
THAT IS WHEN WE HAVE NEW
DEVELOPMENTS IS THAT SOMETHING
THAT CAN BE INCLUDED SO THAT
pINFRASTRUCTURE IS SET UP.
SO IT IS GENERALLY BECOMING
COMMON PRACTICE AND IN LAND USE
--
IN IN AN URBAN COURSE JUST
BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T LIKE HAVING
POLLS IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD SO
FILL YOU GO OUT TO NORTH
NOTONOMUS HE'LL SEE THAT MOST OF
THE NEW DEVELOPMENTS HAVE
UNDERGROUND IT EMPHASIS.
HOLDER NEIGHBORHOODS LIKE SOUTH
OF TOMAS BECAUSE THE DEVELOPERS
WERE SMALLER THEY DIDN'TDO
MASTER PLAN DEVELOPMENT IN THE
SIXTIES AND SEVENTIES.
ARE YOU TO HAVE MORE POLLS SO I
THINK THAT'S THE TREND IT'S LESS
LIKELY TO HAPPEN WHERE YOU HAVE
A LOT OF SMALL DEVELOPMENTS.
SPENDING INTO THE WILD DUH
LEANDER BEEN INTERFACE --
WHERE YOU HAVE FIRE HAZARD TO
WHERE IT'S ONLY TWO TO THREE
BUILDINGS TOGETHER ONE
INDIVIDUAL WE HAVE AN OBLIGATION
TO GIVE THOSE PEOPLE ACTRESS
CITY?
PRINT AND SO THEY'RE NOT GONNA
DO THE UNDER GROUNDING ON THEIR
OWN.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A MASTER PLAN
DEVELOPER TO DO THAT AND THAT'S
WHY TALK ABOUT NEW DEVELOPMENTS
SO NEW DEVELOPMENTS BUT THEY'RE
GOING TO PROBABLY BE CLOSER AND
ALTHOUGH NOT ALWAYS BECAUSE
WE'RE SEEING A LOT OF MASTER
PLAN DEVELOPMENTS IN HIGH HAZARD
AREAS -- I
SUSPECT WE'LL SEE THAT HOWEVER
THEY ARE GOING TO FACE THEIR OWN
CHALLENGES AS THEY DO THAT AND
I'M NOT SAYING THAT WE CAN
REQUIRE THEM TO DO THAT THAT'S A
LOCAL LAND USE PREROGATIVE --
ONE IF YOU PUT IT UNDERGROUND IF
YOU HAVE TO REPAIR IT IT COSTS
MORE AND TAKES LONGER TO FIX THE
EXPERIENCING HURRICANE SANDY IS
YOU CAN GET COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE POOLS AND WIRES ABOVE
GROUND.
COULD BE BACK IN SERVICE IN A
WEEK [inaudible]
ON AVERAGE.
AND HURRICANE SANDY THAT
COMMUNITIES THERE WERE
UNDERGROUND THE AVERAGE IS MORE
LIKE THREE MONTHS.
AND THAT'S BECAUSE PARTICULARLY
WITHOUT SMART METERS TO PINPOINT
THE BREAK.
YOU HAVE TO DIG UP A LOT. TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE THE PROBLEM IS
FOR YOU GET SMART METERS HE HAD
SMART METERS BICU THAT STILL
DOES NOT.
MEAN THAT YOU GET EVERYBODY BACK
IN SERVICE QUICKLY. TO AS WE SEE
INNOVATION AND WE SEE FIVE G.
COMING INTO THE MARKETPLACE AND
PEOPLE WANT THAT BROADBAND
THROUGH ITS --
THAT'S THAT'S NOT TIED TO
LOCATION.
YOU GOTTA HAVE POLLS ABOVE
GROUND.
SO DOES CONTAIN COMMUNITIES ARE
LIKELY TO NOT.
CHOOSE UNDERGROUND A BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO HAVE THOSE POLLS
FOR FIVE G..
HERE WE HAVE TO HAVE A
BROADCAST.
THE MEANS GOOD BE ABOVE GROUND.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO HAVE FIBER
TO BE ABLE TO CARRY THE HIGH
LEVELS OF OF DATA THAT PEOPLE
ARE BROADCASTING.
IN YOUR HAVE TO HAVE ELECTRICITY
TO TO POWER THE BROADCAST.
SO THOSE PEOPLE WHO DO CHOOSE TO
UNDERGROUND MAY BE GOING FOR
GOING ON FIVE G. BROADBAND
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THE PSEUDO. TO USE CHAIRMAN.
AND SO I'M LOOKING AT THE
WELFARE MITIGATION PLAN RISK
ASSESSMENT RATE MAKING
ENFORCEMENT SO THE FIRST COLUMN
IS.
WILDFIRE PREVENTION PLANNING SO.
CAL FIRE WHO USED TO BE
[inaudible]
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY. TO THOSE
FORESTERS THAT ARE INSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA.
POLITICALLY LIEU CITED OUT
SOMETIMES TO THEY'RE BASICALLY
WORKING WITH.
YOU ALL AND THE UTILITY TO COME
UP WITH A RISK ASSESSMENT IN A
PLAN THAT'S GOING TO BE
IMPLEMENTED.
SO THAT'S THE FIRST COLUMN.
THE SECOND HOMES THEN YOU
SOMEBODY SS IS HOW MUCH IT'S
GOING TO COST.
AND THEN YOU PASS THAT RATE.
BONTA THE RATE PAYER AND THE
UTILITIES ABLE TO THEN PRECOOKED
THEIR COST TO DO THIS PLAN.
IN THE THIRD COLUMN IS
COMPLIANCE AND ENFORCEMENT.
SO WHEN A UTILITY DOES NOT
IMPLEMENT THE PLAN.
WHAT KIND OF ACTION HAPPENS
THEN?
OR HAS THAT NEVER HAPPENED.
NO IF YOU TURN TO PAGE EIGHT OF
THE OTHER STUFF I LEFT IN YOUR
OFFICE THE IT IS THE THE ANSWERS
TO SENATOR DODD'S QUESTIONS WE
ACTUALLY DETAIL SOME OF THE
MAJOR FINDS THAT WE'VE GIVEN FOR
FAILURE --
TO PREVENT FIRES SO THREE OF
THOSE ARE FOR ELECTRIC UTILITIES
FOUR OF THEM ARE FOR TELECOM
PROVIDERS --
THEY ARE FINE STAY ARE WHAT HOW
WE ACTUALLY TRY TO DRIVE THE
SOUTH.
NOW THERE'S THE QUESTION WHAT D
YOU DO WITH THINGS THAT DON'T
RESULT IN SOME KIND OF HARM.
THE THAT DATED DAY VIOLATIONS
THE THE FIX IT TICKETS AND SO
THAT'S PART OF WHAT WE'VE BEEN
STRUGGLING IN WORKING TO
ACTUALLY IMPROVE AND SO WE
ACTUALLY DETAILED SOME OF THE
PROGRAM SO WE HAD. TO BUILD A
TRUE.
ESCALATING ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM
AT THE CPUC INNARAL OUR LETTER
--
TO TO SENATOR DIED I THINK THE
AREA THAT IS GOING TO ALWAYS BE
PROBLEMATIC IS THAT WE HAVE A
DIFFERENTIAL.
ABILITY TO COMPLY --
COULD FORCE COMPLIANCE.
FOR THE ELECTRICITY AND THE
WATER YOU A UTILITIES WERE WE
PAY WE AND THE GAS UTILITIES
WILL HAVE THE FULL BOAT OF RATE
MAKING.
AND WE CAN APPLY THAT LESS SO
FOR THE TELECOM FROM MINORS WHO
ARE ALSO IN THAT POLL WHO ALSO
SOMETIMES CONTRIBUTE TO FIRES.
SO WHAT HAT WHAT WE DON'T HAVE
IS REAL [inaudible]
CRIMINAL.
ENFORCEMENT POWERS WE DON'T HAVE
THE ABILITY TO GO TO THE COURTS
WE HAVE TO DO THAT WITHIN OUR
OWN SYSTEM FOR THE MOST PART.
IT IT BE SAFE TO SAY THAT.
MAY RECOUP THE THEY'VE BEEN PAID
TO DO THE WORK SO THE INVESTOR.
IS REAPING THE BENEFIT OF THAT
RATE THAT WAS SET TO GO DO THE
WORK AND THE WORK NEVER GOT
DONE.
AND THERE WAS NO.
A IT WAS A FIX IT TAKE IT
THEY'RE STILL RECOUPING THAT
COST AND SO IT WEARS THE
INVESTOR ON THE HOOK --
FOR SAYS THERE ARE --
TWO COMPONENTS TO THIS THE ONE
THERE ARE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
ANDY A METHODOLOGY IN PLACE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY GET SILLY IS
SPENDING THE MONEY ON SAFETY.
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN ALLOCATED
AND IF THE DOME AND OF SPENDING
THAT MONEY WELL THAT GETS
FLAGGED IN THE IN THE WAY THAT
THE RATE MAKING WORKS IS
ACTUALLY NO ABILITY FOR THEM --
TO TO EARN THE RATE OF RETURN ON
THE INVESTMENT THAT THEY SERVED
IN MACON SAFETY AT ALL SO THERE
IS A GREAT MAKING COMPONENT
AUDITS THE COST TO MAKE SURE
THAT MONEY IS GOING WHERE IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE GOING AND
FLAGGING AND IF IT IS AND AND
THEN THERE'S THE SECONDARY.
COMPONENT GOLF.
SO WITH THE RULES AND STANDARDS
THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE SHE COULD
SPEND ALL THE MONEY THAT YOU
WEREALLOCATED THE STILL BE OUT
OF COMPLIANCE OR VICE VERSA YOU
COULD THEORETICALLY BE IN
COMPLIANCE AND NOT HAVE SPENT
THE MONEY RATES OF BOTH OF
THOSE.
SITUATIONS COULD THEORETICALLY
HAPPEN SO WE HAVE THE FROM
PROGRAMS THAT ARE THE COST SIDE
AND THEN THE NOTE PROGRAM THAT
FOCUSES ON THE DOG COMPLIANCE OF
THE ACTUAL PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE AND MAKING SURE
THAT IT'S CONSTRUCTED
MAINTAINED.
IN ACCORDING CALM IN ACCORDING
TO COATS.
SO JUST TO GO WILL DEEPER WHEN
WE FIND A UTILITY FOR FAILING TO
DO SOMETHING WORK CAUSING HARM.
THAT GOES TO THE GENERAL FUND
INCOMES FROM SHAREHOLDERS
GENERALLY.
BUT IT DOESN'T GO BACK TO
ACTUALLY IMPROVING THE
INFRASTRUCTURE HE GOES TO THE
GENERAL FUND.
SO I I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
I'M.
HEARING WHAT I THINK YOU SAID
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
THERE.
IF THEY'VE DONE THE WORK YOU GO
OUT AND CHECK SOME A CHECKS TO
SEE IF THE WORK'S BEEN DONE AND
IF THERE IS BEEN.
MORE [inaudible]
RECEIVED.
THEN COSTS CAN YOU'RE ALSO
YOU'RE ALSO REVIEWING THE COST
AT THE SAME TIME IS THAT CORRECT
[inaudible]
SO.
DEPENDING UPON THE PROGRAM WE
HAVE A LOT OF PROGRAMS REMINDED
YOUR SPECIFIC FUNDS IN
EXPENDITURES TO SEE WHETHER IT
ACTUALLY DID COSTS THAT.
SOMETIMES THOUGH WILL DO SOME
PLANNING.
WHICH IS THE RATE CASE --
AND LOOK AHEAD AND SAY THEY
THINK IT'S GONNA COST THIS MUCH
EVERYBODY BEATS UP THOSE NUMBERS
AND THERE'S AN AGREEMENT ON A
PRICE PER WILL SAY.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE YOU TRACK
THAT IN A SPECIFIC KIND OF AN
ACCOUNT AND THEN IN IN THE YEAR
TWO OR THREE YEARS WILL HOW WILL
HAVE A LOOK AT THAT ACCOUNT TO
SEE WHERE THEY'RE ACTUALLY
COSTA.
AND THEN IF IT DIDN'T COST THAT
MUCH THAT WE TAKE IT OUT OF YOUR
NEXT BUDGET.
SO THERE'S AND THOSE KINDS OF
TRACKING.
THAT THE THIS IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WE DON'T GO OUT AND LOOK
AT EVERYTHING THE UTILITIES.
TO THAT'S WHAT I THINK --
THE SPELL SHINKO WAS TALKING
ABOUT WHEN SHE SAID THE LABOR
FORCE WHERE HE ECONOMIC
REGULATOR SO WE TEND TO USE
AUDITS A LOT.
SO I TAX AGENCIES DON'T GO AND
CHECK YOUR BANK BOOK EVERY EVERY
MONTH TO SEE THE YEAR ACTUALLY.
PUTTING MONEY ASIDE PAY YOUR
TAXES TO DO IT AT THE END OF THE
YEAR AND FRANKLY SOMETIMES
THEY'LL GO BACK TO HOT IT.
AND SO WE USED THAT AS A TOOL TO
GENERALLY SEND THE MESSAGE WE
MAY BE CHECKING DON'T MESS
AROUND AND WILL WE CATCH HIM
THEN THAT'S A PROBLEM.
IF THEY DON'T HAVE THE THE
SYSTEMS AND PLACES ANIE OTHER
AUDITOR THEN WE REALLY START TO
TRIED TO DIAL DOWN THAT'S THE
CORE THING DO YOU HAVE THE
TRACKING SYSTEMS. TO SHOW US THE
U. INTERNALLY KNOW THAT YOU'RE
DOING THE THINGS.
CAN WE SEE THAT THOSE TRACKING
SYSTEMS THOSE THOSE THOSE
CONTROLS ARE IN PLACE.
CAN WE ACTUALLY THEN GO AND DO
SPOT CHECKS BECAUSE THAT'S A
MORE EFFICIENT WAY GENERALLY.
NOW THE QUESTION IS.
DO WE GO FURTHER THAN THAT AND
START TO USE PEOPLE TO GO OUT
AND WALK THE LINE AS WE DO IN
THE RAILROAD INDUSTRY WE WALK
EVERY FOOT OF TRACK TO IT EVERY
YEAR.
OR DO WE CADETS A VERY
TRADITIONAL WAY OR TO USE
TECHNOLOGY WE COULD BE USING
TECHNOLOGY IN THE RAIL INDUSTRY
TO DO THAT FASTER AND PROBABLY
BETTER.
BUT THAT'S NOT.
WHAT WE WHAT WE DO?
THAT WE ACTUALLY FOLLOWING
FEDERAL GUIDELINES.
HERE ARE QUESTION IS SHOULD ARE
WE GONNA START TO DEVELOP THE
TECHNOLOGY CAPACITY. TO DO THIS
THROUGH BIG DATA THROUGH --
THROUGH --
DRONES IN LIGHT ARE TO BE ABLE
TO GO MONITOR AND TO HAVE THAT
MORE OVERSIGHT BECAUSE IS THERE.
I HEAR YOU'RE SAYING THERE'S NO
I NOT TO GET.
COMPLETED AND JUST PAY A FINE
AND THE ROOM AND THE INVESTOR
BENEFITS THE HARVEST OF THAT.
I I I DON'T SEE THERE'S NO
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE THEY COME
FROM AN AGENCY THAT DID NOT --
EFFECTIVELY MONITOR YOU KNOW ALL
THOSE THE GAS PIPELINE INCIDENT
AND P. GENIES --
SYSTEM AND WE WENT BACK AND
SPENT A LOT OF TIME AUDITING
SOME PLACES WE FOUND THAT THEY
DIDN'T HAVE THE CONTROLS IN
PLACE AND WE DON'T CATCH IT
BEFORE.
ALL I CAN TELL YOU IS THAT WE
ARE WORKING REALLY HARD. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN BUT WHICH COULD TAKE ITS
TIME FOR ME TO ACTUALLY SIT HERE
AND TELL YOU THAT I THINK WERE
THERE.
I DON'T WANT I DON'T WANT TO
MISLEAD YOU ADELINE I OVERSTATE
THE CASE BUT I THINK WE GOT A
LOT MORE WORK TO DO [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MAYES.
THANK YOU OFFER FOR BEING HERE
AND THAT TAKING SOME THEM SOME
THAT IT COULD QUESTIONS ROUND
AND ENJOYING A LISTEN TO SOME OF
THE RESPONSE. TO THEM WE'VE HAD
--
MANY ARE CONVERSATIONS SOME OVER
THE LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON A HANDFUL OF US
THEM WORKING ON THIS.
AS SINCE JANUARY --
THEN YOU'RE RIGHT THE IT HAS
GONE FROM THE DEALING WITH
INVERSE CONDEMNATION --
TO THAT NOW --
IT SEEMS AS THOUGH THAT WE'VE
GOT TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO BE
ABLE TO REDUCE OF THE IMPACT OF
OF WILDFIRES ACROSS ACROSS THE
STATE. TO WANT TALK A LITTLE BIT
IF I CAN ABOUT THE IN WITH
INSURANCE I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE IS A QUESTION THAT HAVE
BEEN POSED --
TO YOU --
THE BUT IN REGARDS TO YOUR ROLE
THE PC'S ROLE MARIE IT IT AND
INTENT ESTABLISHING WHAT TYPE OF
OF LIABILITY.
INSURANCE AT THAT DE I USE
SHOULD HAVE A MAN IN REGARDS TO
ALSO A RECOVERING OF THOSE COSTS
AS WELL. TWO WE DON'T GENERALLY
REQUIRE LEVELS OF INSURANCE
BECAUSE THERE'S DIFFERENT
ACTIVITIES THE UTILITY HAVE TO
ENSURE AND IT'S A GOOD IT'S
ALWAYS A CHALLENGE TO KNOW
WHETHER THEY HAVE ENOUGH
COVERAGE.
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN MONITORING IN
AND IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT IN
TERMS OF FIRE IS HE CAN'T GET
INSURANCE?
SO WHAT DOES IT MATTER WHAT
LEVEL WE SAT [inaudible]
THE CAMPFIRE.
AND SO THAT'S PARTIALLY A HAY
QUE OUTCOME OF THE INSURANCE
INDUSTRY STARTING TO LOOK AT
THEIR RISK IN THE FACE OF
ADVANCING CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND THEY LOOK AT TEN YEARS OF
DROUGHT IN CALIFORNIA AND THEY
BEEN BACKING OFF ON THEIR
COVERAGE.
SO I THINK THAT THAT'S THAT'S
ITS A TACIT ADMISSION.
THAT WE PROBABLY HAVE TO START
LOOKING TO DIFFERENT MODELS
BECAUSE IT'S ALSO TRUE.
THAT THOSE SAME INSURANCE
COMPANIES HAVE BEEN LOOKIN AT
AND OTHER AND AND SOME OF THE
THE RETAIL COMPANIES HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT THE FIRE MAPS AND
SAYING.
WELL HOLY COW.
ARE WE GONNA START TO TO AREAS
THAT WE NOW KNOW OUR EXTREMELY
HAZARDOUS.
AND SHOULD WE JUST GET OUT OF
THE BUSINESS IS SIMILAR TO THE
TO THE POSITION THAT THEY TOOK
AFTER THE LOMA PRIETA
EARTHQUAKE.
WHEN MANY OF THE RETAIL
INSURANCE COMPANIES WHO SERVED
HOMEOWNERS IN COMMERCIAL AND
EVEN INDUSTRIAL CUSTOMERS?
JUST DECIDED THEY WERE NOT GOING
TO WRITE MORE POLICIES THAT
COVER EARTHQUAKE RISK HEARING
CALIFORNIA.
SO I THINK THAT THAT HARM IF WE
DID SET STANDARDS IT DOESN'T
MEAN THAT THEY CAN GET IT.
OR IF THEY DO GET IT IS GOING TO
BE SO EXPENSIVE THAT WE MIGHT
JUST SAY THAT WERE YOU PROBABLY
BETTER OFF SELF INSURING.
SO HOW DO WE EVERY BUSINESS HAS
GENERAL LIABILITYINSURANCE
EVERY BUSINESS DOES.
AND THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
I'LL USE AND THE APPEAL USES
THAT THE PTO USE WHICH YOU GUYS
DOWN FOUND THE DON'T REGULATE%
RELEASED THEM TO VERY LITTLE
EXTENT IF YOU DO.
THE P. YOU USE ARE ABLE TO US TO
TO JUST RATES TO BE ABLE TO
FACTOR FOR THAT THAT LIABILITY.
THE I'LL USE ARE NOT ABLE. TO DO
THAT SO IF THEY CAN'T GET
LIABILITY INSURANCE. TO BE ABLE
TO RUN THEIR BUSINESS AND TO
PROVIDE SOME CERTAINTY BOMB TO
THEIR CREDITORS.
I'M.
AT WE GELLED OUT WITH ON THE
STATE CONSTITUTION THAT SAYS
THAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE THE
FIRST PAYER.
AND RIGHT THE RIGHT TO CHECK FOR
A 100% OF THE OF THE COST WHEN
THERE MIGHT ONLY BE 1% OR 5%.
I'M LIABLE THAT THE SEAT DOESN'T
SEEM TO GEL TO ME WELL I
WOULDN'T ARGUE THAT IT DOES IT
DOESN'T SEEM TO GEL TO THE TO
THE CAPITAL MARKETS.
THESE UTILITIES DON'T RUN.
ON THEIR CASH RECEIPTS THEY
BORROW A LOT FOR NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SOMETIMES FOR
OPERATIONS BECAUSE THEY'RE
COLLECTING IN SMALL AMOUNTS SO
IF THEY HAVE TO PUT IN NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE THEY HAVE TO PUT
IN NEW.
SYSTEMS THAT THEY HAVE TO GO TO
CAPITAL MARKETS EITHER BONDS OR
THROUGH SELLING SHARES TO BE
ABLE TO GET THE CASH THEY NEED
THEM.
F. THOSE CAPITAL MARKETS START
TO SEE THAT AS THE FIRST PAY
YOUR WHICH IS WHAT THE COURTS
DECIDED THAT --
UTILITY SHOULD BE YOU HAVE.
ANY ANY RESPONSIBILITY FOR THEN
YOU HAVE TO BE THE FIRST PEOPLE
TO PAY IT'S NOT.
NECESSARILY A A A JUDGMENT OF
NEGLECT IT WAS THE COURTS WAY OF
AVOIDING HAVING.
TO DEAL WITH ALL THOSE CLAIMS
AND THAT WAS INVERSE
CONDEMNATIONS CALIFORNIA WHO HER
LAST TIME.
CALIFORNIA IN ALABAMA ARE THE
ONLY TWO STATES TO USE THAT.
SO THE CAPITAL MARKETS ARE
LOOKING AT THIS THEY'RE SAYING
WELL THESE GUYS MAY HAVE TO PAY
A LOT OF CLAIMS.
AND THEY MIGHT HAVE TO THEN.
PULL BACK CASH FROM OTHER THINGS
INCLUDING PAYING SHARES THE YOU
KNOW GOD HELP US IF THEY MISTER
BOND PAYMENT.
BECAUSE THEN THERE WOULD BE.
A UNWILLINGNESS TO INVEST.
ANNIE AND CALIFORNIA UTILITIES
THEY MAY ACTUALLY GO SO FAR AS
TO SAY THAT CALIFORNIA'S
BUSINESS CLIMATE IS IS IN
DISARRAY.
AND DECIDE NOT TO INVEST
ELSEWHERE I'D THAT'S THE KINDS
OF THINGS THAT HAPPEN WHEN
MARKETS GET NERVOUS --
WHEN YOU ADD TO THAT AGAIN THE
FACT THAT THE INSURANCE
COMPANIES ARE DEPARTING FROM
THIS MARKET?
AND HALL THAT FALLS ON THE
UTILITIES.
I THINK THAT THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY YOU SEE A LOT OF OF
INVESTORS REALLY DO THIS
DISCONCERTED ABOUT WHAT'S TAKING
PLACE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO I DON'T TALK TO THOSE
INVESTORS WITH THE LEGISLATURE
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO IS PART OF
THE REFORMS FOR THE P. YOU SEE.
CLAIRE THAT THOSE INVESTORS ARE
NOW ON PARTY'S.
IN OUR PROCEEDINGS SO TO TALK TO
THEM THEN TRIGGERS ALL OF THE EX
PARTE COMMUNICATIONS.
SO I JUST MADE THE PERSONAL
ASSESSMENT THAT I WOULDN'T TALK
TO THEM SO I DON'T HAVE REAL
CONFIRMATION OF WHAT THEY'RE
THINKING I CAN ONLY LOOK AT
THEIR PUBLISHED REPORTS.
OF HOW THEY LOOK AT THE CREDIT
OF THESE UTILITIES.
SO THAT'S IMPORTANT TO US TO
UNDERSTAND THAT BECAUSE IF IT
AFFECTS THEIR ABILITY TO RAISE
CAPITAL AND THEY HAVE TO HEAR
GOING TO HIT A A CASH SHORTFALL
AT SOME POINT.
THEY MAY COME TO US AND SAY OKAY
YOU'VE GIVEN US DIRECTION TO
SPEND THIS MUCH MONEY ON
ELECTRIFICATION A TRANSPORTATION
THIS MUCH MONEY ON BIOMASS
FACILITIES THIS MUCH MONEY.
ON VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WE
DON'T HAVE THE CASH AVAILABLE.
TO DO ALL OF THAT WHAT'S THE
PRIORITY.
SO THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
THAT WE WILL FACE.
I TEND TO NOT THINK THAT THERE
WILL BE BANKRUPTCIES AND
CERTAINLY NOT SOON.
BUT I DO SEE IMPAIRMENT TO
CREDIT RATING AND I'VE BEEN A
BILL YOU DO CAPITAL FORMATION
AND POTENTIAL LIMITATIONS ON
BEING ABLE TO FOLLOW THROUGH ON
SOME OF THE COMMITMENTS THEY MET
THEY MADE.
YOU MIGHT NOT BE THE RIGHT
PERSON TO ASK THIS QUESTION OF
BUT I'M.
HE DID I USED TO THEIR CREDIT
RATINGS HAVE HAVE DROPPED WHICH
IS CREATED THIS BIT OF UP A BIT
OF A CRISIS BECAUSE MANYOF THEM
WERE JUST ABOVE.
A JUNK BOND STATUS IS THAT AS
MUCH REVIEW IF I COULD I YOUR
LINE OF QUESTIONING IS SUSAN
WHOSE SOUND VERY MUCH IMPORTANT
AND IT GOES TO A LOT OF THE
HEART OF WHAT WE'RE HERE TO DEAL
WITH --
HOWEVER IN THIS PARTICULAR
AGENDA WE'RE GONNA TRY AND I
KINDA LET GO A LITTLE BIT SO
THAT THERE COULD BE AN ANSWER TO
THE QUESTION TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE THIS IS A REALLY SIMPLE
AND I'M MISTER CHAIR JUST A
MINUTE COULD BE BILLY BUT A YES
OR NO ANSWER.
I'M JUST IN REGARDS TO WHETHER
THE P. SAME IN THE SAME WAY THAT
THE VALUES HAVE.
YOU MIGHT NOT BE AWARE THAT WE
NEED NOT YET I MEAN IT MAY
HAPPEN I HAVEN'T REALLY LOOKED
AT THEM CAREFULLY A WHEN I WAS
ON THE BOARD OF THE SACRAMENTO
MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT PLACE
TO WATCH THAT PRETTY CAREFULLY
BECAUSE WE ARE TRYING TO SAVE
GETTING CHEAP AND LOANS BUT IN
OUT I HAVEN'T SPENT A LOT OF
TIME ON IT LATELY SO GREAT THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND THANK YOU
MISTER.
THANK YOU ARE WE'RE GOING TO TO
SHIFT NOW WE DO APPRECIATE YOU
BEING HERE AND SUPPLYING ANSWERS
TO THE THE QUESTIONS THAT --
CERTAINLY --
ARE OR TRYING TO GET AT SOME
REAL ISSUES AS IT RELATES.
TO THE URGENCY AND I KNOW THAT
THIS IS A PLANNING PROCESS AND
WE'RE GOING TO OBVIOUSLY LOOK AT
ISSUES THAT MAY GO BEYOND SORT
OF THE MORE IMMEDIATE ACTIONS
THAT CAN BE TAKEN BUT CERTAINLY
ON SAFETY.
THERE ARE A SOME VERY IMPORTANT
RESPONSES THAT YOU'VE BEEN ABLE
TO GET AND WE DO HAVE --
DETAILED A FULL OF QUESTIONS
ANSWERS THE QUESTIONS THAT THE
SENATOR PUT FORTH AT THE LAST
MEETING AND SO WILL TAKE THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION BUT WE WILL
CERTAINLY.
LOOK TO HAVE YOU COME BACK AGAIN
IF WE NEED TO TO BE MORE
SPECIFIC ON SOME OF THE
REMAINING --
AREAS OF INTEREST AND CONCERN
ABOUT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
SHIFT NOW IF WE COULD.
GO TO OUR NEXT PANEL IN THIS
KIND OF GOES TO THE MITIGATION
PLANS AND A LOT OF IT WAS BEING
PUT BEFORE YOU AND WE APPRECIATE
YOUR EFFORT TO TRY TO GET
THROUGH THAT NOW --
SPECIFICALLY AS IT RELATES TO
AYE ARE YOU PLANNING AND
IMPLEMENTATION WHILE FAR
MITIGATION PLANS.
NOW THIS MAY CREATE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS TO SORT
OF GO BACK TO SOME OF THE THE
ARE QUESTIONS THAT WERE BEING
POSED. TO THIS PANEL AND WITH
THAT WE THINK YOU AND THEY WILL
WELCOME OUR NEXT PANEL ALTERNATE
OVER TO SENATOR DODD.
I THINK YOU.
COLLISON BICU ON ITS BACK
[inaudible]
DO.
SKINNER COULD TAKE WE GET THE
NEXT PANEL THAT'S COMING UP FILL
HARRINGTON SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT
FOR ITS MISSION AND DISTRIBUTION
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON --
KEVIN DOSSO VICE PRESIDENT.
ELECTRIC ASSET MANAGEMENT PGA
NEED DAVE.
DIRE SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT SAN
DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC AND MARK JUST
OF ATTORNEY COALITION CALIFORNIA
UTILITY EMPLOYEES.
LOOK IF WE GO THE SAME RATE THAT
WE DID ON THAT FIRST PANEL --
WHAT WE'RE GOING TO START OUR
LAST PANEL FIVE THIRTY I'M TO BE
DONE HERE WE ARE TO BE DONE?
CO CHAIR AND I TALK ABOUT THIS
AT FIVE O'CLOCK.
SO -- I'D
LIKE TO GIVE YOU EACH FIVE
MINUTES IF WE NEED MORE DETAIL
THAN THAT --
WILL ASK YOU --
YOU NOTE SPECIFIC FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS TURNED OUT.
WHO'S GOING TO START.
THEY GETS ITS FILL VERY DID GET
SENT.
THE CHAIRMAN I WILL LEAD OFF AND
NOW GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN DODD
I JOIN HOPE YOUR VICE PRESIDENT
TRANSMISSION AND DISTRIBUTION
FOR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON.
BOB FIRST OF ALL WE APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU TODAY ABOUT A WHILE FIRE
MITIGATION STRATEGIES.
WITH PROBLEM AS YOU KNOW THE NEW
NORMAL WE HEAR SO MUCH ABOUT HAS
HAD A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT.
ON ALL OF OUR COMMUNITIES --
THE IMPACT IS VISIBLE IN
WILDFIRES SUTTON CALIFORNIA THIS
YEAR AS WELL AS LAST YEAR --
AND AS I THINK WE ALL UNDERSTAND
RIGHT NOW AT THIS MOMENT --
THERE'S A NUMBER SO GIVING
WILDFIRES ACTIVELY BURNING IN
OUR STATE.
AND UP ON THAT NO DOUBT I WILL
LIKE TO RECOGNIZE THE EFFORTS OF
OUR FIRST RESPONDERS NOT OUR
EMPLOYEES AYE INCLUDING LINEMAN
FROM IBEW TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT IT.
OUT TO THESE EVENTS WITHIN OUR
TERRITORY AND AT THIS MOMENT --
IMPEACHING THE SERVICE TERRITORY
TO ME DELAYED.
I I WANNA BE CLEAR ON ONE POINT
HERE --
SCE'S LASER FOCUSED ON ITS
ENHANCE WHILE FIRE MITIGATION
STRATEGY --
WHICH BUILDS UPON OUR EXISTING
HOW WELFARE PROGRAMS.
HOW THE SAFETY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES AND EMPLOYEES ARE
TOP PRIORITY AYE AND DEMANDS NO
LESS?
BUT IN THE FOLLOWING
PRESENTATION WILL SHARE WITH YOU
AND I DO HAVE A SLIDE DECK I'LL
BE REFERRING TO APPEAR OUT AGREE
TO THIS A PUPPY DOWN FOUR
MINUTES NOW --
THE DISCUSSION --
ON THE WELFARE MITIGATION
EFFORTS ALREADY UNDERWAY AND
HIGHLIGHT AREAS WERE RISING TO
THE CHALLENGE OF THIS NEW
OPERATIONAL BEFORE SYSTEM.
I'M NOT BEFORE LAST YEAR'S
WILDFIRE HIGH NORTHERN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AS HE ALREADY HAD
OPERATIONAL PRACTICES IN PLACE
TO REDUCE WILDFIRE RISK DURING
EXTREME WEATHER CONDITIONS --
OVER THE YEARS WE'VE ADOPTED
AREA COMPREHENSIVE WELFARE
MITIGATION PROGRAM A COMPRISES
THREE MAIN ELEMENTS OF FIRST OF
ALL IDENTIFYING RISK SICKLY
MITIGATING THAT RISKY THOROUGHLY
RESPONDING TO THE WILDFIRES RACE
WHEN THEY DO OCCUR.
NOW AS AN OUTCOME OF THE
STRATEGY OF A NUMBER OF
OPERATIONAL ACTIONS CURRENTLY IN
PLACE TO REDUCE UP THE RISK OF
WILDFIRE.
BODIES INCLUDES RESTRICTIONS ON
WORK GOING ON DURING RED FLAG
WARNINGS WE PUT THOSE IN PLACE
WHENEVER THERE'S A RED FLAG
WARNING.
I'M BOB BLOCKING AUTOMATIC
DEVICES IS AGO RE CLOSES IN OUR
SYSTEM WE DO NOT RE ENERGIZE
THOSE WHEN THERE'S A BAN ON THE
SYSTEM DURING A HIGH --
AYE REQUIRES TIME --
ALSO WELL OUR VEGETATION MANAGER
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THOSE LATER.
ABOUT WE HAVE A VERY ROBUST MAN
OUT F THE STATION MANAGER
PROGRAM.
AS WELL AS A PREEMPTIVE POWER
SHUT OFF PROGRAM SAFETY POWER
SHOP AMONG OTHER ACTIONS --
BUT I WILL SPEND JUST A MOMENT
ON A COUPLE OF THOSE.
TALKED A BIT ABOUT THE
RESTRICTION OF WORK DURING RED
FLAG WARNING PERIODS.
I'M TALKING A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT --
THIS ASPECT OF OPERATIONS --
INCLUDES ANNUAL MID CYCLE
PATROLS VEGETATION --
AND WE ALSO LEVERAGE AERIAL
LINES FACTIONS IN HARD TO REACH
LOCATIONS I'M IS PART OF THIS
AND I THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT
PART OF OUR PROGRAM.
WE ALSO PARTNER WITH FIRST
RESPONDERS AND THROUGHOUT THE
SUMMER CONDUCT JOINT PATROLS --
WITH LOCAL FIRE AGENCIES TO
INSPECT FOR DICTATION NEAR POWER
LINES WE CALL THIS OUR PROJECT
SANTA ANA --
LASTLY AND I DID MENTION THE
PROACTIVE I SHUT OFF HIS
OPERATION PRACTICES CAN REDUCE
FIRE RISK.
AYE IN A PREEMPTIVE WAY AWARE
UTILITY OR LIKE THE AS C. E.
ESTUDIAR PRETTY NAY.
UP JUST EMPOWER PREEMPTIVELY IN
VERY LIMITED A HIGH FIRE RISK
SITUATIONS AND ONLY DURING THE
MOST EXTREME WEATHER CONDITIONS.
TIME NOW WITH C. TURNING --
TO SLIDER I ACTUAR ON SLIDE
THREE NOW.
SEC SHOULD WE CONTINUE TO INVEST
SYSTEM HARDING OR ELECTRIC GRID
--
STAR WERE ON SLIDE FOR NOW.
S. C. SYSTEM SERVES FIVE FIFTY
THOUSAND SQUARE MILES AND
INCLUDES MORE THAN ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION POWER POLESWITH
APPROXIMATELY ACCORDED THEM
LOCATED HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS.
NOW BASED ON A WEATHER ANALYSIS
CONDUCTED A COUPLE YEARS AGO AS
HE LAUNCHED A COMPREHENSIVE POLL
REPLACING PROGRAM TWENTY
FOURTEEN WHICH CONCENTRATED
FIRST ON POLES LOCATED IN AREAS.
THE POSE BOTH HIGH WIND AND HIGH
FIRE RISKS AND ASSESSING THESE
FALLS AGAINST THE UPDATED WIPED
OUT WHEN STANDARDS.
SOLUTION OUR EXTENSIVE EXISTING
PRACTICES WHICH COULD A TWENTY
FOUR HOUR EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
CENTER --
AND THIS IS DOWN SITUATION
AWARENESS BOTTOM AN AROUND THE
CLOCK INCIDENT COMMAND TO USING
CONDITIONS MERIT AS HE'S
CONTINUING HAS AGO
METEOROLOGICAL MONITORING AND
FORECASTING CAPABILITIES.
SO NOW I TALKED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHAT WE'VE HISTORICALLY
DONE LIKE TO MOVE ON TO WAYS OR
ENHANCING OUR RESILIENCE.
SO AGAIN AS A LARGE PROVIDER OF
INFRASTRUCTURE SERVING YOU
GEOGRAPHICALLY DIVERSE AND
BROUGHT SERVICE TERRITORY WE
KNOW THE HARDING OUR SYSTEM'S
GOING TO BE ONE OF THE CORE
STRATEGIES.
UP FOR RISING TO THE CHALLENGE
OF YEAR ROUND WHILE FOR SEASON.
THE BESIDES POLL REPLACING
PROGRAMS I DISCUSSED.
I IT SEES HARDING THE DESIGN OF
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE IN OTHER WAYS
ON THESE A SIGNIFICANT AYE WE'RE
INCREASING USE OF FIRE RESISTANT
POLLS.
A COMPOSITE CROSS ARMS COVER
CONDUCTOR WHICH WILL BE A A
SIGNIFICANT --
INVEST IN ACROSS OUR SYSTEM.
AND CURRENT LIMITING FUSES AND
SELECT AYE FAR RISK AREAS TO
ENHANCE RESILIENCY OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND REDUCE THE
RISK OF IGNITIONS.
THAT'S YOUR RAP UP POLICE OF
OKAY TOM MIA GOT TODAY AND GOT A
GREAT DECK I GOT THROUGH IT
ALREADY SUBJECT SURE I I WOULD
LIKE TO USE A COUPLE THINGS I
THINK.
HISTORICALLY SCE'S EMPHASIZE
MITIGATION WILDFIRE RISK UP BUT
THE YEAR ROUND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WILDFIRES IN THE NEW NORMAL
ENVIRONMENT UNDERSCORE THE NEED
TO DO MORE --
WAS TAKING PRACTICE STEPS TO
BOLSTER WHILE FIRE MITIGATION
PLANNING.
AND BASED ON GOVERNOR BROWN'S
RECENT PROPOSAL A GREAT HARDING
ENHANCEMENTS.
ABOUT WE BELIEVE WE'RE ON THE
RIGHT TRACK.
AT THE STATE UTILITIES NEED TO
REEVALUATE EXISTING POLICIES I
THINK THAT'S BEEN A THEME IT'S
REALLY WAS DURING A GERMAN
PICKERS DISCUSSION EARLIER --
PROCEDURES AND STANDARDS AND
DEVELOP A COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH
A TWO HOUR FIRE MITIGATION
ENCOMPASSES OPERATIONAL
PRACTICES WHETHER MONITORING AND
SYSTEM HARDENING.
BUT THIS REQUIRES SIGNIFICANT
ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT THE GRANT
I THINK HAS BEEN DISCUSSED A
LITTLE BIT ALREADY AS WELL.
S. E. WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
REGULATORY AGENCIES FIRST
RESPONDERS AND FIERY DISEASES
WEALTHY COMMUNITIES OUR
CUSTOMERS LIVE WORK AND OPERATE
BUSINESSES TO ENSURE THAT OUR
EFFORTS.
ARE FULLY COORDINATED.
IT FOR THAT CALIFORNIA'S
CRITICAL ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE
AND THE PEOPLE THERE.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR DODD --
YEAH I CHAIRMAN HOLDER MY NAME'S
KEVIN DOW SO I'M NOW VICE
PRESIDENT ELECTRIC ASSET
MANAGEMENT OF P. JEANNIE AND I
AM THE OFFICER RESPONSIBLE FOR
OUR COMMUNITY WELFARE SAFETY
PROGRAM.
WE'VE UP PASSED OUT OF THE
PRESENTATION THAT WILL DEVELOP A
FEW AND I JUST WANNA HAVE SOME
OF THE HIGHLIGHTS IN THE CONTEXT
OF KEEPING OUR MY REMARKS ON THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE DOING ON THE
GROUND --
TODAY THIS FIRE SEASON --
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE'RE DOING TO
KEEP OUR CUSTOMERS AND OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE BUT BEFORE I SAY
THAT I I REALLY WANT A GUY WHO
HIGHLIGHT THAT OUR HEARTS GO OUT
TO THE THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE.
BEING IMPACTED BY THE WILDFIRES
THAT ARE HAPPENING TODAY.
I THINK --
LOSE THIS IS JUST AN
ILLUSTRATION OF HOW THINGS ARE
CHANGING.
IN OUR ENVIRONMENT AND I THINK
MAKES THE WORK OF THIS COMMITTEE
THAT MUCH MORE CRITICAL.
I ALSO A P. JEANNIE AND I ALSO
WANT TO MOURN THE LOSS OF AN
EMPLOYEE THAT --
WHO'S WORKING ON THE CAR FIRE
OVER THE WEEKEND --
IT SADDENS US TO TO YOU KNOW IN
THE WORK OF IN THE I GUESS IN
THE COURSE OF HIS JOB --
HE LOST HIS LIFE IT'S BEEN A
RESTORING SERVICE HIGH HAS
RESULT OF THE CAR FIRE.
WE HAVE NINETEEN HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES THAT ARE WORKING IN
RESPONSE.
TO THAT DITTY FIRES THAT ARE
BURNING HERE.
AND ALSO AND PUBLICLY RECOGNIZE
SINCE AND FAN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON AND SAN DIEGO
GAS ELECTRIC.
FOR THE MUTUAL AID THAT THEY'VE
BEEN PROVIDING US FOR THAT
SUPPORT AND ALSO THE IBEW --
WORKFORCE THAT WE HAVE THAT'S
DOING ALL THE HARD WORK OF OF
THAT RESTORATION.
SO WITH RESPECT TO OUR COMMUNITY
WHILE FIRE SAFETY PROGRAM THERE
ARE.
THREE COMPONENTS TO THAT THE
FIRST IS THAT WE'RE FOCUSING ON
BOLSTERING WILDFIRE PREVENTION
AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE --
IMPLEMENTING NEW AND ENHANCED
SAFETY MEASURES AND DOING MORE
OVER THE LONG TERM TO HARDEN OUR
ELECTRIC SYSTEM.
IN TERMS OF BOLSTERING EMERGENCY
RESPONSE AND PREPAREDNESS WE'VE
ESTABLISH A DEDICATED WILD FIRE
SAFETY OPERATIONS CENTER.
ITS STAFF TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
DAY AT TIMES THAT --
CRITICAL EED --
IT'S STAFF BY A TEAM OF HGHLY
INDIVIDUAL HIGHLY SKILLED
INDIVIDUALS KNOWLEDGE ONE
ELECTRIC OPERATIONS.
FIRE SAFETY METEOROLOGY AND
EMERGENCY RESPONSE THE CENTER
PROVIDES REAL TIME CONDITIONS
AND IS REALLY OUR EYES AND EARS
IN TERMS OF WHAT'S HAPPENING --
OUT ON OUR SEVENTY THOU SERVICE
TERRITORY.
THAT TEAM ALSO LEVERAGES
EXTENSIVE CONNECTIONS THAT WE
HAVE WITH CAL FIRE CAL WHO YES
AND A NUMBER OF A LOCAL AGENCIES
THAT ARE SUPPORTING US. FOR ALSO
EXPANDING OUR NETWORK OF A P.
JEANNIE OWNED WEATHER STATIONS
WE'VE HAD SIXTY SIX NEW SUCH A
WEATHER STATION SENSE.
MARCH OR ADDING EIGHT TO TEN NEW
STATIONS --
EVERY WEEK WITH THE GOAL OF
HAVING A TWO HUNDRED INSTALLED A
BEFORE THE END OF THE YEAR.
THE ARMY UROLOGISTS USE THIS
WEATHER DATA TO DEVELOP --
HAVE WEATHER FORECAST IN A
HUNDRED AND NINE INDIVIDUAL FIRE
INDEX AREAS SPREAD ACROSS HER
SERVICE TERRITORY.
AND THOSE WINTER THOSE WEATHER
INDICES ARE DRIVING OUR
OPERATIONAL BEHAVIORS --
ON THE GROUND.
IN TERMS OF ENHANCE WHETHER IT
EXCUSE ME IT IN TERMS OF ENHANCE
SAFETY MEASURES ONE HIGHLIGHT
FIRST THE WORK THEY WERE DOING
IN VEGETATION MANAGEMENT --
A PRESIDENT PICKER HAD TALKED
ABOUT THE REGULATIONS THAT WERE
ADOPTED WITH THE FOUR NEW
CLARENCE STNDARDS.
WE BELIEVE THAT THAT'S NOT
ENOUGH AND US WE'VE IMPLEMENTED
A PROGRAM TO GO BEYOND.
THAT THAT IS FOCUSING ON A
REVIEW REMOVING TREES AND FUEL
FROM AROUND ARE POWER LINES. TO
CREATE ESSENTIALLY A FIRE
DEFENSE ZONE --
THAT -- IS.
REALLY PREVENTS THE THAT
IGNITION OF FIRE BUT ALSO
POTENTIALLY PRETTY HOOKER EAT A
PLACE -- FOR
DEFENSE TO BEGIN.
THE THE AND THE SECONDARY WANTED
TO MENTION IN TERMS OF THE
ENHANCED OF NEW MEASURES IS THT
WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED A PLAN. TO
PROACTIVELY DE ENERGIZED POWER
LINES IN THE MOST EXTREME
CONDITIONS.
THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT CHANGE
WITH RESPECT TO P. JEANINE I I
WANNA REALLY EVER EMPHASIZED
THAT -- WE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE ADVERSE
IMPACTS OF DE ENERGIZING POWER
LINES FOR OUR CUSTOMERS.
OF THAT IN OF ITSELF CREATES AYE
IT'S ONLY SET ITS OWN SET OF A
OF SAFETY HAZARDS.
AND SO WE'RE WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH OUR COMMUNITIES TO
DESCRIBE --
THE IMPLICATIONS OF THAT PROGRAM
AND WORK WITH THEM AS FAR AS
IMPLEMENTING THAT.
THE LAST THING I WANT TO MENTION
IS THAT --
THAT WE HAVE --
DISABLED ARE WE CLOSING DEVICES
ACROSS THE HIGH FIRE THREAT
DISTRICT AREAS THIS COVERS
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND MILES OF
OUR SERVICE TERRITORY.
AND HAVE BEEN DOING THAT
ACTIVELY OVER THE LAST SUMMER --
PHIL HARRINGTON TALKED ABOUT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WORK THAT WERE
THAT IS HAPPENING IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON.
PARA WE ARE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE OTHER TWO UTILITIES AND ARE
IMPLEMENTING A SIMILAR PROGRAM.
THAT'S FOCUSED ON USING
INSULATED --
STRONGER CONDUCTORS NON WOULD
POLLS HARD NEW ENHANCED --
PROTECTIVE DEVICES.
AS WELL AS IMPLEMENTING
RESILIENCE ZONES.
HOW THAT WILL ALLOW US TO
QUICKLY INSTALL ENERGY RESOURCES
OBSERVE ARE AT COMMUNITIES
DURING EMERGENCIES THAT WITHOUT
ALL AND MY REMARKS?
COULD YOU GIVE ME ONE MINUTE
THOUGH AUTHOR ENHANCE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT I SAW THE SLIDE.
HERE TO THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT ABSOLUTELY WE HEAR
THAT PLEASE.
SO.
AS I MENTIONED --
THE OF THE TO THE CPC ADOPTED
NEW REGULATORY STANDARDS THAT --
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL CLEARANCES
SENSUALLY RADIO CLASSES AWAY
FROM OUR POWERLINES.
THIS PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO
REMOVE TREESOUTSIDE OF THAT
ZONE OF AND ALSO CLEAR
VEGETATION --
UNDER OUR POWER LINES TO REDUCE
THE THREAT THAT'S GOING ABOVE
AND BEYOND MEETING COMPLIANCE
REQUIREMENTS.
AND FOCUSING ON SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WERE MENTIONED
EARLIER TODAY ABOUT --
REMOVING BRUSH AROUND --
PROPERTY AGAIN IT IN IN
COORDINATION WITH EFFORTS OF
OTHER IN WITH OUR COMMUNITIES
OUR CUSTOMERS.
WE SEE THIS AS A SIGNIFICANT
ENHANCEMENT --
TO OVERDOING WE'VE ARE INSPECTED
FIVE HUNDRED MILES OF OUR LINE
AND WE ARE ENGAGING --
ALMOST.
SIX THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY --
MR GEYER.
POP CULTURE --
DIED AND CULTURE HEARD IN RUSSIA
COMMITTEE --
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY.
UP THIS REALLY IS A VERY
IMPORTANT TOPIC GO FOR OUR STATE
--
I I'VE BEEN A CG FOR THIRTY
EIGHT YEARS --
I WAS OFFICER IN CHARGE ZERO
SEVEN WILDFIRES.
AND REALLY BEEN INVOLVED OR
MITIGATION PLANS EVER EVER SINCE
THAT TIME FOR OVER A DECADE.
NERDIST AGENCY WE TAKE A VERY
PRO PROGRAMMATIC APPROACH TO
FIRE SAFETY.
EYES DIMENSION WE'VE LEARNED A
LOT OVER A DECADE --
THAT'S WHY WERE AHEAD AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO SHARE A LOT OF THINGS
pWHO DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
EACH
UTILITY HAVE A PROGRAM IN PLACE
--
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THE THE P.
TO SEE A REGULAR SHOULD REVIEW
THE PROGRAM --
AND THEN WE SHOULD BE DEEMED
REASONABLE IF WE MEET THAT
PROGRAM SO AS YOU THINK ABOUT
PUTTING THIS IN THE LAW THOSE
KIND OF THINGS GOING TO AFFECT.
BUT AS MENTIONED EARLIER WE
SPENT.
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS IN THE
LAST TN YEARS ON FIRE HARDENING
A WE NEXT FIVE YEARS WILL SPEND
ANOTHER BILLION DOLLARS
[inaudible]
BOB.
CAN WE STILL BE DUNCES ALONG
PROGRAM THAT MAY LOT OF PROGRESS
LIKE TALK ABOUT JUST THREE AREAS
ARE FAR MITIGATION PLAN FIRST
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS.
PA THAT MINIMIZING CLINICIANS
SOURCES AND SUPPRESSION AND
OUTREACH SO FOR SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS I KNOW SOME OF YOU.
HAVE ACTION BEEN DOWN SCENES OF
OUR WEATHER STATIONS THAT WE
HAVE OVER HER WEATHER STATIONS
OVER HUNDRED CAMERAS IT REALLY
DOES.
THIS BILL ALLOWS THIS A WEEK
BEFORE AN EVENT TO REALLY FIGURE
OUT WHERE WE ARE FROM A FROM A
FIRE AND WHETHER PERSPECTIVE.
SO THE SAME INSTRUMENTS INTAKE
YOU ALLOW ME A REAL TIME TO MAKE
OPERATIONAL DECISIONS.
WE DID NOT HAVE THOSE TOOLS
AVAILABLE --
BICU TEN YEARS AGO SO.
A BEEN OUR CAMERAS WE WORK VERY
CLOSE WITH CAL FIRE.
WHENEVER THERE'S IGNITION THIS
HAPPENED BACK THE LILAC FIRE IN
DECEMBER AND ALSO ON JULY SIX WE
ACTUALLY SAW THOSE FIRES IN
THERE AS BIG AS THIS TABLE.
AND THEN WE WATCHED THAT WE
WATCHES SUPPRESSION THE TOOLS
ARE JUST INVALUABLE.
FOUGHT SO REALLY WHAT IT DOES IT
GIVES IS MICROCLIMATE FORECAST
FOR EACH ONE OF OUR CIRCUITS IN
BACK COUNTRY SO THIS INFORMATION
IS TRULY CRITICAL.
BUT IN THE MINIMIZATION OF OF
FIRES A TALK WITH OF OUR GOODS
MANAGER PROGRAMS --
WE HAVE ABOUT FOUR AND SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND TREES LE IN OUR IN
OUR SERVICE TERRITORY.
PROBABLY THE BIGGEST A PART OF
OUR SUCCESS IS WE HAVE EACH ONE
OF THOSE TREES IN OUR GIS DATA
BASE AND HAD A DATABASE.
WE KNOW THE SPECIES A TREE WE
KNOW HOW FAST IT'S GROWING WE
KNOW IN LAST SUMMER'S TRIMMED
THE LATCH SUMS INSPECTED THAT
REALLY IS THE BASIS OF OUR
PROGRAM [inaudible]
WE ALSO THEN TAKE I HAVE A VERY
VERY DETAILED PROCESS THAT WE GO
OUT AND DO ALL THE PRE
INSPECTION OF THOSE TREES ALL
FOR SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND AND ON
AVERAGE WE END OF TRIMMING ABOUT
A HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
OF THEM BUT WE LOOK AT ALL THE
THEN.
WE TALKED EARLIER ABOUT AUDITS
WE OUGHT DEBT FREE INSPECTION
PROCESS --
THEN WE GO BACK AND EXIT WE WE
DROVE A HARD SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND REMOVED BY A THOUSAND
TREES HERE.
WE'RE PRETTY AGGRESSIVE AND WE
MATED THE MORE AGGRESSIVEBUT WE
TRY TO TEMPT TRIM BACK TEN TO
FIFTEEN FEET.
BAR SO THAT ALL THOSE TREES WILL
MAKE IT TO RECYCLE.
BOB THEM ONTO THE TREE TRIMMING
WILL BACK INTO AN ART OF THE
ACTUAL THE TREE TRIMMERS
HIMSELF.
AND AGAIN THAT'S ENSURE THEIR
CONTRACTORS TO DO A GOOD JOB AND
pSEASON GO BACK IN THE HIGHEST
FIRE THREAT AREAS AND DO ANOTHER
PATROL SO.
YOU REALLY NEVER BE KNOWS --
TO HE HAVE TO REALLY WORK VERY
HARD TO TREAT FOR ME WERE ALSO
USING SOME OF THE TECHNOLOGY NEW
TECHNOLOGIES MENTIONED EARLY
LIGHT ARE.
THAT HELPS IT SHOULD DETERMINE
HOW FAR TREES ARE WAVE MORE
FACILITIES WERE ALSO USE NET FOR
QC BY OVER INFRASTRUCTURE CSUS
NOT SPEAK OF INFRASTRUCTURE.
BOB WEAVER PLAYS STEP.
ABOUT FOURTEEN THOUSAND FOOT
POLES OF STEEL POLES WHEN WE DO
THAT WE PUT A BIGGER WIRE ALSO
AND WE SPREAD THE CONDUCTORS ALL
THIS IS REALLY.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE NEW CONDITIONS
NOW THAT WE KNOW ABOUT GOING TO
LOCAL CONDITIONS.
THROUGH OUR IMITATION WE'VE SEEN
WIND SPEEDS OF A HUNDRED MILES
AN HOUR AND CITY A GO OUT TELL
YOU NO ONE EVER KNEW THE WIND
BLEW THE HARD DIEGO.
SO WE REALLY HAVE SEEN A LOT
THERE.
ARE THREE MAIN PROGRAMS AND
HARDENING ARE OUR FIRM PROGRAMS
ARE DISTRIBUTION POLLS THAT WERE
ACTUALLY KNOW THAT SMALL WIRE
OUT THERE IS IS RECALL PUT A LOT
OF TIMES THE WIND STORM SEWER
FOLK WERE FOCUSINGON SMALL WIRE
REPLACEMENT.
IN AND HIGH FIRE AREAS WE HAVE A
TRANSMISSION PROGRAM.
WE'RE CHANGING OUT --
SHAWL STEEL POLES THAT'S WELL ON
ITS WAY ACTION IT WILL BE DONE
BY -- TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUT YOU HAVE ANOTHER
PROGRAM OVERLOOKING A POLL
LOADING NAME WE TALKED EARLIER
ABOUT --
HAVING COMMUNICATION PROVIDERS
ARE POLLS NOW THAT'S THAT'S A
BIG EFFORTS ARE USING LIDAR
TECHNOLOGY OUT THERE ALSO TO
SURVEY ALL THE POLLS ARE HIGHERS
FAR GREATER AREA.
RE CLOSERS --
THEY'VE BEEN OFF SINCE MAY OR
JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
ARE PART PROCESS IN THE PAST HAS
BEEN.
THE INTERMITTENT SPRING WHERE
BILLY ELEVATE CONDITIONS THAT
COME BACK ON AND IN DECEMBER
JANUARY WE NEVER TURN THEM BACK
ON THIS YEAR AND THEY WON'T BE
ON AGAIN UNTIL WE GET SOME RAIN
SAN DIEGO SO IT COULD COULD BE A
LONG TIME.
SO AGAIN A LOT A LOT OF WORK
THERE AND JUST LASSEN OUT REGION
SUPPRESSION WE HAVE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS TO OUR CUSTOMERS
ISSUES IMPORTANT.
ESPECIALLY THE POWER IS DE
ENERGIZED.
BOB WE WE ALSO WORKED VERY CLOSE
TO THE AGENCIES WE SHARE ALL HER
INFORMATION HELLFIRE OF SOME OF
OUR BIGGEST SUPPORTERS ARE CAL
FIRE THE CITY SAN DIEGO OTHER
FOLKS THAT WE WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH.
I AS FAR SUPPRESSION.
ARE WE ACTUALLY DO HAVE THE HELL
ANKARD SAN DIEGO IT CAN DROP
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED GALLONS OF
WATER --
SMALLER HELICOPTER TO SEE MOST
THE TIME COULD DROP THREE
HUNDRED SO IT WOULD ACTUALLY
THIS YEAR DISPATCHING THROUGH
CAL FIRE.
BUT WE'VE GOT MORE WATER THIS
YEAR THAT WE HAVE ANY OTHER HERE
IN THE PAST [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WAS DOWN
IN ALPINE AND SAW WHAT A GREAT
JOB THAT WAS TO GET THAT FIRE
OUT AS QUICKLY AS IT DID GET
OUT.
MISTER JOSEPH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I THINK IF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
I REPRESENT THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES
THAT INCLUDES IBEW.
TWELVE FORTY FIVE WHICH IS
MISTER DOESN'T MENTIONED LOST
MEMBER TO THE CAR FIRE THIS PAST
WEEKEND AS HE WAS WORKING TO
RESTORE SERVICE.
WE KNOW THE UTILITY LINES CAN BE
THE SOURCE OF IGNITION AND EVEN
ONE SPARK CAN HAVE DISASTROUS
CONSEQUENCES.
WE NEED A SAFER ELECTRIC GRID TO
PREVENT THAT SPARK.
WE NEED OUR ELECTRIC GRID
HARDENED SO IT'S LESS LIKELY TO
CAUSE A FIRE. TO GET THAT SAFE
DRUG SAFER ELECTRIC GRID WITH A
COMPREHENSIVE REGULATORY PROGRAM
THE FOCUS ON SAFETY AND WE DON'T
HAVE THAT NOW.
PRESENT PICKER HAS TRIED TO MAKE
THE SYSTEM SAFER MISS MALASHENKO
HAS TRIED TO MAKE THE SYSTEM
SAFER.
AND THEY HAVE MADE SOME
IMPROVEMENTS BUT IT'S OBVIOUSLY
NOT ENOUGH.
WE NEED TO HARDEN UTILITY SYSTEM
SO WE DON'T HAVE A REGULATORY
SYSTEM RIGHT NOW TO GET THAT
DOT.
AND WE NEED A CLEAR PROCESS
HOLDING UTILITIES ACCOUNTABLE.
TO THE WE DON'T HAVE TO HAVE
ANOTHER CONFERENCE COMMITTEE
NEXT YEAR OR THE YEAR AFTER THAT
ARE THE AFTER THAT TO DEAL WITH
SOMETHING THAT THE COMMISSION
SHOULD BE DEALING WITH.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO BEEF
UP THE WHILE FIRE MITIGATION
PLANS.
THERE FILE THE COMMISSION IS A
GOOD START.
WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
DRAWS HEAVILY FROM S. B..
TEN EIGHTY EIGHT WE'RE MAKING
GOOD PROGRESS ON THAT FRONT.
BUT WE RESPECTFULLY SUGGEST THAT
BETTER MITIGATION PLANTS ALONE
ARE NOT ENOUGH. TO DO IT WOULD
NEED TO DO TO PREVENT WILDFIRES.
AND MANY CLEAR STANDARDS FOR
WHEN THE UTILITY HAS BEEN
PRUDENT AND WHEN IT HAS NOT TO
THE COMMISSION KNOWS WHEN TO
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE AND YOU
DON'T HAVE TO MAKE THE DECISION
YEAR AFTER YEAR. TO GET THE
SAFER SYSTEM WE WANT AND THE
ACCOUNTABILITY THAT WE DESERVE.
WE NEED TO IMPROVE THE PROCESS
AT THE P. YOU SEE IN THREE WAYS
[inaudible]
FIRST.
WE CAN'T LEAVE SAFETY COSTS
BURIED IN THE GENERAL RATE CASE
[inaudible]
RIGHT NOW.
WE HAVE THE WORK FORCE PLANTS IN
ONE PLACE BUT WE HAVE THE COST
TO IMPLEMENT THEM IN A DIFFERENT
PLACE.
WE NEED TO FOCUS PROCEEDING
WHERE WE DECIDE WHERE THE
COMMISSION DECIDES HOW AND HOW
MUCH. TO HARDEN THE SYSTEM.
THE CURRENT PROCESS WHERE THE
COSTS FOR SAFETY COST FOR
WELFARE MITIGATION OR IN THE
GENERATE CASE IS NOT WORKING
THERE ARE JUST TOO MANY OTHER
THINGS.
IN THE GENERAL RATE CASE.
YOU KNOW YOU'VE GOT ELECTRIC
GENERATION CUSTOMER SERVICE
OPERATIONS SUPPLY MANAGEMENT
LOGISTICS SUPPLIER DIVERSITY
FLEET SERVICES I DON'T HAVE FIVE
MINUTES I'M NOT GONNA GO ON WITH
THE WHOLE LIST BUT YOU GET THE
IDEA.
THERE ARE DOZENS AND DOZENS OF
TOPICS IN A JOHN A RATE CASE SO
WHICH SAFETY JUST ONE AND
WILDFIRES JUST ONE SUBSET OF
THAT ONE THING.
SO WE NEED TO HAVE A GREAT CASE
THAT FOCUSES ON SAFETY AND
COMBINES THE SAFETY IN THE PLANS
IN ONE PLACE.
THIS LEADS TO MY SECOND POINT.
THE SAFETY PLANTS HAVE TO BE
TIED TO THE COSTS.
WE NEED TO HARDEN THE SYSTEMS WE
NEED TO MANY OF THE THINGS THAT
THE THREE TOYS HAVE JUST
TESTIFIED ABOUT.
BUT WE CAN'T AFFORD PERFECT
SAFETY WE DON'T HAVE UNLIMITED
MONEY.
AND SO THE COMMISSION HAS TO
BALANCE THE COSTS OF IMPROVING
SAFETY WITH SOME THINGS WE WANT
DONE.
YOU KNOW IT MAY BE THAT THE THE
BEST THING TO DO IS TO DO
SOMETHING EIGHTY FIVE TIMES THE
COMMISSION SAID YOU KNOW.
WE CAN ONLY AFFORD TO DO IT
SIXTY TIMES.
BUT WE NEED THE COMMISSION TO
MAKE THOSE DECISIONS.
I NEED TO DO IT TOGETHER IN A
RAPE CASE NOT SEPARATELY YOU
KNOW IN A WILDFIRE PLAN
PRECEDING THAT SAYS ONE THING AT
A RATE CASE THAT SAYS SOMETHING
ELSE.
THIRD POINT THIRD THING WE NEED
TO DO.
WE NEED TO USE THE SAFETY PLANS
TO SET THE STANDARDS. FOR THE
UTILITY TO MEET AND A PROCESS
FOR THE COMMISSION TO HOLD THE
UTILITY ACCOUNTABLE. TO MEETING
THOSE STANDARDS.
WHAT'S THE COMMISSION HAS MADE
THE HARD DECISIONS.
THAT'S SAFETY PLAN SHOULD BE THE
BENCHMARK ABOUT WHETHER UTILITY
HAS BEEN RECENT ONE PRUDENT.
IF UTILITY FOLLOWS ITS PLAN
THAT'S UNBEATABLE PRUDENT IF IT
HASN'T FOLLOWED ITS PLAN.
BUDGET RESPONSIVE FOR THE
DAMAGES AND SHOULD BE FINE.
THE COMMISSION SHOULD BE THE ONE
DECIDING.
WITH THE UTILITY ACTION WAS
REASONABLE PRUDENT.
AND WE DON'T WANNA BE BACK HERE
TO DO THIS AGAIN EVERY YEAR.
SO LEGISLATOR THIS COMMITTEE
SHOULD GIVE THE COMMISSION THAT
GUIDANCE GIVE THE COMMISSION THE
PROCESS.
SO THAT IT CAN DO ITS JOB AND
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO IT OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
SO WE WOULD TAKE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FIX THE UNDERLYING
PROCESS SO WE CAN GET ON WITH
HARDENING UTILITY SYSTEM AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND SETTING THE STANDARDS OF THE
COMMISSION COULD APPLY TO HOLD
THE UTILITIES ACCOUNTABLE SO WE
DON'T HAVE TO COME BACK HERE
AGAIN AND AGAIN [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IF YOU MISSED JOSEPH.
OKAY THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY WOULD BE TAKE
QUESTIONS NOW'S THE SENATE
CANNELLA.
IT'S JUST A QUICK QUESTION IS
FOR IS THE THE MANAGEMENT OF THE
FUEL OTHER ANY REGULATORY.
OBSTACLES RIGHT NOW THAT ARE IN
YOUR WAY FROM FROM PERFORMING
THOSE DUTIES AND IF SO WHAT ARE
THEY AND HOW CAN THEY BE
APPROVED.
I THANK YOU CENTER FOR THE
QUESTION I THINK ONE OF THE KEY
ISSUES IS THAT --
TO AS WAS ALLUDED TO A LITTLE
EARLIER THAT THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT SITUATION.
IS VERY DIFFERENT THAN OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE.
USING LIDAR SURVEYS WE ESTIMATE
THAT THERE ARE OVER A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY MILLION TREES THAT
COULD.
FALL INTO FOUR GROW INTO OUR
POWERLINES.
WAS SO ONE OF THE KEY ISSUES OR
FOCUSING ON IS HOW DO WE
ACTUALLY GET ACCESS TO DO THE
TYPES OF WORK TO GO ABOVE AND
BEYOND --
MEETING THE COMPLIANCE
REQUIREMENTS AND SO THE BIGGEST
ISSUE FOR US.
IS AND UTILITIES GENERALLY IS
THAT WE NEED TO GAIN PERMISSION
FROM PROPERTY OWNERS TO DO THAT
WORK AND SO.
I GIVING TOOLS THAT ALLOW US. TO
DO THAT IMPORTANT SAFETY WORK IT
IS REALLY A CRITICAL ENHANCEMENT
THAT -- IS
NECESSARY SO ONLY PRIVATE
PROPERTY ACCESS THAT'S THAT'S
THE BIGGEST TOP SCORE THERE ANY
AGENCIES WITH FISH AND WILDLIFE
FOR OTHER STATE AGENCIES THAT
ARE.
A OP SCHOOLS FROM THE PERFORMING
THAT WORK ABSOLUTE OF SUBSTITUTE
AYE AYE HE'S YOU KNOW WHO
THERE'S A PRIVATE PROPERTY
OWNERS BUT ALSO AGENCY LAND
MANAGER MANAGERS AND IT'S THE
SAME ISSUE --
NOW IT'S EVEN MORE COMPLICATED
WITH RESPECT TO THE THE
GOVERNMENTAL LAND MANAGERS IN
THAT THEY HAVE.
MANY MANY REGULATIONS AND LAWS
AND OTHER ISSUES THAT THEY HAVE
TO FOLLOW ALL OF WHICH TAKE
TIME.
AND GET IN THE WAY OF DOING THIS
FOR THIS CRITICAL SAFETY WORK.
WE'VE MADE SOME GOOD PROGRESS
WITH A WITH SOME OF THE FEDERAL
AGENCIES SERVE --
THE OF US FOR SERVICE BUREAU
LAND MANAGEMENT AND OTHERS --
BUT IT STILL HASN'T YET TURNED
INTO --
REALLY A CLEAR PATH FOR
COMPLETING THAT WORK.
OBVIOUSLY WE CAN DOING ABOUT
FEDERAL OF GOVERNMENT BUT IN THE
STATE GOVERNMENT LEVEL ARE THERE
AGENCIES THAT ARE AT HAVE YOU
IDENTIFIED AREAS.
THAT YOU WANT TO CLEAR OUT
BECAUSE OF A FIRE HAZARD AND THE
STATE AGENCY HAS.
HELD YOU UP TO WHERE YOU COULD
NOT PERFORM THOSE TASKS.
OKAY SO AS PART OF THIS SO THAT
THE SHORT ANSWER TO THAT IS YES
--
WE DEAL WITH --
THE STATE OF STATE PARKS
CALTRANS --
AND THOSE TYPES OF AGENCIES A
PROBLEM MOST THAT WE DEAL WITH
THE MOST OUT WE ALSO HAVE --
I GUESS THOSE ARE THE STATE
AGENCIES THAT ARE I THINK THE
THE THE LARGEST MANAGERS OF
LAND.
HERE WHAT'S A TYPICAL TIME FRAME
IT I'M ASSUMING YOU HAVE TO GET
PERMITS TO TO CLEAR THAT LAND.
WHAT'S A TYPICAL TIMEFRAME FROM
THE TIME TO THE TIME YOU GET A
PERMIT TO BUILD A TO CLEAR THOSE
TREES.
SO WE'RE STILL IN PROCESS WITH
RESPECT TO THE NEW PROGRAM THAT
I'VE TALKED ABOUT BUT WE YEAH
IT'S THAT WERE EXPECTING AS
RELATES TO THE STATE.
LAND MANAGERS OF SIX MONTHS OR
MORE IN ORDER TO ACCOMPLISH THE
WORKERS TO YOU'VE IDENTIFIED
TREES THAT COULD BE A FIRE
HAZARD.
AND IS TAKING OVER SIX MONTHS
FOR THE STATE TO PROCESS THOSE
PERMITS.
ARE NOT AT THIS POINT NOT AGAIN
I'M TALKING ABOUT ARE FOR THAT'S
WHAT YOU'VE GOT TO CHIU EXPECTED
SO WE EXPECT TO THAT'S WE'VE
SEEN AS IT RELATES TO OTHER.
WITH YOUR WILDLIFE MANAGEMENT
PLAN IS THAT CONSISTENT DO YOU
IDENTIFY AN AREA THAT'S LIKELY
TO CAUSE A BIG FIRE AND AND WHAT
DOES THAT WORK WITH YOUR PLAN TO
HAVEOVER SIX MONTHS TO TO GET
PREVENT.
A NO THAT'S WHAT THE THAT'S BY
MEGHAN WERE WERE NEGOTIATING AND
CASE BY CASE BASIS WITH OCEAN
WITH WHOM.
THE THE LAND MANAGERS WERE
PROPERTY OWNERS TO COMPLETE THAT
WORK IT WILL BUT LET'S PUT
PROPERTY OWNERS IN A DIFFERENT
CATEGORY OF A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
STEP THINK WE GOT A FRIEDMAN
BILL THAT.
WOULD GIVE YOU ACCESS TO PRIVATE
PROBLEM ASSUMING YOUR SUPPORT OF
THAT BILL YES ABSOLUTE COMES
BACK YOU KNOW LOOK FOR TALKING
ABOUT ALL THESE OTHER AREAS.
AND WE'RE NOT TALKING I THINK
FUEL MANAGEMENT REMOVAL OF THE
FUTURE OF A FIRE THAT FUEL.
AND WE ARE GETTING IN OUR OWN
WAY AT THE STATE LEVEL I THINK
THAT'S A REAL PROBLEM WITH THINK
THAT HE'S BE HIGHLY LA FEEL
LIKE.
YOU'RE NOT AGGRESSIVELY
ADDRESSING THAT ISSUE I FEEL
LIKE YOU'RE I DON'T TRY TO BE
KIND OF THESE AGENCIES BUT IF
WE'RE GOING TO CRAFT A BILL THAT
THAT DEALS WITH THIS ISSUE THAT
HAS GOT TO BE PART OF THAT.
THAT PLANNED SO.
IF THAT'S A PROBLEM I BET THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ESTA
HIGHLIGHT WHAT THE ISSUE IS AND
HOW WE RESOLVE THAT ISSUE I
THINK THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRICING
THAT POINT --
THAT IS AN ISSUE IN THIS IS A
ONE OF THE AREAS THAT WE NEED
HELP FROM THE LEGISLATURE ON TO
ADDRESS OKAY WELL I WOULD LIKE
TO AND UPON CONCLUDE BY
QUESTIONS BUT TO BE NICE TO HAVE
TO FOLLOW BACK UP ABOUT EXACTLY.
HOW WE CAN SOLVE THAT PROBLEM SO
WHEN FATHERS THAT BUT WHAT I
WOULD I'D LIKE TO DO IS FOLLOW
UP ON YOUR QUESTION AND THAT'S
THE OTHER JET GENTLEMAN IF
THAT'S IS IF YOU FIND THE SAME
ISSUE?
I IMPORTANT YOUR COMPANY YEAH I
THOUGHT I WOULD HAVE WOULD SAY
FOR A SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
ANSWERS YES --
I I THINK THE PRODUCT DAY
PRIVATE OWNERS HAVE BEEN
PROBABLY JUST ORDER OF MAGNITUDE
OF THE LARGER ISSUE VERSUS DEAL
WITH -- BUT
NONE WERE SUPPORT OF THAT
LEGISLATION IS WHILE THE
HELPLESS --
HELPLESS TO MORE AGGRESSIVELY
OUR OUR OWN IN THE TOUR JUST
PUTTING IN THE ORDER OF
MAGNITUDE THAT WE HAVE ABOUT A
MILLION TREES IN INVENTORY.
MUCH LIKE JUST EUGENIA
CONFUSION ANYWHERE SO WE DO HAVE
THE ABILITY TO TRACK WHAT'S
GOING ON THE QUESTION IS MOVING
AGGRESSIVELY TO THOSE TRIMS AS
WE SEE WE NEED TO DO THAT.
OUT WE TRIM AROUND A SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND A YEAR SO THE
AT THE VOLUME IS LARGE --
THINK ABOUT THAT'S ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND TREES A DAY AND I IN
OUR TERRITORY SO THIS IS A
ENORMOUS ISSUE AND MOVING THE
PRODUCTION LINE --
EXPEDITIONS YOU THROUGH THAT
ESPECIALLY AS WE HAVE A PERMIT
HANG UPS IS IMPORTANT.
THEY WERE BOTH THE SAME BUT I
CAN'T GIVE YOU SPECIFIC EXAMPLES
FOR PROCEED IN CITIES BUT YOU
KNOW WE WERE ALWAYS OUT THERE
TRYING TO GET THOSE [inaudible]
IN TERMS AND THERE THERE'S ALSO
AN ISSUE AROUND --
PROJECTS IS WERE AS WERE HARD IN
OUR SYSTEM THE SEQUEL PROCESS
CAN BE A LONG PROCESS AT TIMES
TO ADD SOMETHING ELSE THAT --
YOU KNOW THE QUICKER WE GET THAT
DONE THE FASTER WE CAN IMPROVE
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE ALSO.
JUST ONE FINAL QUESTION SO WAS
IT A HUNTINGTON LAKE A COUPLE
WEEKS HERE WHICH IS EDISON I
THINK UC CONTROLS THAT AREA.
AND THEY ARE TERRINGTON OF NE
TAKING DOWN TREES BUT IT SEEMS
LIKE THEY'RE JUST BEING LEFT IN
PLACE.
WHICH IS STILL FUEL AS FAR AS
I'M CONCERNED.
IS IS THAT PART OF THE ISSUE
WHERE YOU DON'T HAVE A PLACE TO
TAKE THE TREES ONCE YOU TAKE
THEM DOWN.
I AM NOT AWARE THAT HAS BEEN AN
ISSUE FOR US IN THERE IS SOME --
AREAS UP THERE THAT ARE ACTUALLY
FOR SERVICE SO I CAN'T SPEAK TO
THIS IS A VERY REAL YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THAT IS AN AREA WHERE
AGGRESSIVELY --
USING LIGHTER TECHNOLOGY --
OUR OUR PLAN IS TO REMOVE THOSE
BUT BUT DID AS FAR AS I KNOW THE
AT THAT BEING AN IMPEDIMENT TO
TRIMMING HAS NOT BEEN ONE OF THE
WELL.
I UNDERSTAND SO SO YOU FEEL
LIKE.
THERE COULDN'T BE ADDITIONAL.
OF RESOURCES FOR YOU TAKE THOSE
TREES ARE IN YOUR IF WE HAVE A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE MILLION
TREES OUT WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO
WITH THAT FUEL IS WHO LEGAL BILL
WOULD ALWAYS BE HOPEFUL HAVE A
PLACE FOR THEM TO GO AYE SO I
THINK ANYTHING THAT COULD.
RELIEVE THE POTENTIAL BOTTLENECK
WHETHER THERE'S ONE TODAY OR
WILL BE ONE IS HELPFUL SO
BIOMASS IS AN EFFECTIVE WAY TO
DEAL WITH TREES THAT YOU HAVE
TAKEN THE I'M REALLY COULDN'T
SPEAK TO THE BY MASSIVE ISSUE
AND IN PARTICULAR.
THAT.
THANK YOU.
WILL BE DEALING WITH THAT NEXT
WEEK DO YOU KNOW AS WELL A
CRISIS [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES.
BECAUSE OF THE CAST THAT WE HAVE
AT HAND.
HEALTH EACH OF YOU PRESENTED ARE
YOU PREPARED TO PRESENT TO THE
COMMITTEE YOUR PROPOSALS ON WHAT
SHOULD BE INCLUDED.
I I'LL START WITH THAT --
I THINK WE HAVE A FRAMEWORK AND
WE'RE OPENING WERE OPEN TO
ADDING TO THAT FRAMEWORK --
WE ACTUALLY HAVE A PLAN THAT WE
SUBMITTED TO P. YOU SEE IN THE
CAN DOWN OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS.
IT IT'S NOT FOR THE EXACT SAME
PURPOSE BUT BUT WE WE HAVE A
FRAMEWORK THERE AND DAY AND WE
WERE DEFINITE POSITION TO YOU
KNOW START THAT DISCUSSION.
AND I AYE BALANCE FOR US SO WE
CALIFORNIA EDISON BUT WE ARE
ALSO READY TO DO NOT HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION AND KEVIN MENTIONED
--
AT SOME OF THE OTHER
COLLABORATION THAT IS ESPECIALLY
HAPPENED A VERY RECENTLY IS
WE'VE -- AS
AS FOR UTILITIES WE COULD
COLLABORATE ON ON GOOD PRACTICES
--
BUT I DIDN'T WANT TO MAKE A
POINT I HESITATE SAY BEST
PRACTICES BECAUSE I THINK THE
POINTS WERE MADE A COUPLE OF
TIMES.
ALL OF OUR SERVICE TERRITORIES
ARE DIFFERENT SO WHAT MAY BE
BEST AND ONE UP MAY NOT BE BEST
MOTHER THAT THAT POINT WAS MADE
IN THE EARLY DISCUSSIONS.
BUT HAVING SAID THAT --
WE WE HAVE A PLAN AND A
FRAMEWORK I WILL BE MAKING A
FILING AT THE COMMISSION UP FOR
SOME ADDITIONAL WORK WE EXPECT
TO DO OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS.
ON OUR INFRASTRUCTURE I THINK
THAT WOULD BE ONE ELEMENT OF
FORMS BASIS A FURTHER DISCUSSION
IN TERMS OF WHAT STANDARDS
SHOULD OR COULD BE.
UP WERE READY FOR THE
DISCUSSION.
BUT I WOULD JUST ADD TO THAT --
IS BECAUSE PHIL MENTIONED THAT
WE WE HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY
CLEVERLY COST ACROSS THE AISLE
USE HERE TO DEVELOP A A BASIC
FRAMEWORK IN THE THAT THE IDEA
WOULD BE THAT.
ALL THREE OF THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES WOULD USE THAT SAME
FRAMEWORK AND AGREE ON THE
COMMON PRACTICES THAT MAKE MOST
THE MOST SENSE.
HAVE ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE AND
AND A SUPPLEMENT THAT WITH
SPECIFIC ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
UNIQUE.
TO EACH OF THE COMPANY SERVICE
TERRITORIES HIGHLIGHTING SOME OF
THAT YOU KNOW THE DIFFERENCES
IN.
OF THE VEGETATION AND TYPOLOGY
AND SOME OF THOSE TYPES OF
THINGS --
AND I THINK WITH WITH MILLION
AND HALF OF SO WHAT IS THE BEST
MOST EFFECTIVE WAY OF REDUCING
WILD FARM OF RISK [inaudible]
CENTER STONE.
BUT IF YOU ARE MISTER CHAIR
ENDOWMENT DON'T THINK APPEAR
TESTIMONY --
I WANT TO FOLLOW UP A LITTLE BIT
ON NOW CENTER CANNELLA IS --
COMMENTS HAVE HUNDRED TWENTY
NINE MILLION A DEAD OR DYING
TREES.
AND AND SPEAKING WITH SOME OF
THE UTILITIES --
ENOUGH AND A PRIVATE DATA
CONVERSATION --
THE ISSUE A SEQUEL COMES UP AND
IMPEDING YOUR ABILITY TO GET RID
OF SOME OF THE THE FUELS OUT
THERE COULD YOU EACH DISTRICT
REFLECT ON WHAT.
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SEE HAPPEN
WITH SEAQUEST THAT WOULD BETTER
ENABLE YOU TO DO.
YOUR JOB OF CLEARING VEGETATION
AND AROUND YOUR LINES.
SO I'LL ALL STARTIN --
HIGHLIGHTS SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES A THAT --
THAT WE HAVE FACED WITH RESPECT
TO THAT AND ALL I WILL GO TO THE
QUESTION ABOUT WHO WOULD HAVE
WOULD HAVE WE BEEN DOING WITH
THE TREES THAT WE'VE BEEN
REMOVING SO AND IMPEACHING
SERVICE AREA WE'VE HAD POOR THAT
WERE JUST DEVASTATED BY.
TREE MORTALITY SO WE'VE BEEN
REMOVING --
WELL OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
THOSE TREES EVERY YEAR IT TOOK
US ABOUT A YEAR TO STAND UP AND
GET PERMITS INCLUDING SEQUEL TO
HAVE A PLACE TO PUT BACK --
PUT THAT WOULD WE'VE WE WERE
ABLE TO ESTABLISH UP WE HAD TO
FIRE ATHAT A FILE ON A LUMBER
MANAGEMENT PLAN AND THE VARIOUS
OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
REQUIREMENTS.
AND SO I STREAMLINING IN A
DELICATE IDENTIFYING A LEAD
AGENCY THAT ADDRESSES THAT.
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION IS THE LEAD AGENCY
FOR MOST OF THE WORK THAT WE DO
IS UTILITIES --
THAT HELPS HOGAN HAVING A SINGLE
LEAD AGENCY WITH A CLEAR MISSION
IN MIND.
OUT WOULD BE A SUBSTANTIAL
ENHANCEMENT RELATIVE TO THE WORK
THAT WE DO.
SO YOU'RE SAYING IT IT BASICALLY
TAKES A YEAR TO GET OF THE
PROCESS TO GET A TRUE BOOTING
INTO TOOK PLACE WORK IN THE
COMPOST ENTERED OR DESTROYED.
BY I WANT TO CLARIFY THAT'S WHAT
TOOK US TO CREATE THE STAGING
AREA.
THAT WE NOW USE ON A REGULAR
BASIS SO WERE ABLE TO PICK UP
THAT WOULD INTO AN OVERLY
TALKING ABOUT PETER PLANTS ARE
PROBABLY IN THE IN THE COMING
WEEK BUT I KNOW THAT DAN
SPEAKING WITH SOME OF THE KICKER
PLANTE --
FOLKS WE GOT ABOUT TWENTY OF IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IF WE
HAD UNLIMITED FINANCIAL
RESOURCES ACCORDING TO THEM
MAYBE TWELVE YEARS. TO GET RID
OF A HUNDRED TWENTY NINE BILLION
TREES THERE SOME PICKERS.
THAT ARE ACTUALLY ON THE VERGE
OF CLOSING THE FAST ENOUGH FOR
THE DAY TO STAY IN BUSINESS SO
THAT'S KIND OF AN URGENT
SITUATION.
COMING NEXT QUESTION IS --
FOR FC -- IS
YOU KNOW --
OR NO NO I REPRESENT THE
IDYLLWILD AREA WE JUST HAVE THE
CRANSTON FIRE THAT WAS STARTED
BY AN ARSONIST WHICH IS A VERY
UNFORTUNATE SITUATION --
WHILE I WAS UP THERE TOURING --
THE SITE AND WITNESSING THE
GREAT WORK OF HELLFIRE AND ALL
THE THE BACKUP FIRE AGENCIES
KEEPING THAT FIRE OUT OF THE
CORPS OF IDYLLWILD IMPLYING CHO.
I I NOTICE THAT THE TRANSMISSION
LINES INTO AND I NOTICED SOME
VERY DISTURBING PICTURES WHICH I
LOVE TO SHARE WITH YOU
PRIVATELY.
THAT SHOWS ELECTRICAL LINES
GOING THROUGH TREES.
NOW THIS FIRE WAS AN ARSONIST
FIRE THAT STARTED AT THE BOTTOM
OF THE HILL.
THERE ARE ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND
PEOPLE THAT LIVE IN HIGH TO ON
HIGH GOAL FOR A FULL TIME.
THIRD TWO WAYS AND INTO A TIME
TO EVACUATE THAT HILL NOT
KNOWING THAT THAT FIRE WAS GOING
TO REACH A LOT OF THE
RESIDENTIAL UNITS.
BUT HAD A WHILE WIRES SPARK IN A
WIN EVENT.
IN IDYLLWILD AND IT HAPPENED IN
THE COR.
WE MAY NOT BE JUST TALKING ABOUT
SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED HOMES THAT
WERE LOST IN OF COURSE WE
EMPATHIZE WITH ALL THE RESIDENTS
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
SUSTAIN THAT DAMAGE BUT WE CAN
REPLACE HOMES.
AND WE CAN DISCUSS THE FINANCES
OF THAT BUT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
THREE TO FOUR THOUSAND PEOPLE
THAT COULD BE INCINERATED.
AYE IF WE DON'T APPROPRIATELY
GET OUR VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
UNDER CONTROL IN AND AROUND OUR
UTILITIES AND OF COURSE GETTING
RID OF FIVE DEAD TREES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO.
HOW DO WE ENHANCE THAT
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT SO WE CAN
GIVE A COMFORT LEVEL?
OUT TO THESE PEOPLE AND IT UP AS
A PART OF RISK ASSESSMENT AS A
PART OF SCE TO LOOK AT AREAS
THAT ARE COME FIND.
THAT IF WE DO HAVE A WILDFIRE WE
COULD SEE AN INK A MUCH HIGHER
INCIDENCE OF MORTALITY AS
OPPOSED.
TO DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE STATE
TO PRIORITIZE THOSE AREAS
DIFFERENTLY SO BOB BOB DOLE
START WITH OF A FIRST --
COUPLE IN AND BY THE WAY --
I'D BEEN FOLLOWING THE CRATCHIT
FAR VERY CLOSELY OBVIOUSLY --
AND I KNOW OUR TEAMS THROUGHOUT
THE AND THANKFULLY THAT WAS --
WAS EXTINGUISHED A RELATIVELY
QUICKLY I KNOW THE ANSWER COOPER
AS OUT THERE AS WELL SO WE HAD
--
CUSTOMERS AT THE END OF THOSE
LINES WHO LOST POWER.
ON RELATIVE TO OF AND THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT STANDARDS
AND HOW WE APPROACH THAT AND AND
MAYBE TO A POINT IN PARTICULAR.
I THINK THIS IS WHERE STANDARDS
--
AS WE CAN ALL ALIGNED ON THEM
ARE CRITICAL.
I ON THE DEPENDING ON THE LINE
OF FOR EXAMPLE THAT IS TRULY
TRANSMISSION LINE VERSES THE
DISTRIBUTION LINES --
WE HAVE AUTHORITY AND RIGHTS AND
ABILITY TO DO ADDITIONAL
TRIMMING FOR EXAMPLE
TRANSMISSION LINE HOW WE HAVE
RIGHTS OF WAY WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CREATE MORE
AGGRESSIVELY.
AND A SOMETHING WERE MOVING
FORWARD WITH ON DISTRIBUTION
LINES WHICH I OBVIOUSLY CAN LOOK
VERY SIMILAR TRANSMISSION LINES
--
WE DON'T HAVE A SIMILAR RIGHTS
OF WAY AND I THINK YOU KNOW WE
WE ARE AGGRESSIVE AS A SINGER
GAS LIKE FIGURES.
AND MOVING VEGETATIONS THOSE
LINES WE HAVE A DIFFERENT LEVEL
OF AUTHORITY SO THREE THAT'S
REALLY BE HEARD UP TO YOU BUT DO
YOU BELIEVE THAT THAT'S AN AREA
WHERE WE SHOULD BE REGULATING
THAT WITH ANCILLARY STRUCTURES
AND ACT AS SALES THAT COULD.
CREATE PROBLEMS FOR YOUR
TRANSMISSION LINES HIGH I THINK
I COULD MAYBE TAKE A STEP BACK
TO QUESTION ABOUT --
THAT IT IN THIS CONVERSATION WAS
PRETTY MUCH THE LAST DISCUSSION
WITH CHAIRMAN PICKER --
HAVING STANDARDS INCONSISTENT
STANDARDS ACROSS THAT STATION
MANAGEMENT AND OTHER THINGS IS A
REALLY TO WILDFIRE --
THAT THE UTILITIES A OUR REALLY
BE HAD COME PART OF THEIR
WELFARE MANAGING PLAN IS A
HELPFUL THING I I OBVIOUSLY MORE
DIRECTION IN THAT AREA --
REPAIRS MORE REQUIREMENTS BUT I
THINK IN MANY CASES --
THAT LEVEL DIRECTION TO BE
HELPFUL.
SO I GET AGAIN AND OBVIOUSLY
WE'LL BE LOOKING AT ALL OF OUR
LINES INCLUDING THOSE AND IN THE
IT OUT AWHILE THERE AND WE HAVE.
A INGRESS AND EGRESS --
PART OF THE HIGH FIRE AREA
DESIGNATIONS TWO AND THREE
ACTUALLY DO INCORPORATE --
EGRESS INGRESS AND OF THE NUMBER
POPULATIONS FUEL LOADING SUSAN
LAYER OF THAT ITEM THOSE
ELEMENTS GO INTO PRIORITIZATION
NOT ONLY FOR VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT BUT ALSO
INFRASTRUCTURE REPLACEMENT --
MY COLLEAGUE HERE LATEST EUGENE
MENTION A SMALL WIRE PLACE FROM
PROGRAM WE HAVE HAD THAT UNDER
WAY FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS WERE
ACCELERATING THAT IN HIGH FIRE
AREAS.
SAME WITH POLL REPLACEMENTS WE
DO TARGET AREAS WHO WE THINK ARE
MORE VULNERABLE THAN OTHERS SO
--
IT'S A COMPLEX ANALYSIS BUT BUT
THIS THE THE ELEMENTS THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT I'D
DEFINITELY FACTOR IN TO HOW WE
ASSESS AN AREA AND HOW WE FOCUS
OUR RESOURCES IN A PRIORITY
BASIS -- TO
TOGETHER TRIM VEGETATION ADDRESS
INFRASTRUCTURE CHANGES I'M AND
AND REALLY RESPOND TO THE
WELFARE SYSTEM JUST ONE FINAL
BUT QUESTION --
WE HEARD FROM THE PC THAT THEY
BASICALLY HAVE. THIRTY AUDITOR'S
BETTER IN CHARGE OF OVERSEEING
ALL THESE LINES THOUSANDS OF
MILES OF LINES.
AND TO ME IT SEEMS LIKE THERE
SHOULD BE --
A MORE DEFINITIVE PARTNERSHIP
WITH HELLFIRE --
TO ENSURE THAT. FOR IT OVERSIGHT
TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE HELPING YOU
pWITH YOUR YOUR VEGETATION
ISSUES
OF WHICH THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
YOU WOULD ENCOURAGE A PC TO
ENTERTAIN A MORE DEFINITIVE
RELATIONSHIP WITH A HELLFIRE
FIRE MARSHALS AND ENSURING THAT
--
YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT BEING
COUNTERS THAT ARE OUT THERE
LOOKING AT THE LINES AND HAVE
PEOPLE THAT UNDERSTAND FIRE
DYNAMICS LOVE THEM MORE
COMPREHENSIVELY I I I THINK THAT
COULD BE VERY HELPFUL THERE'S
ACTUALLY --
SOMEWHAT OF A MODEL LEASE A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE OF
UTILITIES AND CAL FIRE IS THE OF
PARTY LINE FEEL PREVENTION A
FIELD GUIDE.
IT REALLY ADDRESSES DEVICES BUT
I THINK THAT'S A VEHICLE THAT
THAT'S A DOCUMENT UPDATED EVERY
TEN YEARS IT'S IN ITS RENEWAL
CYCLE RIGHT NOW IS THAT MIGHT BE
A PLACE.
OF TRADITIONAL COLLABORATION
WHETHER IT'S THERE OR NOT I
THINK THAT LEVELS COLLABORATIONS
EXTREMELY HELPFUL PROCUREMENT.
BUT SENATOR --
JACKSON BLAST LAST ONE IT THANK
YOU -- GET
pSEQUEL WE MIGHT WANT TO LOOK AT
THE KINDS OF THE KINDS OF
BONUSES THAT HAVE BEEN PAID TO
SOME OF THE LEADERSHIP IN.
A PARTICULAR NO P. CHENEY HAS
GIVEN SOME SIGNIFICANT BONUSES
SAID THAT MIGHT BE AN ISSUE THAT
MAYBE THAT MONEY WOULD BE BETTER
SPENT.
TRYING TO DO MANAGEMENT PLANS
BUT KEEPING IN MIND THAT THAT
RIGHT NOW SAFETY IS I THINK.
HAPPILY FINALLY A ON EVERYONE'S
WAVELENGTH --
I'M WONDERING OF THE P. CHENEY
COULD CHIU --
A SHARE WITH US TOM HOW --
YEAR MAKING SAFETY THE OF YOUR A
BUSINESS --
CLEARLY THIS IS.
A CHANGE IN CULTURE COULD YOU
SHARE WITH US.
ARM HOW YOU GOING ABOUT DOING
THAT.
SURE ENOUGH IT TOUGH.
ARAFAT --
YES ABSOLUTELY AND IT'S ITSTARTS
WITH --
JUST HOW WE CONDUCT OUR DAILY
BUSINESS --
WHEN WE --
WE START EVERY MEETING WE FOCUS
ON THE SAFETY OF THE
PARTICIPANTS IN THAT MEETING AT
AND ALTHOUGH --
OFFICE WORKERS PER SE ARE
NECESSARILY EXPOSED TO THE TYPES
OF HAZARDS THAT WE HAVE IN THE
FIELD IT SENDS A MESSAGE TO OUR
ORGANIZATION.
THAT SAFETY IS IMPORTANT --
WE FOCUS ON THE HAVE.
NOTS ARE DALY TAIL BOARD
BRIEFINGS WITH OUR WITH OUR
CREWS AND EMPHASIZING THE THE
REALLY THE CRITICAL FOUNDATION
OF THE WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING
--
SO IT JUST IN TERMS OF HOW WE
DISCUSS AND HOW WE TALK ABOUT
SAFETY ON A REGULAR BASIS --
HIS OF HIS PART OF THAT WE HAVE
ALIGNED R. INCENTIVE STRUCTURES
COME TO HIGH DIDN'T INCORPORATE
A SIGNIFICANT EMPHASIS.
ON THE SAFETY OF EMPLOYEES AND
THE SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC THAT WE
SERVE AS WE CONSIDER THAT --
WE HAVE DEVELOPED A A NUMBER OF
HIGH WEEK BUT WE'RE CALLING OUR
ONE PGD SAFETY PROGRAM.
WHICH FOCUSES ON A EMPLOYEE
SAFETY CONTRACTOR SAFETY AND
PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND IDENTIFIES A NUMBER OF OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT WERE IMPLEMENTING.
CROSSED OUR AND ACROSS OUR
ENTIRE ORGANIZATION EVERY LINE
OF BUSINESS.
DOING IT THE SAME WAY LEVER
PRACTICE --
THE THE OTHER OTHER ASPECT THAT
I WOULD MENTION IS THAT WE HAVE
--
CREATED AN OFFICER LEVEL SAFETY
AND THE SAFETY LEAD TO REPORTS
TO OUR PRESIDENT WHO IS THE
SINGLE CHIEF SAFETY OFFICER FOR
THE ORGANIZATION AND AND IS --
INTERACTING WITH THE BOARD ON A
REGULAR BASIS IN TERMS OF WHAT
IT IS THAT MANAGEMENT IS DOING
TO FOCUS.
ON THAT AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST
--
WE ARE ALSO HOW FOCUSING ON
GRASSROOTS SAFETY SO REALLY.
SAFETY THAT IS IMPLEMENTED BY
THE PEOPLE ON THE FIELD AND
OWNED BY THE PEOPLE IN THE FIELD
--
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE ONES THAT
I'M HARD REALLY HARD.
DETERMINING HOW THINGS ARE GONNA
HAPPEN OVER THE COURSE OF THAT.
OVER THE COURSE OF THEIR DAY AND
OVER THE COURSE OF THE OPERATION
OF OUR COMPANY AND AND HOW ABOUT
WILDLIFE'S SAFETY.
WILDLIFE SAFETY OF THE BOOK A
COUPLE THINGS I WOULD MENTION
THEIR ONE OF THE HIGH.
THAT ONE OF THE KEY AREAS THAT
WE'RE FOCUSING ON IS --
BIRD SAFETY --
MIGRATORY BIRD ACT COMPLIANCE WE
HAVE ADOPTED A HAD A BIRD SAFETY
DESIGN SO HOW WE DON'T LET'S%
LOOK LET'S NARROW THIS DOWN
BECAUSE I'M I'M I'M NOT TALKING
ABOUT.
I'M SORRY I SAID WILDLIFE DENY I
MET WHILE FIRE SAFETY OKAY PUFF
PUFF PUFF.
OBSERVERS TRADE OF GIVE ME.
CANCER HAS TRANSIT QUESTION
THREW ME A LITTLE BIT
[inaudible]
REYES ARE WE TALKING ABOUT
MIGRATORY FOR EXPERTS WHAT IT
WAS MY FAULT SO LET'S GET TO THE
ISSUE AT HAND WILDFIRES.
HERE'S WHAT YOU'RE DOING WHILE
FIRE SAFETY SO I I I IT'S VERY
BRIEF REMARKS AND I COVERED THE
HIGHLIGHTS THEIR IN --
THANK YOU FOR THE CLARIFICATION
--
THE THE PROGRAM THAT I TALKED
ABOUT IS A IS A PROGRAM THAT IS
BUILDING ON TOP OF SUBSTANTIAL
INVESTMENTS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
MAKING IN OUR INFRASTRUCTURE --
OVER NUMBER YEARS JUST UP TO PUT
IT IN CONTEXT PEONIES INVESTED
OVER FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS IN ITS
TRANSMISSION ELECTRIC
TRANSMISSION AND DISTRIBUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE.
A LOT OF THAT WORK GOES DIRECTLY
TO THE TYPES OF MEASURES THAT
REDUCE WILDFIRE RISKS.
PACIFIC WE REPLACING SMALL
CONDUCTORS WITH LARGE
CONDUCTORS.
ARE REPLACING WOULD POLLS
CONDUCTING MAINTENANCE ADDING
ADDITIONAL --
AUTOMATION INSULIN THAT'S THAT'S
WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE'RE NOW
EXPANDING BEYOND THAT.
TO BE A TENSE ALL INSULATED
CONDUCTORS --%
AND NON WOULD POLLS IN THE
HIGHEST FIRE THREAT DISTRICT
AREAS.
YOU THE THING ON A MENTION OF
TALK A LOT ABOUT VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT BUT JUST TO PUT IN
CONTEXT.
PGD INVESTS I'M ALMOST HALF
EVERY YEAR IN A ROW CLEARING
REMOVING AND HANDLING.
OF VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AROUND
OUR HOUSE ARE POWER LINES THIS
IS A SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
ONE THAT HAS DOUBLED --
OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS SO THE
QUESTION THE QUESTION IS IS THIS
ENOUGH I REALIZED LOT MONEY YOU
HAVE THE BIG TERRITORY YOU'VE
GOT A LOT OF THE TO COVER.
IS THIS IS THIS PROGRAM IS IT
SOMETHING THE P. YOU SEE HAS
CREPT DIRECTED YOU TO DO OR SHE
IS THIS YOUR INDIVIDUAL COMPANY
ANALYSIS OF WHAT IS APPROPRIATE
VERSES.
WHAT ARE PERHAPS THE BEST
PRACTICES?
GIVEN YOUR CIRCUMSTANCES AND YOU
KNOW THE AREA YOUR WORK AREA AND
LIKE STP --
SAN DIEGO CLEARLY DIFFERENT OF
VEGETATION AND SO FORTH HOW TO
HOW WE VIEW DECIDED --
WHETHER A HALF A BILLION DOLLARS
OR HAVE YOU DECIDED IF YOU HAVE
THAT THIS IS SUFFICIENT.
SO I THINK SOME OF THE THEMES OF
THE OF THE HEARING TODAY HAVE
INDICATED THAT WE ALL HAVE TO BE
VIGILANT TO CHANGES IN THE
ENVIRONMENT AND RESPOND TO THAT
SO.
I I CAN'T SAY THAT IT'S ENOUGH I
THINK WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THE ENVIRONMENT --
IN THAT WE ARE OPERATING A
SUBSTANTIAL INFRASTRUCTURE AND
AND HOW IS IT THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO ADVANCE THAT IN THE
LAST QUESTION IS WHO SHOULD BE
MAKING THOSE DECISIONS.
SO A PGD SUPPORTS THE PROPOSAL
THAT THE GOVERNOR IS MADE WITH
RESPECT TO A PROP UP A PROGRAM
IN A PROCESS THAT --
CONSIDERS THE UTILITIES WILDFIRE
MANAGEMENT PLANS --
AND INCORPORATES THAT AND IT
INTO THE TRANSPARENT OPEN
PROCESS AT THE CPC USES.
AT WE WE WITHOUT MECHANISM IS
THE RIGHT MECHANISM FOR THIS FOR
THIS APPROACH NUMBER HALF THE
MIGRATORY BIRDS I THINK HA HA HA
HA HA.
SO I I'M GONNA FALL OF ONE WHICH
HOW LONG HAVE YOU BEEN ON THE
JOB.
GOT THIS SPECIFIC JOB YOU'RE ON
RIGHT NOW MISTER DEATH SO I'VE
BEEN IN THIS ROLE FOR ABOUT
THREE YEARS HAVE BEEN WITH A PGD
FOR THIRTY SEVEN AND A HALF
YEARS SO I'VE HEARD EVERYTHING
YOU SAID TODAY.
AND YET PGD WAS FOUND ELEVEN OF
SIXTEEN FIRES IN THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN A WILDFIRE
SEASON.
SO HOW DO YOU.
HOW DO YOU TAKE FROM WHAT YOU'VE
BEEN TELLING ALL OF US HERE AT
THE DIS TODAY?
AND THE FACT THAT ELEVEN OUT OF
SIXTEEN OF THOSE WILDFIRES YOU
WERE NEGLIGENT IN FOLLOWING
STATE LAW.
ON CLEARING IN --
I CLEARING FROM --
YOU KNOW THE POWER LINES.
THE OTHER BECAUSE HE FIRES.
SO THE THE ONGOING SAYS THAT WE
HAVE NOT SEEN THE RESULTS THE
CALIFORNIA INSTIGATION.
AND ARE ANXIOUS TO LOOK TO SEE
HOW IS IT THAT HOW IS IT THAT
THEY CAN MAKE THOSE CONCLUSIONS
WE DON'T WE DON'T KNOW HOW THEY
DID THAT.
AND I AT THE AT THE END OF THE
DAY WE BELIEVE THAT OUR PROGRAMS
HAVE MET THE STATE'S HIGH
STANDARDS FOR HARM. FOR
COMPLIANCE WELL.
FILM AT ELEVEN OKAY THANK YOU
ALL VERY VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE
ALL YOUR TESTIMONY.
LET'S CALL UP THE OUR LAST GROUP
BUT I'M A MEMBER.
THANK YOU WILL NOW CONVENE OUR
OUR FINAL PANEL.
OF THIS WILL DEAL WITH PEER YOU
PLANNING.
AND IMPLEMENTATION OF WHILE FIRE
MITIGATION PLANS AND AS THERE
COMING FORWARD.
TOM IF WE I A I DON'T KNOW IF
ANYONE.
HAS AN IDEA WHETHER NOT THEY
WANT TO PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC
COMMENT BUT IT'S ZERO SHOW OF
HAND SICILY'S AT THIS POINT OF
WHO.
WOULD BE LOOKING TO MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT [inaudible]
SELECT.
OKAY THREE PEOPLE I DOUBT.
OKAY THANK YOU.
THAT'S HELPFUL.
SO WE'RE GONNA WELCOME --
VERY MALIGN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION.
TERRY CROWLEY UTILITY DIRECTOR
CITY OF HILLS PER.
AND MARTIN L. ADAMS TO THE CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION WELCOME
ALL OF YOU.
OKAY -- VERY
YOU LIKE TO GO FIRST.
THANK YOU CHAIR HOLDING --
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS I'M VERY
MOLINE.
EXACTION DIRECTOR THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL YOU SO SOLUTION WOULD
REPRESENT OVER FORTY PUBLICLY
OWNED ELECTRIC UTILITIES AND
AGENCIES ACROSS THE STATE.
AFTER MY BRIEF MARSHALL HERE
FROM THE LARGEST PO YOU AND ONE
OF THE SMALLEST ABOUT THEIR
WILDFIRE PREVENTION EFFORTS --
AT THE OUTSET ONCE THEIR HEARTS
GO OUT TO THE VICTIMS OF THOSE
IMPACTED BY THE MEANWHILE FIRES
WE'VE EXPERIENCED IN THE PAST
TWO YEARS --
WE SHARE THE OPINION THAT THESE
DISASTERS ARE AN INDICATION OF
THE NEW NORMAL THAT REQUIRES US
TO THINK DIFFERENTLY ABOUT.
EFFECTIVE RESPONSE.
PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITIES ARE
LOCALLY OWNED AND NOT FOR
PROFIT.
OUR GOVERNING BOARDS ARE
ACCOUNTABLE TO OUR COMMUNITIES
AND THEY REGULARLY HERE FROM
LOCAL RESIDENTS A GOVERNING
BOARD MEETINGS. ONE TO TWO TIMES
PER MONTH.
AS WELL AS IN BETWEEN MEETINGS
AT PLACES LIKE THE GROCERY STORE
LOCAL RESTAURANTS --
MANY OF YOU HAVE SERVED ON LOCAL
GOVERNING BOARDS.
AND YOU KNOW THE STRONG COUNT
ABILITY THEY HAVE TO THEIR
RESIDENCE.
I'VE BEEN IN CALIFORNIA FOR
NEARLY TWO YEARS AND BEFORE THAT
I SERVE THAT IS BECAUSE THE
DIRECTOR OF THE FLORIDA
MUNICIPAL ELECTRIC ASSOCIATION
--
MY FOR MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS I
WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR DISASTER
RESPONSE WHICH IS PRIMARILY
INVOLVING HURRICANES.
OF THE TWENTY YEARS AGO FLORIDA
DID A POOR JOB TOP TO BOTTOM IN
ITS DISASTER RESPONSE.
AND AFTER SEVERAL YEARS OF BACK
TO BACK MAJOR HURRICANES WE
RECOGNIZE THE NEED FOR
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH.
WHEN OUR BIGGEST LESSONS WAS?
A SURPRISE.
WE LEARNED THE IMPORTANCE OF
FOSTERING A CULTURE.
WHERE UTILITIES AND AGENCIES
DISCUSS WHAT WORKS AND ALSO?
WHAT DOESN'T WORK?
FLORIDA TURNED THE CORNER ON
EFFECTIVE PREPAREDNESS AND
RESTORATION WHEN EVERYONE AGREED
TO WORK TOGETHER TO IMPROVE. TO
THESE ACTIONS WERE ALSO
ANALOGOUS TO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO SOME
DEGREE.
WERE LOOKING STRENGTHENING
UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE
BOLSTERING MUTUAL AID AND
STAGING CREWS.
EDUCATING COMMUNITIES IN
PREPARING RESIDENTS THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRE.
HURRICANE SEASON THERE IN
FLORIDA BUT THE ENTIRE WELFARE
SEASON HERE --
IMPLORING UPON RESIDENTS TO TAKE
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY BURIALS
ORDER I DON'T MEAN TO INTERRUPT
YOU BUT I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT FOR ALL OF OUR PRISONERS.
WE'RE GOING TO STICK TO THE SAME
FIVE MINUTE PRESENTATION.
THANKS THANK YOU.
ALLY AND AS WELL AS IMPROVING --
EMERGENCY NOTIFICATION SIMILAR
TO US SENATOR DODD AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOODS BILL SENATE
BILL EIGHT THIRTY THREE WHICH
CMU A SUPPORTS.
SO WE'RE AT AN INFLECTION POINT
NOW HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
AND I WANT TO TELL YOU THAT.
PEOPLE USE ARE COMMITTED TO
BEING PART OF A BROAD SOLUTION
TO THE STATEWIDE ISSUE --
WE IMPLEMENT PROACTIVE WILDFIRE
PREVENTION RESPONSE TO PROTECT
OUR RESIDENTS.
AND PREVENT WILDFIRES FROM
DEVELOPING AN SENATE HUESO YOU
BROUGHT UP THIS IDEA OF A MULTI
PARTNERSHIP EDGY --
WITH CPU SEEK.
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY UTILITIES
ALL WORK TOGETHER AND THAT'S
WHAT FLORIDA DID IN ITS
HURRICANE PREPARATION AND IT'S A
GOOD IDEA TO BEGIN THAT PROCESS
WHERE WE ARE --
AND IMPROVE GOING FORWARD --
AND AND SENATOR JACKSON YOU
BROUGHT UP OF TENDER JACKSON
STEPPED OUT BUT SHE BROUGHT UP.
LAWYER WHO WILL LEAD THAT AND I
CAN SAY THAT IN FLORIDA WAS THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION AND
THE OFFICE EMERGENCY OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
SO IT'S A GOOD IDEA TO BEGIN
THOSE EFFORTS --
WE COMPLY WITH RULES OF A
VARIETY OF FROM FROM A VARIETY
OF STATE AGENCIES AND WE
ACTUALLY PARTICIPATED IN FOR
YEARS.
AND THE DEVELOPMENT OF A BROAD
ARRAY OF CPUC SAFETY REGULATIONS
ALL PO USE FOLLOW THE CPU SEIZE
POWER LINE CONSTRUCTION
INSPECTION INSPECTION AND
MAINTENANCE REGULATIONS.
AND THIS INCLUDES THE RECENTLY
ADOPTED STATEWIDE FIRE THREAT
MAP AND THE SUBSTANTIALLY
INCREASED VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
AND SAFETY HAZARD.
CORRECTION REQUIREMENTS.
WE ALSO ARE UNIQUELY POSITIONED
WORK WITH OUR LOCAL FIRE
DEPARTMENTS AND FIRST RESPONDERS
HAS MANY PEOPLE USE OUR CITY
DEPARTMENTS THAT ARE INTEGRATED
WITH OUR OVER ALL OF THEM
STRUCTURE.
IT'S A NATURAL COMMUNICATION
PATH THAT FACILITATES EFFECTIVE
COORDINATION.
SO IN CLOSING.
OUR WANT YOU KNOW THAT UP HERE
USE COME IN ALL SIZES.
ARE URBAN RURAL FORESTED IN
DESERT LARGE AND SMALL AND WE
BELIEVE IN A FLEXIBLE STRATEGY.
THAT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT THIS
VARIABILITY.
A WHERE YOU TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE TO MINIMIZE THE IMPACT
OF WILDFIRE ON OUR COMMUNITIES
AND RESIDENTS THANK YOU.
Q..
AND NOW WE'LL HEAR FROM A MARIN
ADAMS AND MY APOLOGIES HERE WITH
THAT THE CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER
FOR LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT WATER
POWER.
THAT YOU VERY MUCH MEDINA FOES
PROMOTION OR WHATEVER.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO SPEAK
EVERYONE TODAY OF THERE'S BEEN
SOME GOOD QUESTIONS I TRIED
RIGHT DOWN.
THINGS I HAD TO OFFER ALONG SOME
OF THOSE LINES TODAY BUT I WOULD
LIKE.
TO BRIEFLY KIND OF HIGHLIGHT
WHAT LOS ANGELES DOES IN THE
AREA WILDFIRE UP PREPAREDNESS.
THIS IS NOT A NEW AREA FOR THIS
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN THE
END OF TWO THOUSAND SEVEN OR
BOARD DIRECTED US TO DEVELOP.
THE A WILDFIRE PREVENTION PLAN
AND SO IN TWO THOUSAND IN THE
ADOPTED THE FIRST PLAN --
AT THE TIME THAT PLAN IS
CONTINUE --
TO EVOLVE OVER THE YEARS AT
CLEARANCE AND BRUSH PROTECTION
AND INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS
IN SUCH AND SO WE DO HAVE --
AND HAVE REALLY VALUE TO THE
RISKS THAT WE SEE IN TERMS OF
WILDFIRE EXPOSURE TO THE CITY
INTO ITS RESIDENTS AND TO THE
AREAS THAT ARE THAT ARE WIRES GO
THROUGH.
AND WE DO TRY TO MITIGATE THOSE
IN THE SENATE ACTIVE IN OUR
UTILITY FOR THE LAST DECADE
PLUS.
AND A METAPHOR IN OUR NEXT BOARD
MEETING IN TWO WEEKS OR BOARD
WILL HEAR THE LATEST UPDATE AND
ADOPT THE LATEST STANDARDS TO
WILD FIRE PROTECTION PLAN.
I'M SERIOUS INNER JACKSON HAD TO
GO ON SHOULD S. COUPLE TIMES A
QUESTION OF WHO SHOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE WHO SHOULD ENFORCE.
THE RULES THAT I WILL SAY THAT
IN A PUBLIC UTILITY --
WE DO HAVE SOME WE NEED A
RESPONSE ON THAT'S OUR BOARD OF
COMMISSIONERS AND THE RESPONSE
OF THE CITY COUNCIL A GROUP OF
ELECTED OFFICIALS WHO
RESPONSIBLE TO THE PUBLIC WHO
ARE WHO ARE ARE OWNERS AND SO.
WE HAVE A VERY DIRECT LINES
RESPONSIBILITIES VERY CLEAR WHO
WE ANSWERED TO SO ON I WOULD SAY
THAT -- IT'S
DIFFERENT IN DIFFERENT SITUATION
BUT IN A PUBLIC UTILITY
SITUATION WHILE THERE MAY BE
SOME ROLL UP AND CHECK IN WITH
THE STATE BECAUSE A LOT OF
THINGS THAT WE'VE IMPLEMENTED
ARE CONSISTENT WITH STATE
STANDARDS.
AND THINGS OF THE SEA HERB PC
WOULD DO BOBBING BUT WE DO HAVE
CREOLIZED RESPONSE REALLY WHO WE
HAVE TO ANSWER TO AND WHO ARE
JOBS ARE BEHOLDEN TO IN AND WE
RESPECT THAT LINE OF AUTHORITY
YES.
AS A BEING THE BOSSES OF THAT WE
NEED TO ANSWER.
NOW THE SECOND PAGE IS A HANNAH
I HOPE YOU WILL RECEIVE THEIR I
FIRE AND AND WINDY AREAS OWNS A
THIS IS JUST THAT BUT THERE'S A
MAP OF LOS ANGELES.
COME BE YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE
LARGE SIX WANT TO SIT IN THE
COUNTRY OF FOUR MILLION PEOPLE
SERVED LOS ANGELES.
HIM HAVE BUT ONE AND A HALF
MILLION SERVICE CONNECTIONS --
WITHIN THE CITY AND STRETCHING
OF OUR TRANSMISSION WHICH
REACHES FIVE STATES WEAVER
GATHER POWER FOR LOS ANGELES
FROM FIVE STATES WE HAVE ABOUT
THIRTEEN THOUSAND MILES OF
CONDUCTORS.
ON THE IN THE CITY ITSELF THE
FIRE ZONES ARE PRINCIPALLY
AROUND THE SANTA MONICA
MOUNTAINS AND THE RIM OF THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY AS YOU SEE.
NOW THE ONLY PLEASE A CALPERS
REALLY IDENTIFIED IS SET UP ROOM
THE SAN FERNANDO VALLEY AND IN
YELLOW SHOWN AREAS AND WE BY
THIS HIGH WIND AREAS THAT WE'RE
CAN.
CERTAINLY WE THINK ABOUT YOU
KNOW THE DENSITY OF LOS ANGELES
WELFARE RISK IS STILL VERY REAL
THERE ARE ELEVEN NUMBER OF RURAL
AREAS EVEN WITHIN.
ITSELF WITHIN ITS FOREIGN
SEVENTY FIVE SQUARE MILES.
WE HAVE MAJOR FIRE SUCH AS THE
BEL AIR FIRE THE WORST FIRED HIS
TO THE CITY OVER FOUR HUNDRED
HOMES LOS.
WE HAD THE YES STATION FIRE --
THAT THE HIT SERIES THE NORTH
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY THE CREEK
FIRE LAST YEAR AND THE HUNGER TO
HUNT AREA.
THAN THE SKIRBALL FIRE RIGHT IN
THE MIDDLE OF LOS ANGELES HOW
RIGHT ABOVE BILL AIR AND THAT
THE IN NEENAH WI PUTTING.
YOU KNOW SUBSTANTIAL REFORMS OF
PEOPLE AT RISK BECAUSE OF THE
DENSITY OF THE CITY SO.
ALTHOUGH WE DON'T SEE THE THE
SPREAD OF THAT SOME OF THE I OR
YOU SEE IN TERMS OF THEIR
FACILITIES RECEIVED A LOT OF
RISK WITHIN LOS ANGELES.
THE SAME TIME BECAUSE WERE IN LA
WE HAVE THE ADVANTAGE OF BEING
CLOSE TO LIVE IT RELATED TO THE
LA FIRE.
TO WHO HAS A FIVE TO SEVEN
MINUTE NATURAL.
TIME TO MOST INCIDENT SO IT'S
VERY DIFFERENT THAN A RURAL
SETTING BUT NONE THE LESS THAT
WE HAVE A LOT OF OF RISK THAT WE
HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF NEXT LIKE
TALKS ABOUT SUMMER CONSTRUCTION
STANDARDS WE'VE ADOPTED A NUMBER
OF STANDARDS FOR CONSTRUCTION
HIGHER FIRES OWNS.
AND HIGH WINDS OWNS NOT ONE OF
THE FIRST THING WE DID WAS GO TO
A LARGER HIGH --
HAVE YOUR CONDUCTORS IN THOSE
AREAS BROTHERS WAH COPPER OR
WHETHER IT'S ALUMINUM CONDUCTOR
STEEL -- WE
HAVE HIGHER READINGS FOR WILL BE
USED IN THOSE ZONES.
WE ALSO CHANGE OUR SPEAK SING
FROM WHAT'S NORMALLY --
CALLED FOR IN STATE STANDARDS TO
LAUNDER SPACING BETWEEN WIRES
AND THAT MEANS THAT WHEN THE
WIND BLOWS.
THAT IS IF THE WHAT CONDUCTORS
MOVE IS LESS CHANCE OF THEY'LL
SLAP TOGETHER AND CREATE A FIRE
RISK IN SO THAT ALONE HAS A LOT
--
TO THE SEAT.
THAT WE HAVE PRUDENT THINGS TO
COVER SOME OF THEBEAR
CONDUCTORS IN CERTAIN AREAS.
AND WE ALSO A GREATER WIND
LOADING A CALIFORNIA NGUYEN
LOTUS LITTLE OVER FIFTY TO HAVE
MILES OUR FOR FOR A DESIGN
PURPOSES.
AND WE'RE USING EIGHTY MILES AN
HOURS ARE DESIGNED PURPOSE WHEN
BOATS WERE LOOKING AT HIGH
CANYON WINS.
BUT BASS OF WE'VE WE'VE
STRENGTHENED OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THESE AREAS THAT WE BELIEVE
ARE MOST PRONE TO HAVE TO FIRE
THREAT.
THE NEXT SLIDE TALKS WITHOUT THE
WHOLE ISSUE OF FUEL SOURCE
MANAGEMENT WHICH IS A BIG ISSUE
THE STATEWIDE.
WE BEGAN WITH OUR OF FIRE
PREVENTION PROGRAM THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PLAN IN
THIS --
MEETS OR EXCEEDS ALL THE
STANDARDS THAT ARE CURRENTLY IN
EXISTENCE ISN'T EXPANDERS.
THERE'S CPUC STANDARD YOUR ORDER
NINETY FIVE IS A CAL FIRE
STANDARD SO WE EXCEED ALL THOSE
EXISTING STANDARDS AND IF THE
STATE DOES ELECTED CHANGER
STRENGTHENING STANDARDS WILL
CONTINUE TO MEET OR EXCEED THOSE
STANDARDS AS WELL.
WE HAVE A MAIN WE MAINTAIN A
DATABASE OVER FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND TREES THAT SIXTEEN FROM
POLAND'S VALLEY ACTUALLY MODEL
BASIN THE BOTHER OF MOST MODEL
BASIN.
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO SAN PEDRO.
WE HAVE A YEAR ROUND TRAINING
CYCLE BETWEEN OUR OWN CREWS AND
CONTRACT CREWS WHERE WE FOLLOW
THIS MEASURE PRACTICES FROM THE
SOCIETY OF MUNICIPAL ARBORISTS
TO MAKE SURE WE TRIM TREES
PROPERLY ALONG THE ENTIRE RIGHT
OF WAYS FOR A FOR OUR
POWERLINES.
WE ACTUALLY TRIM ABOUT A HUNDRED
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND TREES
ANNUALLY IN SPENT ABOUT TWENTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR JUST
ON TREAT.
AND ALL THE TREE TRIMMING AND
THERE'S A QUESTION BEFORE ABOUT
WHO INSPECTS A TREE TRIMMING WE
HAVE CERTIFIED --
LINE CLEARANCE ARBORISTS ON
STAFF THAT INSPECT ALL THE WORK
BOTH BY OUR CREWS AND BY PRIVATE
TO MAKE IT A HOT* CREWS. ONE
ISSUE WE DO SEE IS TREES AND
PRIVATE PROPERTY THAT ARE
OUTSIDE OF OUR RIGHT AWAY.
THAT MAYBE HAVE GROWN LARGEST
CROWNS --
STATE SHE'D GIVEN THE WAY YEAR
WE HAD A COUPLE YEARS AGO BUT
HAVE BAD WE CAN ROOT OLD ROOTS.
AND SO THE POTENTIAL THOSE TO
FALL INTO OUR RIGHT AWAY IS AN
ISSUE AND LOOKING AT HOW WE GET
ON THE PRIVATE PROPERTY IS A
CHALLENGE FOR US IN SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO TACKLE THIS
TIME.
LAST YEAR WHEN THE FOCUS LIMIT
ON OF WE'RE DOING FOR RESILIENCY
PLANNING.
A WE ARE IMPLEMENTING --
MORE SMART GRID TECHNOLOGY AND
DESTRUCTION AUTOMATION WE HAVE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF VISIBILITY OF
OUR SYSTEM NOW BUT NO WE'RE
WE'RE WE'D LIKE TO BE WE KNOW
THAT IN FIVE TO TEN YEARS WILL
HAVE MUCH GREATER CONTROL OVER
SYSTEM.
WE DO HAVE AUTOMATICALLY CLOSERS
ON A CERTAIN NUMBER OF ARTISTRY
XIN LINES BOMB BUT THOSE ARE
CLOSE OUR INSTITUTIONS.
AND WE ALSO ARE RUDE EVALUATING
HOW OFTEN THOSE SHOULD BE USED
BUT TYPICALLY ARE CLOSURES ACT
ABOUT TWENTY ONE TIMES A WEEK.
NONE OF THESE OF EVER CAUSE A
FIRE BUT IF WE DID NOT HAVE A
MAC TO AUTOMATICALLY THE V.
TWENTY ONE MORE POWER OUTAGES WE
CAN THE WAY OUR SYSTEM IS SET
UP.
A LOT OF TIMES EASIER CLOSURES
HAPPEN ON THE VALLEY FLOOR SOME
THE CIRCUITS REGION OF THE HILLS
FULLY HAPPEN IN AREAS THAT ARE
VERY DENSELY POPULATED AND SERVE
A LOT OF PEOPLE.
BUT THEY DO NOT REALLY HOUSE IN
HIGH FIRE AREAS AND SO TRYING TO
SEPARATE OUT THE HIGH FAIR AREAS
FROM OTHER RESTLESS DID ISSUES
S. MISS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
WORKING ON AND WOOD THAT WOULD
AIM TOWARD IN THE FUTURE.
AND WE HAVE NO AUTOMATIC CLOSES
ON TRANSMISSION LINES SO THE
LINES AT TRAVEL THROUGH THE
WILDERNESS DO THEY GO OFF THEY
GO OFTEN SO WE ALWAYS PATROL
THOSE ADDRESS THE OURSELVES.
AND I'M GLAD I MEAN I'M SORRY IF
I COULD JUST INTERRUPT GETS A
SENATOR DODD HAD A QUESTION THEN
AFTER HE'S OUT HIS QUESTION IF
YOU COULD JUST TAKE.
MAYBE THIRTY SECONDS READINESS
THAT'S FINE OKAY A SUBSITE YES
ARE YOU GOING TO POINT OUT THAT
AND THEN OF LASSIE --
WE ARE WE ARE WORKING AT TO LAST
POINT -- WE
DO CONTINUE TO LOOK AT NEW
MATERIALS OF STEELPOLES ARE
MENTIONED NEVER TIMES TODAY
ABOUT THE USE OF STEEL POLES.
ONE OF THE ISSUE THE STEEL POLES
AT THE OF STEEL POLES YOU HAVE
TO TURN THE POWER OFF TO WORK ON
THEM.
THE AND CERTAIN AGENCIES HAVE NO
PROBLEM TURN THE POWER OFF ON
THE CUSTOMERS TO DO THE WORK WE
HAVE A POLICY TWENTY CUSTOMERS
IN POWER WE WORK HIGH.
ON A LOT OF OUR LINES AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE IN SO WE DO YOU STILL
POLLS WHERE WE THINK THERE'S A
PARTICULAR RISK WE DON'T USE IN
UNIVERSALLY BECAUSE A CUDDLE
BECAUSE GREATER POWER OUTAGES
MORE FREQUENTLY AS WE TRY TO DO
OUR WORK.
WELL SO USING THINGS AS PALMER
INSULATORS AS OPPOSED TO
PORCELAIN.
AND ALSO FAR LESS ARMS THINGS
ARE MORE RESILIENT IN THE NEW
PRODUCTS WERE TESTING ONLY
PRODUCTS COME ON THE MARKET LOOK
FOR THE PROPER APPLICATION.
BUT WERE ALWAYS CAREFUL TO MAKE
SURE WE LOOKED AT THE BLOW THE
PLUS AND THE MINUS SIDES OF ANY
OF THOSE.
ON THE LAST COUNT I WANT TO MAKE
IT A MAYES BECAUSE THERE'S TO
TALK ABOUT ABOUT RATES AND AND
EFFECTS OF ALL THIS BECAUSE I'M
OF FIRE PREVENTION.
FARK FIRE PROVISION OF FIRE
SAFETY AS WELL WORKER SAFETY
PUBLIC SAFETY IS ALL BAKED INTO
THE RAKES AND A BIG THAT OUR
EXPECTATION FOR WOULD WHAT WE DO
IS PART OF OUR JOBS.
I WE HAVE A VERY SOLID CREDIT
RATING AGAIN WHAT WE'VE HAD
HAPPEN IN FIRES IS NOT AFFECTED
THAT IT HAS AFFECTED OUR
INSURANCE COVERAGE.
WE'VE HAD LESS COVERAGE FOR MORE
MONEY AND WE SEE CHALLENGES IN
GETTING EVERYTHING THAT CAME UP
EARLIER ABOUT THE CHALLENGES OF
THE IN GOOD INSURANCE COVERAGE
--
BUT THE CERTAINLY A DISSIDENT
PART OF HOW WE OPERATE THE LAST
TEN YEARS SO IS IT IS PART OF
OUR PLAN FOR HOW WE OPERATOR
SYSTEM HOW WE BUILD OUR SYSTEM
AND HOW WE CHANGE OUR SYSTEM IN
THE FUTURE TO KEEP UP WITH
CURRENT WITH WHATEVER RISKS WERE
FACING.
SOURCE OF YEAH BUT OKAY SO --
YEAH YOU HEAR ABOUT INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES THAT IGNITING
FIRES YOU KNOW WE'VE WE SOUGHT
THE OUT.
LAST YEAR --
DON'T HEAR SO MUCH ABOUT
MUNICIPAL --
UTILITIES OR DO YOU KNOW.
SO I I GUESS MY HERB PUBLICLY
OWNED UTILITIES.
AT HOW MANY --
IGNITIONS HAVE YOU HAD FROM YOUR
POWER SYSTEM WITHIN THE LAST TEN
YEARS THAT THE ONLY ONE THAT I'M
AWARE OF IS THE POWERHOUSE FIRE
DO SOME DEBATE ABOUT.
EXACTLY THE CAUSE BUT THERE'S
SOME BELIEVE THAT ONE OF OUR
WIRES WENT DOWN ON ONE OF OUR
POWER PLANT.
AND AND THEN THAT WAS RE POWERED
BUT NOT BY AND AUTOMATICALLY
CLOSER AND THAT THAT MAY HAVE
IGNITED THE POWERHOUSE FIRE.
THERE'S SOME DEBATE ABOUT THAT
WE DETAIN INSURANCE CLAIM ON
THAT.
OKAY SO THEN THEN THE NEXT QUICK
QUESTION BECAUSE WE ARE MOVE OUT
OF PUBLIC COMMENT QUICKLY --
IS WHEN THAT HAPPENED TO PAYS.
WHEN THAT HAPPENS WE PAID
INSURANCE DEDUCTIBLE ARE
RETIREMENT ARE INSURANCE
COVERAGE PAID?
ROUGHLY A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ON THAT.
BUT THEN WE CAME BACK FOR
INSURANCE NEXT YEAR INSURANCE
WENT UP FROM THE BLUE TWENTY
MILLIONS TO THE MID THIRTY
MILLIONS.
AND ARE COVERAGE REDUCED BY
ABOUT SIXTY FIVE SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS OF WHAT WAS AVAILABLE TO
US SO.
ULTIMATELY.
THERE IS A SLIGHT COSTS
INCREASED THE RATE PAYER THERE'S
MORE RISK EXPOSURE TO THE RATE
PAYERS [inaudible]
JUST [inaudible]
ALL OF WHEN THERE IS A FIRE
DISCOUNT FIRE COME AND
INVESTIGATE.
HE IT DEPENDS ON WHERE THE FIRE
IS SADDAM IF WE HAVE A FIRE SO
THE POWERHOUSE FIRE THEY JUST
MENTION.
CORD ON THE ACTUALLY IN THE
ANGELES NATIONAL FORCE WAS
OUTSIDE THE CITY A POWER PLANTS
ALONG ARE ACCURATE COMMITTEE AND
SO HELLFIRE WOULD INVOLVE WITH
THAT.
THE END WOULD HAVE DONE
INVESTIGATION TYPICAL FIRES THAT
WE MIGHT SEE AND THAT MAY AFFECT
US.
WOULD BE IN THE CITY AND SO LA
CITY FIRE WOULD YOU TAKE THE
LEAD ON THOSE SORTS OF THINGS.
SCRUBBING THE FLOORS.
GOOD AFTERNOON --
DESPITE WAY THAT TILBURG IS ONE
OF THE SMALLEST APPEAR USE
PRETTY VIOS SOME PERCEPTION OF
IT -- WE ARE
SMALL --
PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITY BUT OUR
AGENCY WHICH IS A COLLECTIVE OF
SIXTEEN PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITIES
THROUGHOUT NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND SO WE DO SHARE A LOT OF
INFORMATION BETWEEN --
EACH OF THE MEMBERS OF ANTI QUE
--
FOR HILLS FOR EXPLICITLY WE HAVE
FOUR SQUARE MILES VERY SMALL
SERVER TERRITORY BUT SIXTY MILES
OF LINE WITHIN THAT SIR TOWARDS
APPARENTLY DANCE.
WE DO HAVE OVERHEAD LINES THAT
RUN THROUGH ELEVATED AREAS OF
FIRE RISK --
EVEN THOUGH --
SMALL PEEL YOU WE HAVEA VERY
HIGH SYSTEM RELIABILITY SO WE
HAVE A VERY VERY LOW FREQUENCY
OF POWER OUTAGES AND THAT'S DO A
LARGELY TO OUR MAINTENANCE SO.
ONE OF THE THINGS WE DO --
FOR MITIGATION --
ANNUALLY WE TRIM OUR TREES SO WE
DON'T PICK SECTIONS AND SAY
EVERY THREE YEARS WE'RE GONNA
VISIT THAT SECTION BASED ON
GROWTH WE LOOK AT OURS TIRE
SYSTEM EACH YEAR.
SPECIFICALLY FOR TREE TRIMMING
WE REQUIRE THE CLEARANCE FROM A
CONTRACTOR TO BE A MINIMUM OF
FOUR FEET SO TYPICALLY THAT
MEANS THEY TAKE SOME FEET OF
CLEARANCE FROM THE WIRES --
THEY TAKE ADDITIONAL CLEARANCE
FOR WIRE SAS TO THE COMEDY WHAT
HAPPENS DURING HEAVY LOADING OR
HIGHER TEMPERATURES OF THE WIRE
--
WE DO WORK WITH PROPERTY OWNERS
HAVE REMOVE TREES THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY BLOW INTO THE LINES
FROM OUTSIDE THE RIGHT OF WAYS
ON THAT TAKE SOME WILLINGNESS TO
PROPERTY OWNERS BUT THAT'S A
CONVERSATION THAT WE CAN HAVE
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY.
COME WITH THE TO PROACTIVELY RE
CONDUCTOR --
OUR LINES REBUILD AIRLINES SO WE
LOOK AT WE CONDUCTORS ARE
POTENTIALLY HAVE THE RISK OF
FALLING DOWN DURING HIGH WINDS.
WE CONDUCTED THOSE REBUILD THOSE
BEFORE THEIR END OF LIFE --
WE ALSO LOOK AT SPACING
REQUIREMENTS SPREAD THOSE OUT
THAT HELPS --
WITH THE FACE TO FACE --
CONTACT.
THEM WE ALSO LOOK AT WHAT WAS
MENTIONED BY THE REALLY PALE THE
CAO FIRES RECOMMENDATION FOR
SUBJECT POLLS OR OR CERTAIN
TYPES OF EQUIPMENT THAT
POTENTIALLY SHOULD BE CHANGED
OUT FOR OTHER EQUIPMENT THAT ARE
MORE COMPATIBLE WITH THE WILD
AND URBAN AREAS --
AND AGAIN WE DO VISUAL
INSPECTIONS FOR GEO ONE SIXTY
FIVE WE DO THE DETAILS TAXES FOR
ONE PIC --
SIXTY FIVE WE REALLY LOOK AT THE
GEO NINETY FIVE STANDARDS ONE
SIXTY FIVE AS A MINIMUM
STANDARD.
AND WE LOOK TO EXCEED THOSE
WHERE WE CAN.
COME AND WE ALSO CONSIDER BEST
PRACTICES OF THE FEATHER
UTILITIES SO.
FUTURE ACTIONS AND IN THIS FALLS
INTO THIS RANGE OF SHARING OF
INFORMATION WE ARE LOOKING AT
REFLECT DAYS CUTTING OUT RE
CLOSING --
TO AVOID THAT RISK AND WE DON'T
FEEL.
WE WE THINK WE CAN JUST CUT
THOSE OUT AND TAKE THE RISK OF
POTENTIALLY HAVING SUSTAINED
OUTAGES --
WE'RE LOOKING AT STAFFING --
NO SONNY.
NO I I TURN MY PHONE OFF IN VERY
EARLY IN THIS CONFERENCE TO
AVOID THAT.
SOMEONE WANTS WANTS YOU TO WRAP
UP.
MAYBE THAT'S THAT'S THE MUSIC.
THAT'S THE MUSIC --
OKAY SO. FOR EXPEDIENCY --
SO WE DO LOOK AT THOSE WOULD
LOOK AT A STAFFING AND AGAIN YOU
KNOW LOOKING OLD BEST.
IS THAT ARE COMING FOR ITS OR
CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR TO BECAUSE
IT THIS IS A NEW NORMAL --
WE CAN'T DO THE SAME OLE SAME
OLE SO WE'RE LOOKING AT A NEW
WAY TO OPERATE OR UTILITY IN
ADOPTING THE S. TECHNOLOGIES.
ONE THING I WOULD SAY IS THAT
WHAT WORKS FOR LA WHAT WORKS FOR
PGD MAY NOT BE THE RIGHT FIT FOR
SMALL PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITY.
I MEAN WITHIN FOUR SQUARE MILES
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE NEED TO FLY
DRONES AROUND OUR TOWN.
I THINK WE CAN SEND OUR GUYS
HUMANS OUT THERE TO LOOK AT OUR
LINES AND I THINK THAT'S
PROBABLY OF THERE'S A BENEFIT
THERE.
BUT THE PUBLIC SEES HUMANS ON
THE GROUND WORKING --
LOVE TECHNOLOGY BUT IT'S IS
THERE IS A GOOD PLACE FOR AN
EXIT THERE'S ABOUT PLACE --
FOR ONE THINGS UNIQUE ABOUT
HILLS BURGERS WE ARE BOTH THE
PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITY AND WE
ARE A CUSTOMER OF THE INVESTOR
OWNED UTILITIES WE RECEIVE OUR
TRANSMISSIONS SERVICES FROM P.
GINNY SO WE'RE WORKING WITH PJ
NEED TO FIGURE OUT.
WHEN THEY DE ENERGIZE OUR TOWN
THEY'D DE ENERGIZE OUR
TRANSMISSION SERVICE WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN TO THE REST OF OUR
COMMUNITY?
SO WE LOSE ALL OF OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY FACILITIES WE LOSE ALL
OUR PUBLIC WATER.
WASTEWATER COLLECTION SYSTEMS WE
LOSE THE HOSPITAL HOW DO WE
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE SERVICE HOW
DO WE PROVIDE THAT PUBLIC
SERVICE TO OUR COMMUNITY.
DURING THOSE TYPES OF EVENTS AS
WELL AS LOOKING AT THE
CONTINGENCY OF PAY IF WE DID
HAVE A RED FLAG WARNING AND I
DID WANT TO GET ITS CONDITION OF
DE ENERGIZING WHAT DOES THAT
LOOK LIKE AND HOW DO WE NOTICE
OUR CUSTOMERS THERE.
SO IT'S VERY UNIQUE BUT THAT THE
BENEFIT IS --
I'M THE UTILITY TRACTOR I'M OVER
THE WATER MORE THE WASTEWATER
I'M OVER ELECTRIC AND SO I CAN
WORK WITH THOSE GUYS TO SAY HEY
WE NEED TO BUILD THE PLAN TO RUN
GENERATORS AROUND SO THAT.
WHEN THE SOLICITATIONS LOSE
POWER WE DON'T HAVE RAW SEWAGE
SPILLING INTO THE STREETS DURING
THE SO THAT?
AND IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT OUTAGES
UNDER TWELVE TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
DAY -- TWO
DAYS FIVE DAYS THAT'S A
SIGNIFICANT ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE
--
IN ALL THOSE NUANCES HAVE TO BE
REALLY THOUGHT ABOUT BECAUSE
THIS ONE SOLUTION MAY CREATE A
WHOLE HOST OF OTHER ISSUES --
BUT PUBLIC OWNS WORD WERE
SITUATED TO DO THOSE TO LOOK AT
THOSE SAYING SADDAM.
AGAIN LIKE SAID WORK CLOSELY
WITH FLEAS FIRE ON THE WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO NEED TO DO
TRAFFIC SIGNALS [inaudible]
VERY.
IT'S ABOUT HOW THAT WORKS --
AND AND ALSO THE CITY PROVIDE
SHELTER FOR BOTH.
EVENTS THAT HAPPENED INSIDE THE
CITY AS WELL AS OUTSIDE THE CITY
AND SEWER LOOK AT THAT SITUATION
IS OKAY IF WE DO GET INTO THESE
DINNERS AND ADVANCE.
WHAT STE TYPE OF SERVICES DO WE
NEED TO PROVIDE IN OUR PREPARED
TO PROVIDE THOSE ITH AND
WITHOUT POWER?
SO --
WITHOUT IT WOULD OPEN IT UP FOR
THE QUESTIONS.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OF OUR
PANEL.
MISTER WOOD DISK A MINUTE I
SHASTA WHEN QUESTION THAT MISTER
OF SENATOR CANNELLA OUR PAST AND
DO YOU HAVE ISSUES WITH DO YOU
HAVE CHALLENGES IN GETTING
PERMISSION TO DO --
YET HE STRUGGLES WITH OUR
AGENCIES AT THE STATE LEVEL THAT
MAKE IT HARD FOR YOU TO DO.
YOUR WHILE FIRE MITIGATION WORK.
TO DO WE DON'T HILLS FOR DOESN'T
HAVE LANCE THROUGH FEDERAL LANDS
OUR STATE LANDS WE DON'T HAVE
THOSE CHANNELS IS WE'RE REALLY
FOCUSED ON WORKING WITH THE
PROPERTY OWNERS.
OF OUR IS USER MORE WITH FEDERAL
AGENCIES NOT TOO MUCH OF THE
STATE AGENCIES AND WE WILL GET
PERMITS BUT IS A MONTHS LONG
PROCESS TO DO WHAT SHE HE KNEW
PRETTY CLEAR.
AND AND I'D ECHO THAT THAT'S THE
U. S. FOR SERVICE AND WE COULD
USE SOME ASSISTANCE AND ARE.
EXPANDING RIGHT AWAY AND AND
FUEL LOADING IN AND FOR AND HE
WAS.
IN FEDERAL FORESTS ARE US FORCES
--
IT'S BE ITS MAJOR PROBLEM AND WE
AND WE HAVE A DIFFICULT TIME
GETTING THEIR ATTENTION IN
GETTING THEM GETTING ACTION.
THANK YOU SEEN OTHER QUESTIONS
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING A PART
OF THIS CONVERSATION TODAY AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO IF WE NEED --
TO CIRCLING BACK AROUND WITH
UNIT WITH ANY PARTICULAR FOLLOW
UPS GO AGAIN THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE AND NOW.
A TURN THE PUBLIC COMMENT
SECTION OVER TO SENATOR DODD
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH WE'RE
GONNA GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT.
I WE SAW THERE WAS MAYBE HALF A
DOZEN --
SPEAKERS WE'RE GONNA GIVE A
MINUTE EACH I'M SORRY HOPEFULLY
YOU CAN GET YOUR POINT ACROSS TO
US AND Y..
AND THEN ALSO WE WILL ACCEPT
EVERYTHING ANY ABOUT.
OF PAPERWORK OR ANYTHING
COMMENTS IN WRITING AS WELL.
PROCEED SIR RICHARD PIERCE FIRE
CHIEF THE TO RUN FAR DISTRICT
REPRESENTING OUT CAL CHIEFS FIRE
DISTRICTS AND METRO CHIEFS --
EVERYTHING YOU SAID TODAY WAS
NEAR AND DEAR TO OUR HEARTS AS
YOU KNOW A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
--
AS A LARGE PORTION OF PART
PORTION RESPONDED TO THE
INCIDENTS WE AGREE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KEEP THESE
INCIDENTS SMALL.
AND THE BEST WAY TO DO THAT IS
TO IMPROVE COMMUNICATION IMPROVE
NOTIFICATION AND AND ARE A
POSITION OF PRE POSITIONING
RESOURCES --
AS WE USE TECHNOLOGY MOVING
FORWARD WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
OURSELVES AVAILABLE IF YOU CRAFT
YOUR LEGISLATION TO PROVIDE ANY
EXPERTISE WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO
HAVE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY SO THEE THERE'S WAY MORE
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE THAN WHAT
PEOPLE RAISE THEIR HAND.
SO HERE'S THE DEAL WHAT I WHAT
THE COMMENTS LIMITED TO WAS WHAT
WE DISCUSSED HERE TODAY IF YOU
WANT TO DISCUSS ANYTHING ELSE
BESIDES THAT WILL HAVE A HEARING
--
ON THAT AND LET'S KEEP IT TIGHT
PLEASE XP CURVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON STACEY HE RURAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA REALLY APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION AND COMMENTS THIS
AFTERNOON.
ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE A HOWEVER
A SMALL PIECE OF THE WILD FIRE
PREPAREDNESS AND PREVENTION
DISCUSSION AND WE HAVE A MUCH
LARGER PROBLEM ENFORCED HEALTH
AND RESILIENCE AND MANAGEMENT IN
CALIFORNIA AND YOU'RE GOING TO
BE GETTING A LETTER WITH OUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT.
WITHIN THE NEXT FEW DAYS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT.
I BLANCA CASTRO WITH AARP
CALIFORNIA I JUST WANNA FOR
SMALL SAY THANK YOU FOR TALKING
ABOUT SAFETY AND MITIGATION
PLANS --
I'VE HEARD A LOT FROM THE
UTILITIES ABOUT ALL THE GREAT
WORK THAT THEY'RE ALREADY DOING
--
WHAT I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT JUST
REMIND EVERYBODY?
WE CANNOT DEPEND ON THE
RATEPAYERS ONLY TO BE PAYING FOR
ALL OF THE INFRASTRUCTURE
TECHNOLOGY AND MITIGATION THAT
HAS TO HAPPEN.
SO I JUST ASK YOU TO PLEASE
REMEMBER THAT YOU HAVE PEOPLE
WHO ARE ON FIXED INCOME.
AND SO SIXTY DOLLARS A MONTH MAY
NOT SEEM A LOT BUT THEN YOU
INCREASE THAT WITH A FIXED
INCOME IT DOES IMPACT THEM.
SO PLEASE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND AND REMEMBER THE GREAT PAIRS
THANK YOU NEXT.
OUR CHILDREN JIM FINNIGAN
VOLUNTEER WITH AIR P. --
WE WOULD WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS OF THE UTILITY
COMPANIES ABOUT PLANNING A
MITIGATION.
THE KEY QUESTION I HAVE IS WHO
PAYS FOR THAT THEY SHOULD BE
ACCOUNTABLE FOR DOING IT BUT NOT
THE RATEPAYERS THANK YOU.
WE CAN A ALL RETIRED BATTALION
CHIEF FOR CAL FIRE --
I REALLY LIKED HILLS BERG
[inaudible]
I MEAN.
THEY TRIM THE TREES.
IT WOULD YEAR RIGHT DOWN TO IT
GANG BESIDES ALL OF THE
OBFUSCATION.
IT'S REAL SIMPLE.
GET OUT TRIM THE TREES THEN YOU
WON'T YOU DON'T HAVE THE SPARK
AND YOU DON'T HAVE THE FIRE --
I'M HERE REPRESENTING CAN HAIL
NOT CAL FIRE BUT IF YOU GUYS
CREATED --
CAL FIRE ENFORCEMENT GROUP.
THAT ONE OUT AND ENFORCE THE LAW
VIGOROUSLY ENFORCE THE LAW YOU
WOULD HAVE A MAJOR IMPACT.
THANKS THANKS MISTER HLE NEXT
SPEAKER POLICE OPERATION.
GOOD EVENING MEMBERS ROBERT
SPIEGEL CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION AND GENERALLY WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF APPROVING THE
SAFETY AND RELIABILITY OF OUR
UTILITY INFRASTRUCTURE AS THE
PRODUCTION OF OUR PERSONAL
PERISHABLE AT COMMODITIES DEPEND
ON A RELIABLE ACTUAL SERVICE
HOWEVER.
ANY COST OR ANY COST OF ANY
IMPROVEMENTS MUST BE BALANCED
BETWEEN THOSE UP PLACE ON
RATEPAYERS AND BOTH PAIR PAID BY
SHAREHOLDERS AS NEWPROCESSES
WERE DEVELOPED FOR IMPLEMENTING
PLANS RELATED TO HARDING UTILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
EXPENDITURES MUST BE EVALUATED
TO ENSURE THAT RATEPAYERS
BENEFIT AS MUCH AS SHAREHOLDERS
IN THIS PROCESS THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT PETER.
I CARE COSTS AT THE PERSONAL
INSURANCEFEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA I DO LOOK FORWARD TO
THURSDAY'S HEARING.
HOWEVER I JUST CAN'T LEAVE
UNADDRESSED THE STATEMENT THAT'S
MISLEADING THAT CALIFORNIA
ALABAMA ARE THE ONLY TWO STATES
HAVE INVERSE CONDEMNATION.
ALL STATES AND THE CONSTITUTION
HOW INVERSE CONDEMNATION IT'S
JUST THE CALIFORNIA HAS MUCH
MORE MUCH LARGER AND MORE
POWERFUL I USE AND FOR THAT
REASON THE STATE'S APART THE
STATE CUP CALIFORNIA'S
PRACTICALLY ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
THINK IT NOT SURPRISING CARE YOU
PROVIDE.
SO IT WAS A NATION THAT STUFF
JUST TEASING GO AHEAD.
THAT SPEAKER.
CATHERINE THOUGHT ABOUT AMERICAN
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION I'M I TO I
JUST WANTED TO COMMENT ON THE
THE PRESIDENT OF THE P. C.
COMMENTING ON THE INSURANCE
MARKET I'M SURE WE'LL HEAR MORE
ON THURSDAY BUT I I WOULD
COMPLETELY DISAGREE IN TERMS OF
COMMERCIAL AND ALL.
ALSO PRIVATE INSURANCE PARTAKE
YOU VERY MUCH.
JOHN MEMBERS JOHN OR WOULD IT
INDEPENDENT TURNS AGENTS AND
BROKERS SURPLUS LINES
ASSOCIATION OF THE CALIFORNIA
INSURANCE WHOLESALERS.
AND AGAIN ON THE COMMENT I JUST
WANTED TO REAL CONTEXT THERE'S
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS WORLDWIDE IN REASSURANCE
--
THERE'S ABOUT AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
CATASTROPHE BONDS AT ALTERNATIVE
INSURANCE PRODUCTS AVAILABLE TO
ALL BUSINESSES WORLDWIDE. TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WASN'T BIGGEST.
CATASTROPHE YEAR IN THE WORLD
HAS EVER SEEN THOSE
APPROXIMATELY.
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF DAMAGE.
ONLY A HUNDRED AND THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY BILLION OF THAT WAS
INSURED SO THAT LEAVES A NO
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY BILLION
DOLLARS JUST IN THE REINSURANCE
MARKET THAT WAS STILL AVAILABLE
PLUS THE ALTERNATIVE SOURCES.
MILLION OTHER COST MUCH HIGHER
YES BUT IT AVAILABLE IS OUT
THERE IS SOMETHING MAYBE YOU
WANT TO LOOK INTO FURTHER.
I'M BUT I JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU
THE CONTEXT OF THE MARKETPLACE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KURT JOHNSON SONG COMMUNITY
COLLEGE EDUCATIONAL FOUNDATION
AND IN MY PAST LIFE --
I HAD A THIRTY YEAR CAREER
MUNICIPAL PLANNING AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND BOTH THAT CAREER
PLUS A COLLEGE THE DISCUSSION
YOU HAD TODAY I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL THAT ACTUALLY LOOK
FORWARD.
AND A WHILE TRAGEDIES OF
HAPPENED IN THE PAST WE CAN MAKE
A DIFFERENCE IN THE FUTURE.
BUT ALSO --
FOR MY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
BACKGROUND I KNOW WASN'T
SPECIFICALLY BROUGHT UP TODAY
BUT RECOVERY BONDS ARE CRITICAL.
OF THE IDEA THAT WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE NEW STANDARDS OF
MAINTENANCE AND ACTUALLY.
WAYS TO PAY FOR IT THE DON'T
ADVERSELY IMPACT A RATE PRAYER
PIRES'S IS CRITICAL SO.
THANK YOU IT THANKS MISTER
JOHNSON IN FAIRNESS TO MISS
CROSS YOU YOU VIOLATED IT TOO
NEXT SPEAKER.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M DIANE ROGERS
AND PRESIDENT CEO THE RANCHO
CORDOVA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
AS A BUSINESS ORGANIZATION WE'RE
PAYING VERY CLOSE ATTENTION TO
THE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS OF OUR
MEMBERS WE CONSIDER THE COST OF
PROVIDING SERVICES THE IMPACT
THEY HAVE ON OUR ENVIRONMENT
RELIABILITY.
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY A WRETCH
ABOVE THE CALIFORNIA RANCHO
CORDOVA CANNOT PROVIDE THOSE
GOODS AND SERVICESREQUIRED BY
OUR FAMILIES SCHOOLS AND
SERVICES.
IF THOSE SERVICES ARE
UNRELIABLE.
STABLE UTILITIES ARE MUCH LIKE
THE ADAGE OF A RISING TIDE
RAISING ALL SHIPS WHEN SAFE
RELIABLE AND COST EFFICIENT
ENERGY SERVICES ARE PROVIDED
EVERY SECTOR OF THE ECONOMY AS
WELL OFF SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
SPEAKER.
GOOD AFTERNOON CARE MARTINSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES JUST
WANNA THANK YOU FOR THE
CONVERSATION TODAY AS WE REALLY
DO THINK.
THIS IS THE CRUX OF THE ISSUE
THAT THIS COMMITTEE CAN REALLY
FOCUS ON TO MAKE PROGRESS ON IN
THE NEXT THREE TO FOUR WEEKS OF
THE LEGISLATIVE SESSION.
I WON'T VIOLATE THE RULE LIKE MY
MY COUNTERPARTS TODAY BECAUSE WE
WILL HAVE OUR OPPORTUNITY ON
THURSDAY TO EXPRESS OUR
OPPOSITION.
A TO THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AN
INVERSE CONDEMNATION BUT I DID.
BUT I DID.
I DID WANT TO SAY THAT C. SECOND
BEEN VERY INVOLVED WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S TASK FORCE ON TREE
MORTALITY ON FORCE RESILIENCY
AND I WOULD CONCUR WITH MY THE
COMMENTS FROM THE THE RURAL
COUNTIES THAT THIS IS ONE
PORTION.
OF AN OVERALL LANDSCAPE ISSUE
THAT WE NEED TO BE FOCUSED ON
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
CONVERSATION TO AYE THANK YOU.
RETURN MEMBERS I'M AARON EVANS
ON BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES I WOULD JUST
ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY MY
COLLEAGUE AT C. SACKED.
AND ALO OUT OUR THANKS TO THIS
CONVERSATION AND URGE YOU TO
CONTINUE THE FOCUS ON SAFETY AND
PREVENTION.
PARTICULARLY AS OUR STATE IS ONE
SIX THEIR LARGE SWATHS OF THE I
THINK YOU YOU.
ANY FIVE THE WITH THE CHINESE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION OF SOLANO
COUNTY.
OF AND THANK YOU FOR THIS
CONVERSATION A SAFE AND RELIABLE
ELECTRIC GRID IS CRITICAL IN
CREATING JOBS CONTRIBUTING TO
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA ECONOMY AND
SERVING OR LOCAL COMMUNITIES.
SO THANK YOU [inaudible]
YOU -- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE LARA KNOWING HE
TOOK ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
CITRUS MUTUAL CALIFORNIA
CONGENERS IN GROWERS ASSOCIATION
WESTERN ART PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION YOU SEE FARMERS
LEAGUE AND VARIOUS OTHER OUTSIDE
--
INDUSTRY'S ALWAYS RATE PAYERS
THE FOURTEEN SECONDS ALREADY WAS
JUST THE NAMES GO AHEAD I COULD
I GIVE YOU MARK.
A WE JUST WANT TO REMIND THE
COMMITTEE --
DIED REPAIRS ARE THE ONES PAYING
FOR THESE INVESTMENTS SO WHEN I
USE ARE SITTING UP HERE SAYING
THAT THEY'VE MADE INVESTMENTS IN
SAFETY THEY'VE MADE INVESTMENT
AND THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
THE RATE PAYERS PAYING FOR THOSE
COSTS AND WE DON'T WE THINK
MOVING FORWARD THIS COMMITTEE
SHOULD EVALUATE.
HOW THE SHAREHOLDERS CAN ALSO
SHARE IN THAT COST IS NOT ON THE
RATE PAYERS? ONE WAY TO
SPECIFICALLY DO THAT IT IS --
THROUGH AUDITING WHAT'S
HAPPENING OVER AT THE DO YOU SEE
WHEN IT COMES TO THESE PLANS
[inaudible]
IF -- IF THE
THESE PLANS ARE APPROVED AT THE
P. YOU SEE AND THE UTILITIES ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE IMPLEMENTING WILD
FIRE.
MITIGATION MEASURES AND HURTING
THE SYSTEM AND DON'T DO THAT
WITH THE FUNDS RATE PAYERS HAVE
GIVEN AND THEN THESE BIG FIRES
HAPPEN WE DON'T THINK RATE PAIR
SHOULD BE ON THE HOOK FOR PAYING
FOR HARDING NOT SYSTEM IF
THEY'VE ALREADY PAID ON THE BACK
AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE CO CHAIRMAN A CITY --
MICHAEL SAW CALIFORNIA MANY
FACTORS IN TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM THE FARM
BUREAU -- OR
A LITTLE BIT EARLIER THAT --
BOOTH RATEPAYERS SHAREHOLDERS IN
THE STATE ALL PARTICIPATE AND
THIS A LOT IN LIKE IN
MAINTAINING ELECTRIC RID --
THERE FOR ALL PARTIES UNITY DID
SHARE THAT RESPONSIBILITY ING I
SPECIFICALLY INCLUDE THE STATE
IN THAT DISCUSSION.
REDUCING THE FIRE RISK REDUCES
THE RISK OF RELEASE OF CARBON SO
ISSUES SUCH AS A GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND MIGHT BE AN
APPROPRIATE SOURCE OF REVENUE
FOR HELPING TO ADDRESS OUT THAT
WOULD HELP MITIGATE THICK
INCREASE COST --
TO RATEPAYERS SHAREHOLDERS ALL
IT IT FROM INVESTMENTS IN THAT
SYSTEM AND THEREFORE SHOULD ALSO
BE AT THE TABLE --
IT RATHER THAN JUST ALL THE
PRESSURE FALLING TO REPAIRS ON
THAT THANK YOU YOU.
SIR YOU IN THE LINE RIGHT NOW
BACK YOU IN THE BASIN.
NO NO I I DON'T CARE IF YOU ARE
NOT THAT'S THE LAST BEAKER NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON
NOT YOUR HERNANDEZ A MAY HAVE OF
TURN.
I ADVOCATES FOR RATEPAYERS --
I ALSO WANT TO JUST COMMENT ON
THE RATE PAYER A COMPONENT OF
PAIN FOR SAFETY PREVENTION IS AS
MENTIONED EARLIER BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ARE YOU CAN SPEND OF
RICHARD PAYER MONEY.
WE EXPECT BILLIONS MORE WILL BE
SPEND THE NEXT FEW YEARS BECAUSE
OF THAT IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WHATEVER.
EYES ADOPTED BY THE CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE SHOULD REALLY I'M HAVE
A PROCESS THAT PROTECTS
RATEPAYERS --
AND WE THINK THAT --
THE DIRECTION THAT THE CPC HAS
BEEN GOING AS FAR GENERAL USING
GENERATE CASES IS REALLY GOOD
DIRECTION AGO WE ALSO BELIEVE --
GOOD DIRECTION THAT THE GOVERNOR
PUT HIS PROPOSED REGARDING THE
SAFETY AD AND PREVENTION
EXPENDITURES TO HAVE A MORE
HOLISTIC APPROACH MAKING SURE
THAT THE MONEY IS WELL SPENT AND
SPENT IN WAY THAT WILL BE
EFFECTIVE.
AND ALSO PROTECT RATEPAYERS WE
THINK IT GOES IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION THAT PIECE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL SO WE URGE
YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT THAT.
WE WILL HAVE SOME SUGGESTIONS ON
PERHAPS THE ON THAT PIECE
PARTICULAR THANKS SIR.
HELLO MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MADDIE DUNLAP
ON BEHALF OF THE AGRICULTURAL
ENERGY CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION.
YOU JUST OUTLINED OUR COMMNTS
WITH OUR COLLEAGUES FROM THE AG
INDUSTRY AND CMT IN RESPECT TO
THEIR COSTS APPORTIONMENT OF
THIS ISSUE.
AND IS ADVOCATE THAT WE HAVE A
VERY HOLISTIC CONVERSATIONS WE
HAVE BEEN IN THESE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS AND WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE.
AND MAKE SURE THAT IT'S NOT JUST
A PIECEMEAL APPROACH TO SOLVING
THIS ISSUE OF THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
TARA MEMBERS MIGHT MATTER
CONSUMER WATCHDOG IS WANTED TO
SAY WITHOUT BEING REDUNDANT ONE
THIS IS A FAR BIGGER
CONVERSATION THE WAY WE'RE DOING
HERE.
SO CONVERSATIONS THAT'S CAN
INCLUDE EVERYBODY THAT DEALS
WITH --
PREPAREDNESS RESPONSIBILITY AND
THEN ENFORCEMENT.
THIS ALSO IS A CONVERSATIONS CAN
REQUIRE FOLKS LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER COMING TO GET
INVOLVED IN SOMETHING LIKE THIS
AND THOSE OF US WHO HAVE HAD.
A LONG HISTORY OF DEALING WITH
FIRES IN THE WOODLAND AND HUMAN
AREAS IN THE CONFLICT AND WHAT
WE'VE DONE IN THE REST OF THE
UNITED STATES AND AUSTRALIA AND
OTHER COUNTRIES.
THIS IS NOT SOME IS GOING TO BE
DISSOLVED AND IT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT SHOULD REQUIRE A GET OUT OF
JAIL FREE CARD FOR PGA NAY IT'S
A BIG DISCUSSION WE LOOK FOR TO
THE CONTINUING THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
THAT CONCLUDES THE THE BUSINESS
OR THIS COMMITTEE TODAY I WANT
TO THANK --
THOSE PEOPLE THAT --
HAVE HUNG IN HERE TODAY WITH --
WITH THAT'S ALL THE DIFFERENT
SPEAKERS APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
ATTACH AND YOU WE HAD A CAT A
MOVE THIS THING ALONG.
A BUT I THINK WHAT WE DID IS ALL
OF US AND I THINK ALL THE
MEMBERS FOR HANG AROUND.
OF THIS LONG IT'S WHAT HAPPENS
MOST THE TIME IN COMMITTEE
HEARINGS YOU'LL SEE MEMBERS COME
AND GO AND I THANK YOU ALL VERY
VERY MUCH.
FOR HANG IN THERE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
OKAY SO WORD OF THIS MEETING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU